तो आई [गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़] थिंक आई
एम लाइव नाउ।
एक बार सभी लोग बता दीजिए फटाफट इफ आई एम
लाइव।
गुड इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग। नमस्ते। नमस्ते
टू एवरीबॉडी। प्लीज लेट मी नो गाइस।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] इफ आई
एम ऑडिबल एंड विज़िबल क्लियर। एक बार सभी
लोग बता दीजिए। ऑडियो वीडियो बिल्कुल सही
जा रही है। परफेक्ट जा रही है।
एवरीवन प्लीज
लेट मी नो फास्ट फास्ट ऑल वर्किंग फाइन
कोई प्रॉब्लम तो नहीं है ऑडियो वीडियो में
एकदम क्रिस्टल क्लियर ऑडियो क्रिस्टल
क्लियर वीडियो सब कुछ परफेक्ट
आज एक शानदार टॉपिक स्टार्ट कर रहे हैं हम
आपके एसओसी और एसओसी के इस ट्रेनिंग को
खत्म करने की तरफ आगे बढ़ रहे हैं धीरे
धीरे-धीरे हम काफी मजेदार होने वाला है आज
का सेशन। जैसा मैंने पहले ही बताया कि
लinिक्स के टॉपिक हैं जो हम स्टार्ट कर
रहे हैं आज। काफी मजा आएगा। जो लोग लinx
के एनवायरमेंट से ऑलरेडी फमिलियर हैं उनको
भी मजा आएगा। जो लोग नहीं है उनको भी
बिल्कुल सीखने को मिलेगा क्योंकि बिल्कुल
स्क्रैच से मैं बताऊंगा सब कुछ।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
गुड इवनिंग। नमस्ते। नमस्ते। नमस्ते टू
एवरीबॉडी। गुड इवनिंग टू एवरीबॉडी।
नहीं नहीं भाई कॉमिया सिक्योरिटी प्लस
जरूरी है एसओसी के लिए नहीं देखो ऐसा कुछ
नहीं है कि जरूरी है कुछ ऐसा ऐसा कुछ भी
नहीं है अगर तुम करते हो दैट्स योर चॉइस
राइट ऐसा कुछ नहीं है कि हां एकदम उसके
बिना आप एसओसी नहीं बन सकते ऐसा कुछ नहीं
है एसओसी एल1 बनना है तो ये वाली
डिफ्रॉनिक्स की प्लेलिस्ट फॉलो कर लो बहुत
है काफी है इतना ही काफी है यही जरूरी है
और तो कुछ जरूरी भी नहीं है
नमस्ते भाई भाई नमस्ते। नमस्ते नमस्ते
नमस्ते।
चलिए। तो आज की क्लास को हम शुरू करते
हैं। काफी लोग यहां पे हमारे साथ आ चुके
हैं। ये मुझे बड़ा अच्छा लगता है ना कि
लगभग 50 लोग तो डेफिनेटली हैं जो इस सीरीज
को अभी तक फॉलो कर रहे हैं। एंड इस बात की
खुशी भी है। हालांकि इस बात का दुख है कि
इतने लोगों के होने के बाद भी सिर्फ 50
लोग ही यहां पे प्रेजेंट रहते हैं। बट इस
बात की खुशी है कि इतने टाइम के बाद भी वह
50 लोग अभी भी राइट नाउ आल्सो दे आर
करेंटली फॉलोइंग दिस लाइव क्लासेस लाइव
सेशन लाइव क्लासेस की मैं बात कर रहा हूं।
चलिए अच्छी बात है। अच्छा लगा देख के।
ओके।
ओके ओके ओके ओके ओके ओके
नाउ लेट्स बिगिन उसके पहले
एक सेकंड रुक जाइए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
चलिए ठीक है सो वी आर गुड टू को
ये अच्छा लगता है। आप लोग कम से कम 50 लोग
भी रहते हैं तो इट्स गुड। यू आर टीचिंग
ग्रेट सर। यू आर टीचिंग ग्रेट सर। थैंक यू
वेरी मच। आई एम ग्लैड दैट यू आर लविंग माय
टीचिंग। ऐसे ही पढ़ते रहिए। ऐसे ही और
चीजें लेते आएंगे। अच्छा मुझे आप सब से एक
इनपुट चाहिए। एक रिव्यु चाहिए आप सब से। अ
वो मुझे आप सभी लोग बता दीजिए।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़] अगर हम एक और
नेक्स्ट एसओसी जब खत्म कर दे उसके बाद की
बात है। एसओसी खत्म करने के पहले नहीं
करेंगे। टेंशन नहीं लेना आपको। एसओसी खत्म
जब हम कर दें उसके बाद आप में से जितने
लोग हैं सभी लोग रिप्लाई कीजिएगा। वह आपके
लिए मैं पूछ रहा हूं। आप कौन सी ऐसी
ट्रेनिंग चाहते हैं इसके बाद जो हम आपके
लिए फ्री और बहुत ही क्वालिटी ट्रेनिंग
लेकर आए। बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट लेकर आए।
जो एक्चुअली आपके लिए प्रोडक्टिव हो। जो
आप आपके लिए एक्चुअली जरूरी हो। ऐसा कुछ
भी मत बोल देना। कुछ भी मत बोल देना कि सर
हमें यह मशीन लर्निंग सिखा दो। उसका कोई
बेनिफिट आपको नहीं है जब तक कि आप उस
फील्ड में उस डोमेन में एक्चुअली पहले से
नहीं रिसर्च कर रहे हैं, नहीं काम कर रहे।
तो आप एक बेसिक कुछ ऐसा बताओ कि जो
अ ग्रुप ऑफ जो लर्नर्स हैं या वाइड रेंज
ऑफ लर्नर्स हैं उनके लिए भी यूज़फुल हो।
सिर्फ अपना मत सोचना। एक वाइड रेंज ऑफ़
पब्लिक के लिए ऑडियंस के लिए जो थोड़ी सी
अच्छी हो उनके लिए यूज़फुल हो वो मुझे
बताओ। देखो ऐसी कोई ऐसी ट्रेनिंग मत बोलो
जो ऑलरेडी हमारी पेड ट्रेनिंग चलती हो।
वीएपीटी की हमारी पेड एक जॉब ओरिएंटेड
ट्रेनिंग चलती है तो उसका आपको यहां पे
फ्री क्लासेस आपको तो नहीं मिलेगा ना ऐसे
आने ऐसे आके हां वीडियोस के वाइज वैसे मैं
लाके आपको बताया करूंगा लेकिन फ्री पूरी
सीरीज नहीं ला सकता वो पॉसिबल ही नहीं है
उसकी ऑलरेडी पेड बैच चलती है कुछ और बताओ
वीआईपीटी को वीआईपीटी को छोड़ो कुछ और
बताओ कुछ कुछ और आपको नहीं आता दिमाग में
कुछ और कोई और टॉपिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी
इतनी बड़ी है
एसओसी [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] एल2 और L3
की पेड बैच आने वाली है। L1 आपको पढ़ा दिया
है। L2, L3 में ऐसा रिस्क नहीं ले सकता
भाई। L1 में यह हाल है। 50 लोग भी सही से
नहीं आ पाते। अभी तो आज तो 70 के आसपास आ
गए हैं। पता नहीं। बट स्टिल
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओसीन ट्रेनिंग नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी
क्रिप्टोग्राफी नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
एक पागल बोल रहा है डीसीसीआई गजब पागल लोग
हैं यार मतलब मारना पड़ेगा जानते हैं कि
पेड ट्रेनिंग है वह फिर भी यहां पर टाइम
पास कर रहे हैं चलो और रेड टीमिंग रेड टीम
क्रिप्टोग्राफी क्लाउड सिक्योरिटी
ओशियन क्लाउड सिक्योरिटी लाइव में ट्राई
हैक मी हैक द बॉक्स स्पोर्ट्स स्वीगर ब्लू
टीम लैब सॉल्व करो सो समवन इज़ सेइंग लाइव
में सीटीएफ वगैरह करो यह अच्छा एक आईडिया
लगा मुझे दिस आईडिया इज गुड प्रीटी गुड टू
मी
प्रीटी गुड टू मी दिस आईडिया लाइव में जो
आपने बोला चलो अच्छी बात है
यहां पर काफी सारे लोगों के रिस्पांस
मैंने देखा एनआईएसटी फ्रेमवर्क
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
क्लाउड कंप्यूटिंग
हर हर महादेव भाई हाउ मेनी लेक्चर्स आर
रिमेनिंग फॉर एसओसी अभी थोड़े बहुत बचे
हैं हो जाएंगे टेंशन मत लो टेंशन मत लो एक
एक महीना और रुक जाओ हो जाएंगे पूरा
कंप्लीट
अ ओके [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
क्लाउड सिक्योरिटी मत फ्रेमवर्क ओके ठीक
है काफी लोगों के सजेशन है थैंक यू थैंक
यू वेरी मच फॉर द सजेशंस। आई विल सी कि
इनमें से कुछ चीजों को हम अप्लाई कर पाएं
और कुछ चीजों कुछ टॉपिक्स को हम लेकर आ
पाए फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट आपके लिए एंड आपको सिखा
पाए। सो बने रहिए टेंशन मत लीजिए। चलिए
हां बिफोर हां एक और चीज बिफोर वी स्टार्ट
मैं एक चीज और बताना चाहता हूं। हमारे
डेफ़on एकडमी के YouTube चैनल पे चले
जाइएगा आप सभी लोग। वीडियो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] सेक्शन में चले
जाइएगा। एंड यहां पे आपको एक जो वीडियो
मिलेगी बी अ रियल साइबर क्राइम
इन्वेस्टिगेटर। इस वीडियो को पूरा देख
लीजिएगा। हमारी एक डीसीसीआई यानी कि
डिफ्रॉनिक सर्टिफाइड साइबर क्राइम
इन्वेस्टिगेटर की जो लाइव ट्रेनिंग होती
है चार बैचेस कंप्लीट हो चुकी है। फिफ्थ
बैच जो है वो आने वाली है। 29 मई से
स्टार्ट हो रही है। 29th में वन वीक का
टाइम है। एनरोलमेंट स्टार्ट हो चुकी है।
अभी फर्स्ट 20 एनरोलमेंट के लिए ऑफर फी
है। आप सिंपली इसी वीडियो के जब वीडियो को
आप ओपन करेंगे यहां पे। मैं आपको बता देता
हूं कहीं आपको नया पता हो तो यहां पे एक
वेबिनार की भी लिंक है। जैसे कुछ दिन पहले
इसी साइबर क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन को लेके
एक डिटेल वेबिनार कंडक्ट करी गई थी। मैंने
वो वेबिनार होस्ट किया था। वहां पे आपको
रोड मैप बताया गया था। कैसे आप एक
इन्वेस्टिगेटर बन सकते हैं। कैसे लॉ
इनफोर्समेंट एजेंसीज या पुलिस डिपार्टमेंट
या गवर्नमेंट एजेंसीज या प्राइवेट फर्म्स
के साथ काम कर सकते हैं एज एन
इन्वेस्टिगेटर। तो वेबिनार की रिकॉर्डिंग
ये आप देख सकते हैं। इस पे क्लिक करेंगे।
वेबिनार की रिकॉर्डिंग यहां पे ओपन हो
जाएगी। यू कैन वॉच द फुल रिकॉर्डिंग। उसके
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] बाद यहां पे
ये वेबसाइट जो है एनरोलमेंट का है। इस पे
आप आएंगे तो एनरोलमेंट वाली लिंक पे आ
जाएंगे। यहां आएंगे तो यहां पे सिलेबस
डाउनलोड करके देख सकते हैं। पूरी डिटेल
स्क्रॉल कर लीजिएगा। पूरी डिटेल आप देख
लीजिएगा। सब कुछ आपको यहां पे मिल जाएगा।
नॉर्मली इसकी फी ₹15,000 लगभग होती है।
ऑफर में ₹9,000 में मिल रही है। टू टाइम्स
इंस्टॉलमेंट फी है। इनरोल नाउ वगैरह पे
क्लिक करके बटन पे आप इनरोलमेंट वाले पेज
पे जाके एनरोल करके आ सकते हैं। बट यही है
कि 29 मई से स्टार्ट हो रही है। वन वीक का
टाइम है। फर्स्ट 20 इनरोलमेंट्स के लिए
ऑफर फी है। तो ये बात मैंने आपको बता दी
है। अब आप जाइए देखिए एंड इसको यूटिलाइज
कीजिए। साथ ही में सबसे पहला काम आपको
करना है। किसी भी लाइव सेक्शन में जाना
है। एसओसी की कोई भी वीडियो आपने ओपन कर
लेनी है। एंड ओपन करने के बाद जब इसके
डिस्क्रिप्शन को एक्सपेंड करते हैं तो दो
लिंक्स आपको मिलती है। एक WhatsApp चैनल
का और एक WhatsApp ग्रुप का। तो WhatsApp
चैनल वाले लिंक पे जाएंगे तो डिफ़्रॉनिक्स
Academy करके WhatsApp चैनल का आपको लिंक
मिलेगा। इस पे आप आके हमें फॉलो कर
लीजिएगा। 13,000 से भी ज्यादा डिफरस्टर्स
इस चैनल को फॉलो करते हैं। इस चैनल पे
हमसे जुड़े हुए हैं। जितने भी अपडेट्स हैं
सबसे पहले हमारे WhatsApp चैनल पे आता है।
सबसे पहले कहीं भी और आपको नहीं मिलेगी।
कहीं भी कुछ नहीं पता चलेगा। वो WhatsApp
चैनल पे आपको पता चल जाएगा। तो इस पे आके
देख लीजिएगा। WhatsApp ग्रुप है जो एसओसी
के लिए स्पेशली बनाई गई है। इस एसओसी
ट्रेनिंग से रिलेटेड जितनी भी जानकारियां
हैं, रिसोर्सेज हैं, नोट्स हैं या अपकमिंग
जो भी इंटरव्यू प्रिपरेशन की चीजें होंगी,
सब कुछ जॉब्स के लिए अप्लाई हम करवाएंगे।
वो सब चीजों की इनफेशन इसी ग्रुप में
आएगी। तो एसओसी वाले इसको जरूर जॉइ
करिएगा। उसके बाद यह Lindin पे मेरी
प्रोफाइल है स्लैश टेक्निकल नेविगेटर यूजर
हैंडल के साथ। आप इस पे आके मुझे फॉलो
करके मुझसे जुड़ सकते हैं। मुझसे कनेक्ट
हो सकते हैं। मुझसे बातें कर सकते हैं।
साथ ही में Lindin पे ही आप डिफ़्रॉनिक्स
सर्च करेंगे। डी ई एफ आर ओ एन आई एक्स
तो आपको डिफ़्रॉनिक्स साइबर सिक्योरिटी का
Lindin पेज मिल जाएगा। एंड कुछ इस तरीके
के आप सर्च करेंगे Lindin पेज मिल जाएगा
जहां पे 22,000 से भी ज्यादा लोग
डिफ़्रॉनिक्सम से जुड़े हुए हैं। कंपनी से
रिगार्डिंग कोई भी अपडेट, किसी भी तरह की
लाइक किसी भी तरह का कोई भी आपको
अनाउंसमेंट हो गया, गिव अवे हो गई,
कोर्सर्सेस के बारे में हो गया। सब कुछ
आपको इसी Lindin पेज के थ्रू मिल जाएगा जब
आपको उसका इंफॉर्मेशनेशन। आप इसको फॉलो कर
लीजिएगा। यह हमारा एक्स का पेज है।
डेफ़्रोनिक्स Academy हैंडल के साथ। इसको
जरूर फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। देयर विल बी अ लॉट
ऑफ़ थिंग्स दैट विल बी कमिंग ऑन दिस एक्स
पेज। यह मेरी Instagram की खुद की पर्सनल
प्रोफाइल है। नितेश सिंह हैकर Instagram
हैंडल के साथ। यहां फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। यहीं
पे आपको डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी यूजर हैंडल मिल
जाएगी। जो हमारी डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी हमारी
कंपनी का Instagram हैंडल है। लगभग 48,000
लोग इसे फॉलो करते हैं। इनेशनल रील्स,
कंटेंट्स इन सबके लिए। यह हमारी वेबसाइट
है। इस पे आपको अभी यह पूरी वेबसाइट आपको
रिवम्ड और एकदम बिल्कुल फ्रेश लुक में
बहुत ही जल्द मिलने मिल जाएगी देखने को।
इसमें अलग-अलग सेक्शंस एंड बहुत सारी
इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें आने वाली है इस वेबसाइट
पे। अपडेट्स आने वाली है। इसको आप
बुकमार्क करके सेव कर लीजिएगा, फॉलो
कीजिएगा। academy पे जाएंगे तो आपको यहां
पे academydfish.com
पे हमारे सारे कोर्सर्सेस जो हम ऑफर करते
हैं वो आपको मिल जाते हैं। इस नंबर पे
कांटेक्ट करके हमसे सारी इंफॉर्मेशन या जो
भी क्वेरीज क्वेश्चंस हैं आप हमसे पूछ के
पता कर सकते हैं। दैट्स इट। और जो भी
वीडियोस आप देखते हैं रिकॉर्डिंग में तो
नीचे में वीडियो के यहां पे कहीं पे आपको
हाइप का एक बटन दिखेगा। उसको हाइप कर दिया
कीजिए वीडियो को। जितने पॉइंट्स आप हाइप
करते हैं वीडियोस को। वीडियोस उतनी
रिकमेंड होती है YouTube के एल्गोरििदम के
अकॉर्डिंग और YouTube उसको प्रमोट करती
है। तो मैक्सिमम लोगों तक जो है वह वीडियो
पहुंच जाती है आप लोगों के कारण। तो आपकी
वहां पे एक सपोर्ट और एक आपका हेल्प हो
जाता है जो इस वीडियो को मैक्सिमम ऑडियंस
तक पहुंचाती है। क्योंकि
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] मुझे मैं कोई
पेड कोर्स को मैक्सिमम ऑडियंस तक पहुंचाने
की आपकी बात नहीं कर रहा। मैं फ्री एक
ट्रेनिंग चल रही है। फ्री में आपको चीजें
क्वालिटी वाली बता रहा हूं। फ्री में आपको
इतनी चीजें दे रहा हूं। उस चीज को मैं
लोगों तक पहुंचाने के लिए बोल रहा हूं। आई
होप कि आप उस चीज में हमारा सपोर्ट जरूर
करने वाले हैं। डिफ्रॉनिक्स को जरूर
डिफ्रॉनिक्स के वीडियोस को शेयर करते
होंगे। अगर आप नहीं करते होंगे तो किया
कीजिएगा। कई लोगों तक ऐसे लोगों तक भी
पहुंच सकती है जो शायद काफी ज्यादा नीड
में हो ऐसी ट्रेनिंग्स के। राइट?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
एक कमेंट आया था नेपाल से। एक हमारे लर्नर
थे उनका। उन्होंने कहा कि सर नेपाल में
ऐसी ट्रेनिंग्स के 25 से ₹00 लेते हैं और
आप यहां पे फ्री में प्रोवाइड कर रहे हो।
तो ऐसी ट्रेनिंग्स की वैल्यू ऐसे लोग
समझते हैं एंड वी आर रियली ग्लैड कि ऐसे
लोग इस ट्रेनिंग का पार्ट है या इस पूरे
डिफ्रॉनिक्स कम्युनिटी का पार्ट है। इस
साइबर सिक्योरिटी कम्युनिटी का पार्ट है।
चलिए [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अब यहां पे
हम आज जो टॉपिक करने वाले हैं उसके लिए
मैं आपको पहले ही बता देता हूं। लinिक्स
की टॉपिक है ये। आप लinक्स की ये टॉपिक
है। अब लनिक्स में अलग-अलग तरह के फैमिलीज़
होते हैं। चाहे वो रेड हट फैमिली हो या
चाहे आपका डेबियन फैमिली हो, रेड हट या
सेंटोस फैमिली हो। यहां पे हम लinक्स की
बात सिंपल कर रहे हैं जिसमें मोस्टली हम
डेबियन वाली चीजें कंसीडर
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
डेबियन वाले प्लेटफार्म पे हम सब कुछ
परफॉर्म करेंगे जो जो नॉर्मली जैसे आपका
Windows भी सपोर्ट करता है। काले लinक्स
उसी पे बेस्ड है। आपका Uban टूल्स पे
बेस्ड है। ये सारी।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] तो अभी तक
आपने एसओसी के Windows सेक्शन को देखा था।
अब Linux के सेक्शन को स्टार्ट कर रहे
हैं। इसके बाद Linux की सेक्शन की एक और
एसओसी की वीडियो आएगी और उसके बाद Linx
पार्ट ख़ हो जाएगा। तो हमने एसओसी का पूरा
बेसिक्स भी कवर कर लिया था। स्टार्टिंग
में ही ट्राईटमी और इन सब के थ्रू भी करा
था। उसके बाद हमने पूरी साइबर सिक्योरिटी
मॉड्यूल फॉर एसओसी कंप्लीट करा। उसके बाद
हमने पूरी नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी मॉड्यूल फॉर
एसओसी कंप्लीट करा। उसके बाद हमने
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को शुरू किया। उसमें हमने
क्या Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को कंप्लीट
किया। अब हम Linux ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को
कंप्लीट कर रहे हैं। सबसे बड़ी खुशखबरी की
यह बात है। आप सब वो खेलिए। प्लीज डोंट
रिपीट द मैसेजेस। आप स्पैम करेंगे तो आपको
टाइम आउट कर दिया जाएगा तो आप फिर मैसेज
नहीं कर पाएंगे तो प्लीज रिपीट मत कीजिए
एक दो बार मैसेज करके छोड़ दीजिए
[हंसी] ओके तो अब यहां पे जो लinक्स की ये
फर्स्ट वीडियो है इसके बाद एक और वीडियो
आएगी लinक्स की और लinक्स भी आपकी कंप्लीट
हो जाएगी। उसके बाद हम बढ़ेंगे हमारे एसओसी
के कंप्लीशन की तरफ जहां पे एसओसी की
प्रैक्टिकल चीजें जो हैं वो शुरू हो
जाएंगी। लैब्स वाली चीजें ट्राईकमी के
लैब्स हो चाहे कोई और लैब हो हैंड्स ऑन
प्रैक्टिससेस जो है वो सब शुरू हो जाएंगी।
आप एसआईएम डैशबोर्ड को समझना शुरू कर
देंगे। कैसे वो काम करता है। किस तरीके से
अलर्ट को आप डील करते हो। किस तरीके से
इन्वेस्टिगेट करते हो, एस्केलेट करते हो।
किस तरीके से रिॉल्व सब कुछ जो है वो आपको
समझ आने लगेगा। एंड एसओसी के प्रैक्टिकल
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन के साथ ही साथ हम इस सीरीज
को एंड करने की तरफ बढ़ने लगेंगे। तो ये
आपके लिए खुशखबरी है कि अब हम बहुत हद तक
हमने सिलेबस का 70% कंप्लीट कर दिया है।
जस्ट 30 75% मान के चलो 25% जो है आपका
कंटेंट अभी जो बचा है उसको हम एसओसी
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन और प्रैक्टिकल्स जब होंगे
तो उसके साथ ही हम खत्म करेंगे और उसके
बाद एक इंटरव्यू का प्रिपरेशन का मैं आपको
बताऊंगा कैसे आपको करना है, किस तरीके से
करनी है, कहां-कहां अप्लाई करना है, मैं
आपको यह भी बताऊंगा। इसके लिए बेफिक्र
रहिएगा कि आप थर्ड ईयर, फाइनल ईयर मतलब आप
एलिजिबल होने चाहिए। देखो एलिजिबिलिटी में
मेरा कोई हाथ नहीं है। पहले ही मैं आपको
बता रहा हूं। यू मस्ट बी एलिजिबल। हां, हम
आपको वो चीजें खोज के जरूर देंगे जहां पे
हो सकता है कि नॉन आईटी बैकग्राउंड वालों
के लिए भी वो जॉब रोल एलिजिबल हो। ऐसी
चीजें बहुत कम मिलती है बट कहीं भी मिलेगी
तो हम आपको वो भी बताएंगे। और जो आईटी
वाले बंदे हैं, जो एलिजिबल बंदे हैं जो
जॉब रोल में लिखा हुआ होगा। अब मान लो कोई
कंपनी हायर कर रही है एसओसी के लिए। अब
उन्होंने जो जॉब रोल में मेंशन किया है हम
उसको तो नहीं बदल सकते। मैं तो नहीं जाकर
उनको बोल सकता कि भाई ये क्या डाला है?
इसको हटाओ इसको कुछ और चेंज करो। तो उनके
जॉब रोल के अकॉर्डिंग अगर आप एलिजिबल हैं
हम आपको हर जगह अप्लाई करवाएंगे। आपको
बताएंगे कैसे करना है, क्या करना है?
इंटरव्यूज के लिए आपको क्वेश्चंस भी शेयर
करेंगे। कुछ डमी क्वेश्चंस शेयर करेंगे।
आपको WhatsApp के ऊपर ही एंड आपको
प्रिपेयर कराएंगे। एंड होपफुली हमारे बहुत
से कैंडिडेट्स जॉब क्रैक कर पाएं। एंड
हमें अगर ऐसा पता चलता है हमारे को आके
ऐसी खुशखबरी दें कि सर आई हैव गॉट द जॉब
एज एन एसओसी एनालिस्ट या एसओसी एल वन एंड
उस टाइम जो खुशी जो हैप्पीनेस मुझे होगी
वो हैप्पीनेस किसी और को नहीं हो सकती इवन
आपको भी नहीं होगी आप जॉब लगा लो आप 1 लाख
की भी सैलरी ले लो 500 की ले लो 25000 की
ले लो कोई भी सैलरी आपको मिले कुछ भी मिले
आप एकदम से आई थिंक मान लो कि आप बहुत ही
फाइनेंशियली वीक फैमिली से बिलोंग करते हो
तब भी आपको उतनी खुशी नहीं मिलेगी जितनी
मुझे खुशी मिलेगी जब मुझे पता चल जाएगा कि
यू आर द वन हु वर द हु आर अ स्टूडेंट ऑफ
दिस पर्टिकुलर सीरीज एंड यू गॉट प्लेस्ड
यू गॉट अ जॉब यू स्टार्टेड अर्निंग दैट्स
व्हाई तो चलिए वहां हमारा ये सीरीज का
सपना सक्सेसफुल हो जाएगा एंड वो बहुत एक
अलग लेवल की खुशी होगी तो स्टार्ट करते
हैं आज की क्लास एंड
होपफुली [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आप लोग
इस पे फोकस करेंगे सेशन में चलिए
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल
स्टार्ट करते हैं अह सेशन को मैं स्लाइड
को स्टार्ट कर देता हूं
ओके
चलिए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अब यहां पे आज की जो सेशन है उसमें हम
लinक्स की फाइल सिस्टम स्ट्रक्चर यानी
फाइल सिस्टम आर्किटेक्चर को समझने वाले
हैं। इसको समझेंगे बट उसके पहले मैं
लinक्स का एक मशीन भी ऑन कर लेता हूं। अगर
आप में से आप में से कुछ लोगों के पास
Linx इंस्टॉल्ड है तो आप अपना भी लैपटॉप
ऑन कर सकते हैं। अगर नहीं है कोई बात नहीं
है। व्हाट इफ यू कैन डू यू कैन फोकस ऑन
दिस पर्टिकुलर अभी सेशन एंड फोकस जरूर
कीजिएगा क्योंकि आपको अगर समझ में नहीं
आएगा ना सब बेकार हो जाएगा। सारा बेकार हो
जाएगा आज का सेशन। तो प्लीज फोकस आप
प्रैक्टिस कर पाए या ना कर पाए डजंट मैटर।
बट फोकस ऑन दिस सेशन। आप बाद में भी इस इस
क्लासेस इस क्लास के बाद रिकॉर्डिंग देख
के और उसको प्रैक्टिस कर सकते हैं। अगर
आपका लinक्स इंस्टॉल नहीं है तो इंस्टॉल
कर सकते हैं। सिंपल सा फंडा है। आप कोई भी
Linux का डिस्ट्र डिस्ट्रो या
डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं। KL
Linx या Ubuntू अगर कर लेते हैं तो वेल
एंड गुड अच्छा रहेगा। ठीक है? इजी होता
है। ईजी इंस्टॉलेशन है। Kali Linux आप
आराम से इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं। Ubuntू को
बहुत ईज़ली इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं। एंड यू
कैन गो अहेड। ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अब मैं यहां पे एक मशीन स्टार्ट कर रहा
हूं। यहां पे मैं काली लinक्स को स्टार्ट
कर रहा हूं। एज एमआई काली एज आई लinक्स
मशीन। काली एक डेवियन बेस्ड लinक्स मशीन
है। तो मैं काली को यहां पे वीएमवेयर में
मैंने इंस्टॉल करके रखा है। हां अगर आप
में से कोई ऐसा है जिसको काली को इंस्टॉल
करना नहीं पता वीएमवेयर के अंदर में तो
हमारे चैनल पे वो भी है। सब कुछ है यार
डिफ्रॉनिक्स के चैनल पे। डिफ्रॉनिक्स में
क्या नहीं है? तो आप क्या कीजिएगा? हमारे
चैनल पे चले जाइएगा। एंड यहां पे वीडियोस
सेक्शन में चले जाइएगा। हमारे चैनल पे
सबसे नीचे स्क्रॉल करके आइएगा चैनल पे।
बिल्कुल नीचे वीडियोस में। ठीक है? जब
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] नीचे आएंगे
तो यहां पे आपको एक एक वीडियो मिलेगी
Linux 2023.2 कंप्लीट स्टेप बाय स्टेप
इंस्टॉलेशन इन VMware। दो तरीके मैंने इस
इसमें बताए हैं। एक वर्चुअल मशीन फाइल के
साथ, एक नॉर्मल आईएसओ फाइल के साथ। दोनों
में से कोई सा भी तरीका यूज़ करके आप काली
इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं VMware के अंदर में।
बहुत आसान तरीका है। मात्र 28 मिनट की
वीडियो है। आपका 28 मिनट लगेगा। आप
इंस्टॉलेशन कर पाएंगे। यहां वर्जन 2023.2
है। बट अभी वर्जन लेटेस्ट वर्जन जो है
काली की अगर आप देखेंगे
काली ऑर्ग
यहां पर तो अभी [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
जनवरी फरवरी मार्च आई थिंक टू चलना चाहिए
2026.2 होना चाहिए मेरे ख्याल से 2026.1
ही चल रहा है। ठीक है? तो 2026.1 अभी चल
रहा है फिलहाल के लिए। बट इस वर्जन से
कंफ्यूज मत होइएगा। आप ये वर्जन ही
इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं। 2026.1 कोई भी
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। कोई भी इशू नहीं आएगा।
ये पहले का वर्जन इंस्टॉल है बट प्रोसेस
सारा कुछ सेम है वो तो इस वीडियो को फॉलो
करके आप काली लinक्स को इंस्टॉल कर सकते
हैं अगर आपको नहीं आता है तब की बात मैं
बोल रहा हूं। ठीक है अगर आती है वेल एंड
गुड कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। चलिए अब जो है
हम काली को मैं स्टार्ट कर लेता हूं और
साइड बाय साइड मैं इसको इसलिए बता रहा हूं
मैं आपको काली लinक्स नहीं सिखाने वाला।
मैं आपको लinक्स की फंडामेंटल चीजें जो एज
अ एसओसी आपको बहुत जरूरी पड़ती है क्योंकि
जब आप एंटरप्राइज़ नेटवर्क को डील करते
हैं, जब आप कंपनीज़ के नेटवर्क में होते
हैं तो कंपनीज़ के नेटवर्क में Windows के
साथ-साथ लinक्स मशीनंस भी यूज़ की जाती
हैं। मोस्टली सर्वर्स वगैरह जो हैं
मोस्टली लinक्स मशीनंस पे ही आपको देखने
को मिलेंगे। तो Linux के साथ फमिलियर होना
इज़ वेरी वेरी वेरीेंट। एंड इसलिए Linux के
बेसिक्स आपको जानकारी होंगे। तो So L1 की
आपकी पोस्ट की गरिमा आप और भी ज्यादा बढ़ा
पाएंगे। आप और भी ज्यादा वहां पे थोड़ा सा
मस्ती कर पाएंगे, मजे कर पाएंगे, थोड़ा
टशन दिखा पाएंगे। यह बात है। मैं आपको
इतनी चीजें क्यों बताता हूं? आप आप समझ
नहीं पाते। कुछ लोग टॉपिक्स के लिए बोलते
हैं कि सर ये टॉपिक वो टॉपिक इतना समझ लो
कि मैं आपको वो वो टॉपिक्स भी बता रहा हूं
जो आपके लिए जो आपको एसओसी में और कोई
नहीं बताएगा या उतनी ज्यादा ना भी जानो तो
भी चलता। लेकिन मैंने फिर भी उसको इंक्लूड
करा है। क्यों? क्योंकि जब आप जॉब में जाओ
ना तो आप थोड़ा टशन दिखा पाओ। जब आपको
मौका मिले यू कुड शो योर टशन कि अरे मुझे
ये भी पता है सामने वाला सोचेगा अच्छा
तुम्हारे लेवल से ज्यादा तुम्हें पता है
तो हां भाई मुझे मेरे औकात से ज्यादा पता
है क्योंकि मैंने डिफ्रॉनिक्स एसओसी की
ट्रेनिंग करी थी बस हो गया हमारी थोड़ी
एडवर्टाइजमेंट हो जाएगी तुम्हारा टशन दिख
जाएगा एंड फ्री में हमने एक क्वालिटी
ट्रेनिंग भी कंप्लीट कर ली अब क्या चाहिए
भाई इससे ज्यादा मैं कुछ और कर सकता हूं
नहीं कर सकता हूं चलिए करना होगा तो कर
दूंगा आगे चलके और कुछ
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके भैया जी लेट्स सो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
एज अ फ्रेश सर, एक क्वेश्चन है, हाउ मच
पैकेज आई कैन गेट? पैकेज के चक्कर में मत
पड़ो एज अ फ्रेशर, मैं यही बोलूंगा।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
वाह! शिपिंग पीस व एज अ फ्रेशर
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] कभी भी पैकेज के
चक्कर में मत पड़ो। कम से कम एक साल एक साल
तक किसी भी कंपनी में पैकेज की टेंशन लिए
बिना काम करो। पैकेज थोड़ा कम भी हो, पैसा
थोड़ा कम भी हो, चलेगा, दौड़ेगा। गो एंड गेट
टू वर्क। एंड उसी कंपनी में अगर एक साल के
बाद आपके पास वो अच्छी इंक्रीमेंट ऑफर कर
रहे हैं। आपको इंक्रीमेंट ऑफर कर रहे हैं
तो यू शुड कंटिन्यू इन दैट कंपनी। आप एक
कंपनी में जितना ज्यादा टाइम स्पेंड
करेंगे, कंपनी के कंपनी से आप उतनी ज्यादा
फमिलियर होते हैं। कंपनी के मैनेजमेंट का
ट्रस्ट आप में बढ़ता है। और कंपनी आपके
ग्रोथ के बारे में भी फिर सोचेगी। बट आप
कंपनी स्विच करते रहेंगे ना कुछ-कुछ टाइम
पे सैलरी अपग्रेड के चक्कर में तो हर
रिक्रूटर हर एंप्लयर ये सोचेगा ये तो भाई
उछल कूद करने वाली मछली है उछल कूद
करते-करते एक दिन चली जाएगी इससे इस पर
रिस्क नहीं ले सकते हैं ये होता है चीज तो
ये चीजें आप थोड़ा सा
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अ ध्यान
रखिएगा ठीक है चलिए नाउ लेट्स
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
बिगिन सबसे पहले फाइल सिस्टम स्ट्रक्चर को
हम समझते हैं लinक्स के तो व्हाट इज़
लinक्स फाइल सिस्टम सिंपल सिंपल सा फंडा
है। Linux ऑर्गेनाइज़ज़ एवरीथिंग इन अ सिंगल
हायरार्कियल ट्री स्ट्रक्चर। Linux हर चीज़
को एक सिंगल हायरार्किकल ट्री स्ट्रक्चर
में क्या करता है? ऑर्गेनाइज़ करता है। अब
यहां पे Windows की तरह Linux में नहीं
होता है कुछ भी। Windows में आपने देखा है
ना C ड्राइव, डी ड्राइव, ई ड्राइव, एफ
ड्राइव, जी ड्राइव बनाते रहो, पार्टीशन
बनाते रहो स्टोरेज के अकॉर्डिंग एंड आपके
पार्टीशन बनते रहेंगे और आपका काम चलता
रहेगा। Linux में हर चीज स्लैश होता है।
एवरीथिंग इज स्लैश ऐसे ये जो स्लैश आप
कीबोर्ड पे देते हो ना कीबोर्ड पे जो नीचे
में कॉमा डॉट के बाद जो बटन होती है स्लैश
वो स्लैश ही लinक्स में सब कुछ है। सोचो
एक छोटा सा नोटेशन स्लैश कितनी पावरफुल
चीज होती है कि इसके अंदर पूरा का पूरा
लinक्स काम करता है। लinक्स की हर एक चीज
इसी के अंदर काम करती है। दैट्स इट। दिस
इज़ कॉल्ड रूट डायरेक्टरी। इसको हम रूट
डायरेक्टरी बोलते हैं जो यह फ़ाइल सिस्टम
का नोटेशन होता है आपका। रूट
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] डायरेक्टरी
इसलिए बोलते हैं क्योंकि इसके अंदर रूट
आपका प्रेजेंट रहता है। एक रूट डायरेक्टरी
जो कि सबसे ज्यादा यूज़फुल, सबसे ज्यादा
पावरफुल एंड सबसे ज्यादा जो है यूज़ होने
वाला डायरेक्टरी होता है। इसको हम रूट
डायरेक्टरी बोलते हैं। तो अब रूट
डायरेक्टरी इसलिए बोलते हैं क्योंकि इसी
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर रूट नाम का एक फोल्डर
भी होता है। एक डायरेक्टरी होती है और
इसके ही अंदर में और बाकी के इंपॉर्टेंट
फाइल्स जो होते हैं लinक्स में वो सारी
चीजें होती हैं। एवरीथिंग स्टार्ट्स फ्रॉम
रूट। हर चीज रूट से शुरू होता है लinक्स
के अंदर में। अब इसमें ना आपको कुछ
इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें पता चलेंगी। लinक्स के
अंदर में आपको ऐसीऐसी चीजें पता चलेंगी कि
आपको मजा आ जाएगा। आप देखना आज की क्लास
आप करके देखो कंप्लीट क्लास। आपको मजा ना
आया तो मेरा नाम बदल के रख देना। क्या
रखोगे? डेफ्रोनिक्स मास्टर कोई बात नहीं।
अब देखो [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब
हां एक क्वेश्चन आपसे। आप में से कितने
लोग लinिक्स से फमिलियर हैं? चाहे वो काली
हो, युबंटू हो, फेडोरा हो या हुनिक्स हो,
कोई सा भी लinक्स हो डजंट मैटर आपने
जिंदगी में या पैरेट हो जिंदगी में कभी
कोई लinक्स डिस्ट्रो यूज़ किया हो, चलाया
हो, कभी इंस्टॉल किया हो, कभी थोड़ा बहुत
हैंड्स ऑन किया हो। कितने लोग हैं ऐसे? तो
जरा बताइए मुझे।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
प्लीज लेट मी नो इन द चैट। एवरीबॉडी और जो
नहीं है नो लिख दीजिए।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
काफी लोग हैं।
क्या बात है? [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
काफी लोग हैं जो Linux को यूज़ कर रहे हैं।
ग्रेट। Linux ऐसी ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम या
कर्नल बोल लो। Linux इज अ कर्नल। ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
देखो Linux ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम नहीं बोलते।
Linux इज़ नॉट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम। अगर कोई
आपसे पूछे कि इज़ Linux ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम एन
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम तो बोलना ना Linux इज़ नॉट
एन ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम। अब वो पूछेगा हैं।
ऐसे कैसे बोलते तो है Linux? Linux एक
कर्नल होता है। कर्नल कर्नल के ई आर एन ई
एल एंड Linux कर्नल पे बेस्ड बाकी
डिस्ट्रीब्यूशंस होते हैं। जैसे काली
लinक्स हो गया। Ubeबू हो गया आपका pाटo हो
गया आपका fedura हो गया आपका व्हाटएवर तो
ये जो अलग-अलग डिस्ट्रीब्यूशंस है जो
लinक्स कर्नल पे बेस्ड होते हैं चलते हैं
ठीक है तो कभी भी कोई पूछे तो डोंट से
लinक्स ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम वो टेक्निकल आंसर
सही नहीं है ये ठीक
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] है
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
लinक्स इज़ अ कर्नल राइट ठीक है नाउ लेट्स
मूव टू द नेक्स्ट पार्ट अब नेक्स्ट पार्ट
की तरफ बढ़ेंगे लेकिन उसके पहले मैं एक और
चीज़ आपको क्लियर करना चाहता हूं धमाकेदार
चीज़ कि लinक्स में जब हम लinक्स की बात
करते हैं
लinिक्स की बात करते हैं तो लinक्स में
एवरीथिंग इज अ फाइल दैट्स इट। ये शायद आप
लोगों में से कई लोगों को नहीं पता होगा।
अभी बहुत कुछ और पता चलने वाला है। लinक्स
में एवरीथिंग इज अ फाइल। फाइल एक फाइल है।
डायरेक्टरी एक फाइल है। इमेज एक फाइल
ऑलरेडी है। डॉट एक फाइल है। एक्सटेंशन एक
एक्सटेंशन की कोई डायरेक्टरी या कोई कोई
फाइल है वो भी एक फाइल है।
कुछ भी लinक्स में हर एक चीज़ फाइल है।
वहां Linux में हर चीज़ फाइल है। बस इतना
जान जाओ। अभी कांसेप्ट उसका आपको लगेगा कि
क्या है बट इसके ऊपर थोड़ा सा थोड़ा सा आप
रिसर्च करना अगर आपको मन करे तो बट लinक्स
लinक्स में हर एक चीज फाइल है दैट्स इट ये
याद रखिएगा
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] नहीं डायरेक्टरी
इज़ आल्सो अ फाइल लinक्स में डायरेक्टरी इज़
आल्सो अ फाइल बहुत लोगों को ऐसा है ना
डायरेक्टरी हम बोलते हैं राइट डायरेक्टरी
एक फोल्डर को कहते हैं राइट बिल्कुल सही
बात है लेकिन लinक्स में एवरीथिंग इज़ अ
फाइल ये याद रखिएगा हमेशा इसके ऊपर रिसर्च
कर लीजिएगा। ठीक है? चलिए
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] नाउ लेट्स मूव
फॉरवर्ड।
आगे की तरफ बढ़ते हैं। अब ये तो आपको समझ
में आ गया। अब Linux के एक स्ट्रक्चर को
हम समझते हैं। जैसा मैंने बोला कि सब कुछ
स्लैश के अंदर होता है। एवरीथिंग इज़
स्लैश। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] इसके
अंदर होता है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब ये क्या
है? अब Linux में स्लैश जो है ना एक
पार्टीशन की तरह है। जैसे आप Windows में
एक पार्टीशंस बनाते हो। सी ड्राइव डी
ड्राइव ई ड्राइव एफ ड्राइव वैसे ही समझो
कि ये जो स्लैश है ये एक मेजर बड़ा सा
पार्टीशन है और इसी के अंदर बाकी
छोटे-छोटे छोटे-छोटे फोल्डर्स डायरेक्टरीज़
ये सब एकज़िस्ट करते हैं। हालांकि वो सब भी
फाइल है बट स्टिल छोटी-छोटी डायरेक्टरीज़
या छोटी-छोटी फाइल्स वो सब एकज़िस्ट करते
हैं। अब इसी स्लैश के अंदर में एक
डायरेक्टरी होता है बिन एक एसबिन एक ईटीसी
एक डेव एक होम एक यूजर एक टम एक वार एक
बूट एक रूट एक लिब एक ऑप्ट एक एमएटी एक
मीडिया एक एसआरवी एक सिस एक प्रॉप इसी के
अंदर सब प्रेजेंट है। ये सारी चीजें होती
है। ठीक है? प्लीज डोंट
स्पैम। अगर आप 11th क्लास में हो पढ़ाई और
साइबर सिक्योरिटी को लेके इनमें प्रॉब्लम
हो रहा है तो टेंशन मत लो। पहले 12th पे
फोकस करो। ठीक है? 12th पे फोकस करो। जैसे
ही 12th पे फोकस करोगे 12th अच्छे से
क्लियर करो। देन साइबर सिक्योरिटी को
पैरेली कॉलेज में जाके उसको पैरेली
कंप्लीट करो। ठीक है? उसके साथ जाओ। अब
यहां पे ये सारी चीजें आपकी स्लैश के अंदर
में प्रेजेंट होती है। स्लैश के अंदर में
रहती है। अब क्या है ये? चलो मैं आपको
लाइव आज दिखाता चलूंगा ताकि आपको दिमाग
में आपके फिट होता चले। ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां हम
लinक्स में आ चुके हैं। काली लinx का ये
डेस्कटॉप एनवायरमेंट डेस्कटॉप आ गया आपका।
ठीक है? XFC
अब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यहां पे मैं
राइट क्लिक करूंगा। टर्मिनल को ओपन
करूंगा। ठीक है? मैं इसको थोड़ा सा ज़ूम इन
कर देता हूं। सॉरी ताकि यह बड़ा हो जाए।
नहीं लेट नहीं हुआ। अभी स्टार्ट हो गया।
यह हो गया। अभी हम फिलहाल Linx में मैं
इसको सीडी कमांड से पहले यहां पर आता हूं
और क्लियर कर देता हूं। पहले मैं आर एम
हिस्ट्री वाली हटा देता हूं। एक बार इसको
हटा देते हैं ताकि आपको कमांड्स दिखे ना
और आपको मैं यहां पे डायरेक्ट पहले फर्स्ट
टाइम ऐसे दिखा दूं। देखो अ इसको मैं माइनस
भाई छोटा हो जा। छोटा हो जा। हां। आई होप
यू ऑल कैन सी द स्क्रीन। राइट? अब यहां पे
मैं सीडी कमांड से पहले प्र्ट चेंज कर
देता हूं। यहां पे मैं आ गया हूं। ठीक है?
अब फिलहाल लinक्स में हर चीज एक पाथ होता
है। हर चीज एक पाथ होता है। ठीक है? जस्ट
हर चीज इज पाथ। तो करेंटली जो यह पहला जो
यह आपका सेक्शन है यह आपको बताता है कि आप
किस टाइप के यूजर से कनेक्टेड हैं। किस
टाइप के यूजर के शेल प्र्प्ट में है। तो
अभी हम रूट यूजर के प्र्प्ट में है। रूट
यूजर से हम लॉग्ड इन है। यह रूट उस चीज को
बताता है। उसके बाद यह काली। अब लinक्स
में जब आप होस्ट नेम टाइप करेंगे तो आपको
होस्ट नेम दिखेगा। तो यह होस्ट नेम हमारा
काली है जो यहां पे यह आपको दिखा रहा है
यह वाला पार्ट। ठीक है? इसको एक ब्रैकेट
के अंदर रखा हुआ है। और यहां पे जो है यह
बताता है प्रेजेंट वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी।
करेंटली आप किस डायरेक्टरी में काम कर रहे
हैं लinक्स के अंदर में। ठीक है? बस ये
चीजें हैं। तो यहां पे पीडब्ल्यूडी कमांड
एक होती है प्रेजेंट वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी।
लinक्स में ये कमांड्स आप लिखते चलिएगा
नोट्स के नोट्स के लिए। आपके लिए यूज़फुल
रहेगा। मैं सच बता रहा हूं। जो भी चीजें
बता रहा हूं लिखते चलिएगा। आपके लिए
यूज़फुल रहेगा। पीडब्ल्यूडी कमांड जब एंटर
करेंगे तो आपको प्रेजेंट वर्किंग
डायरेक्टरी ये बताता है। तो ये वाला जब
सिंबल आपके पास दिखे तो इसका मतलब समझ
जाइए कि आप रूट डायरेक्टरी में काम कर रहे
हैं। और अगर आपको ये सिंबल दिखे ये वाला
सिंबल स्लैश तो इसका मतलब समझ जाइए कि आप
स्लैश डायरेक्टरी में काम कर रहे हैं।
स्लैश में ओनली स्लैश में हैं आप फाइल
सिस्टम के अंदर। ये दो चीजें हैं। बस आपको
दो चीजों का ध्यान रखना है। अगर इस तरह का
कुछ आपको दिखे यहां पे पीडब्ल्यूडी के लिए
तो आप समझिए यहां पे आप दिख रहे हैं तो
स्लैश रूट के अंदर काम कर रहे हैं। और इस
तरीके के दिखे तो आप स्लैश के अंदर काम कर
रहे हैं। दैट्स इट। इसी के अंदर ऑपरेट कर
रहे हैं। अब ये स्लैश रूट का मतलब क्या
हुआ? स्लश रूट का मतलब हुआ इस स्लैश के
अंदर में यह रूट एग्जिस्ट कर रहा है। यानी
फाइल सिस्टम के अंदर रूट नाम की एक लोकेशन
है वो एग्जिस्ट कर रहा है। तो यही वो
स्लैश है जिसके अंदर सब कुछ एग्जिस्ट करता
है। अब मैं आपको दिखाता हूं कैसे। अब यहां
पे हम स्लैश के अंदर फिलहाल है और हमें
इसको अगर देखना है कि इसके अंदर क्या-क्या
चीजें हैं तो मैं एलएस करूंगा। एलएस एक
कमांड होती है लिस्ट करने के लिए लinक्स
में। जैसे Windows में डीआईआर कमांड होती
है। नहीं एसओसी में काली लinक्स का कोई
यूज़ केस ऐसा नहीं है। ऐसा कोई मैंडेटरी
नहीं है। आप यूज़ करना चाहो तो कर सकते हो।
लinक्स के तौर पे आपको लinक्स
डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन के बारे में जानना है। आप
काली की जगह पे एसओसी के लिए आप U1 यूज़ कर
लो। कोई सा भी डेबियन बेस्ड या डेविए OS
यूज़ कर लो। चलेगा। इट्स नॉट मैंडेटरी टू
यूज़ काली। ठीक है? यू आर नॉट डूइंग हैकिंग
और समथिंग लाइक दैट।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां एलएस
करोगे। लिस्ट जो डायरेक्टरी कमांड होती है
डीआईआर कमांड होती है Windows में तो एलएस
करने पे यह लिस्ट करेगा इस स्लैश के अंदर
की सारी फोल्डर्स या फाइल्स डायरेक्टरीज़
और फाइल्स तो मैं एंटर करूंगा अब एंटर
करूंगा तो यहां पे मुझे इसके अंदर की जो
भी प्रेजेंट डायरेक्टरीज़ और फाइल्स जो भी
चीज़ हैं वो सब मेरे को देखने को मिल
जाएगी। अब ये जब डायरेक्टरीज़ आप देखेंगे
तो आपको कुछ सिमिलर आपको देखने को मिलेगा
जो
आपने कहां देखा था? यहां इस इमेज में देखा
था। बिन एसbिन ईटीसी डेव होम ये सब देखा
था आपने वही चीज़ है बिन ये देखो बिन एसbिन
डेव ईटीसी होम रूट एमएटी ऑप्ट प्रॉक वेयर
यूएसआर यूजर की जो होती है लिब 32 लिब 64
लाइब्रेरी ऑप्ट एमT मीडिया ये सारी
डायरेक्टरीज आपको दिखेंगी जो आपने यहां पे
इमेज के अंदर जो मैंने आपको दिखाया था तो
यही चीजें मैंने आपको बताई थी कि यहां पे
स्लैश के अंदर में ये सारी चीजें एग्ज़िस्ट
करती हैं जिसका कोई ना कोई मतलब होता है।
अब जैसे यह बिन डायरेक्टरी है। बिन
डायरेक्टरी। ठीक है? तो बिन डायरेक्टरी
रेफर्स टू द यूजर बाइनरीज़
एग्जीक्यूटेबल्स। यानी कि कोई ऐसी बन
एग्जीक्यूटेबल बाइनरी है वो बिन वाले
सेक्शन में आपकी प्रेजेंट रहेगी। जैसे कोई
भी एग्जीक्यूटेबल बाइनरी है जिसको आप
एग्जीक्यूट कर सकते हो जिसको आप रन कर
सकते हो इन Linux सिस्टम। जैसे Windows के
अंदर में देखो ये सिंपल सा ऐसा है।
Windows के अंदर में आप एग्जीक्यूटेबल
इंस्ट एग्जीक्यूट करते हो। exec फाइल्स हो
गई। डॉटbat वगैरह ये सब होते हैं
एग्जीक्यूटेबल्स। तो जनरली एग्जीक्यूटेबल
फाइल प्रोग्राम फाइल्स वाली फोल्डर में
रहती है। रहती है ना भाई? प्रोग्राम
फाइल्स वाले डायरेक्टरी में
एग्जीक्यूटेबल्स नॉर्मली रहती है उनका।
उसी तरीके से Linux में बिन हमारा है।
यहां पे जितने भी एग्जीक्यूटेबल्स हैं आप
चाहें तो इसके अंदर आप उसको प्लेस करके
एंड उसको डायरेक्टली रन कर सकते हैं। वो
एक पाथ सेट कर देता है और आपका जो भी
एग्जीक्यूटेबल होगा लinक्स के अंदर यहां
से रन कर जाएगा बिन के अंदर में। ठीक है?
अब उसी तरीके से एक होता है एसिन। तो
जितने सिस्टम बाइनरीज़ होते हैं, जो सिस्टम
फाइल्स होते हैं। ठीक है? जैसे Windows
में सिस्टम 32 के अंदर सिस्टम फाइल्स
प्रेजेंट होते हैं। वैसे ही यहां पे एसबिन
है। तो सिस्टम बाइनरी जो होते हैं
एग्जीक्यूट बाइनरी वो यहां पे रहते हैं।
उसी तरीके से एक ईटीसी फोल्डर होता है।
इसमें होती है कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल्स। ये
बहुत ही शानदार चीज है। मैं आपको इसको
दिखाना चाहूंगा क्योंकि दिस इज़ वेरी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] इंपॉर्टेंट।
अब बिन और एसबिन की बात की, तो चलो मैं
आपको वो भी दिखा देता हूं। मैं थोड़ा सा
और इसको छोटा कर देता हूं। ज्यादा बड़ा हो
जा रहा है। हां। अब मैं अगर बिन में चलूं
सीडी बिन में आपको ले चलूं तो यहां पे मैं
एलएस करूंगा तो एलएस करने के बाद यहां पे
आपको ये बिन में बहुत सारी यहां पे फाइल्स
अंदर देखने को मिलेंगे। ठीक है? ये देखो
ये बहुत सारी ये सब एग्जीक्यूटेबल्स हैं।
अगर मैं आपको इस तरीके से ना तो मैं आपको
डायरेक्टरी डायरेक्टरी के अंदर डायरेक्ट
ले चल के विजुअलाइज़ करके दिखाता हूं। जैसे
हम सीएम सीएमडी में कमांड चलाते हैं वैसे
ही इसका टर्मिनल होता है जिसमें हम सारे
कमांड्स के थ्रू सारा काम कर सकते हैं
Linux के अंदर में। बट ग्राफिकली भी मैं
आपको लेके चलता हूं। यहां फाइल सिस्टम है
वही स्लैश वाला जो है इसके अंदर ही सारा
कुछ प्रेजेंट है आपका। आपकी रूट
डायरेक्टरी भी प्रेजेंट है। इसलिए इसको
रूट डायरेक्टरी बोला जाता है क्योंकि रूट
का ये डायरेक्टरी है। रूट इसी में
प्रेजेंट होता है। रूट के साथ-साथ और बहुत
सी इंपॉर्टेंट डायरेक्टरीज़ प्रेजेंट है।
जिसमें कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट डायरेक्टरी की बात
करूं जो बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट होते हैं वो है
ईटीसी आपका वेरी वेरीेंट वेयर वेरी
वेरीेंट
प्रॉक वेरी वेरीेंट बिन कहां गया आपका? का
बिन बिन बिन बिन बिन बिन वेरी वेरीेंट। तो
ये डायरेक्टरीज़ यहां पे प्रेजेंट होती है।
अब यहां पे मैं बिन वाली डायरेक्टरी में
चलूंगा तो आपको बहुत सारी यहां पे
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल्स कॉन्फ़ सॉरी
एग्जीक्यूटेबल बाइनरीज़ दिखेंगी जो यहां पे
प्रेजेंट रहती है। अब इन बाइनरीज़ को आप
डायरेक्टली क्या कर सकते हो? एग्जीक्यूट
कर सकते हो। जैसे ये एप्ट गेट बाइनरी यहां
पे प्रेजेंट है। यानी आप एप्ट गेट कमांड
को डायरेक्टली अपने सिस्टम पे कहीं से भी
चला सकते हो। यहां पे जो भी बाइनरी
प्रेजेंट रहेगी आपको सिस्टम में
डायरेक्टली एग्जीक्यूटेबल होगी। जैसे कि
हम यहां पे एप गेट कमांड को चला सकते हैं।
कैसे चला सकते हैं भैया? एप हफन गेट ये
कमांड डाला और अपडेट
एप गेट के बाद अपडेट यानी कि ये अपडेट
करता है। रेपोजिटरी अपडेट चेक करता है। तो
मैंने ये अपडेट कमांड चलाया। यहां पे
रेपोजिटरी जो है मेरी अपडेट होना शुरू हो
चुकी है। तो यहां पे ये कमांड चल चुका है।
रेपोजिटरी इज़ बीइंग अपडेटेड। दैट्स इट।
ठीक है? तो इस तरीके से ये बिन जो सेक्शन
है वो आपका काम करता है बाइनरीज़ के लिए
एग्जीक्यूटेबल बाइनरीज़ के लिए और यहां पे
डन ये कम कमांड चल चुका है। अब उसी तरीके
से
इन द सिमिलर वे
यहां पे और भी बाइनरीज़ हैं। इनमें से जो
जो बाइनरीज़ आप चाहो वो आप चला सकते हो।
आराम से रन कर सकते हो। तो यह आपका बिन हो
जाता है। उसी तरीके से यहां पे हम एस बिन
की बात करते हैं। यहां पे हमने बात किया
एस बिन। तो एस बीन में जब हम आएंगे तो
यहां पे सिस्टम बाइनरीज़ प्रेजेंट रहेंगे।
जो सिस्टम से रिलेटेड सिस्टम वाली बाइनरीज़
हैं वो यहां पे प्रेजेंट रहेंगे। तो आप
उसको भी ये भी एग्जीक्यूटेबल बाइनरीज़ होते
हैं। अब इसी सारी डायरेक्टरी में एक
डायरेक्टरी होता है ईटीसी जो कि बहुत-ब
ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट डायरेक्टरी है ईटीसी।
ईटीसी के अंदर में आपको जितने भी
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल्स हैं, अलग-अलग पैकेजेस
के लinक्स में हम सॉफ्टवेयर्स नहीं बोलते
हैं। हम पैकेजेस बोलते हैं। तो अलग-अलग
पैकेजेस के यहां पे कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल्स
आपको मिल जाएंगी। ठीक है? एंड उन
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल्स के अंदर उस पर्टिकुलर
सॉफ्टवेयर या पैकेजेस के अंदर की सेटिंग्स
आप चेंज कर सकते हो। अंदर की कोई भी इनेशन
चेंज कर सकते हो। Linux की खासियत यही है
कि यह एक ओपन सोर्स प्लेटफार्म है। एंड
यहां पे आप जितने भी टूल्स हैं, जितने भी
टूल्स प्रेजेंट हैं, उन सबकी एक तो कोड
देख सकते हो कि क्या किस तरीके से कोडेड
है, किस तरीके से ये बने हैं। दूसरी चीज़
कि आप उसमें चेंजेस करके खुद का एक
डुप्लीकेट या कॉपी बना सकते हो। अपने
तरीके से उसको वर्क करा सकते हो। ये खूबी
है Linux की। अब जैसे अब यहां पे ईटीसी के
अंदर में आ गए। बीटीसी के अंदर में बहुत
सारी यहां पर फाइल्स हैं। जैसे कि मैं कोई
सी भी एक फाइल अगर ले लूं
लेट्स से प्रॉक्सी चेंज इज देयर एनी मान
लो एक कॉन्फ़िगरेशन है यहां पे प्रॉक्सी
चेंज 4. अब मैं इसको राइट क्लिक करूंगा
और यहां पे ओपन विद माउस पैड कर देता हूं।
मैं इसको ओपन करता हूं। तो यहां पे आपको
ये कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल दिख जाएगी। जो
प्रॉक्सी चेस प्रॉक्सी चेस एक यूटिलिटी है
एक पैकेज है जिसके थ्रू आप अपनी आईपी मतलब
एड्रेसेस जो होते हैं उसको प्रॉक्सिफाई कर
देते हैं टॉर का यूज़ करके आप अपने सिस्टम
को थोड़ी एनमिटी प्रोवाइड कर देते हैं।
कहने का मतलब यह है अभी के लिए फिलहाल
इतना जानिए। तो इसकी पूरी कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
यहां पे आपको देखने को मिल जाएगी। अब
इसमें आप जो चेंजज़ करना चाहें,
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन में चेंजज़ करना चाहें, डालना
चाहें, वह सब यू कैन डू हियर। तो ईटीसी इज
द वेरी पावरफुल डायरेक्टरी ऑन द लinक्स
सिस्टम। इसी तरीके से एक वायर डायरेक्टरी
होती है जिसके अंदर में आपको अलग-अलग तरह
के और डायरेक्टरीज दिखेंगी। बैकअप की
डायरेक्टरीज दिखेंगी। टेंपरेरी
डायरेक्टरीज दिखेंगी। लॉग्स की डायरेक्टरी
दिखेंगी। और यही लॉग डायरेक्टरी एज एन
एसओसी एल1 आपके लिए सबसे ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट है। वेयर लॉग स्लश वेयर स्लश
लॉग यह वाली डायरेक्ट जिसके अंदर में
लॉग्स कलेक्ट होते हैं। अलग-अलग पैकेजेस
के अकॉर्डिंग एंड अलग-अलग आपने जो भी
चीजें परफॉर्म करी है अपने उस लinक्स मशीन
पर उसके लॉग्स यहां पे कलेक्ट होती हैं।
जैसे वीएमवेयर के रिगार्डिंग लॉग्स के
फाइल पड़ी हुई है। कलेक्ट हुई हैं आपकी।
जैसे अपाचे स जो अपाचे सर्वर होता है उसके
रिगार्डिंग लॉग है। यहां पे एप के
रिगार्डिंग लॉग है। आप देख सकते हैं यहां
पे हिस्ट्री लॉग हिस्ट्री लॉग ये सब लॉग्स
आपके यहां पे होते हैं। जिन लॉ्स को पढ़
के एज एन एसोसिएट आपको आईडिया लग जाएगा।
लगेगा कि एग्जैक्टली क्या हो रहा है?
एग्जैक्टली व्हाट इज़ हैपनिंग देयर? तो ये
वायर वाली डायरेक्टरी भी काफी इंपॉर्टेंट
होता है। उसी तरीके से यहां पे एक रूट
डायरेक्टरी है। रूट के अंदर नॉर्मल
फोल्डर्स जैसे डॉक्यूमेंट्स, डाउनलोड्स,
म्यूजिक, पिक्चर्स ये सारी चीजें होती हैं
आपकी प्रेजेंट रहती है। इसके अंदर और भी
चीजें होती हैं। अ देखो जो भी आप
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर जा रहे हो तो इसके
अंदर ना जो आपको दिख रही है वो तो दिख रही
है। एक तो चीज़ आपको दिख रही हैं। दूसरी
चीज़ होती है जो दिखने वाली नहीं है। जो
हिडन है वो आपको यहां नहीं दिख रही है। तो
हिडन डायरेक्टरीज या फाइल्स को देखने के
लिए आपको व्यू पे जाना है और यहां पे आपको
एक ऑप्शन मिलेगा शो हिडन फाइल्स या
कंट्रोल एच प्रेस करके क्लिक करेंगे तो जो
हिडन फाइल्स हैं वो आ जाएंगी। देखो पहले
जो हिडन फाइल्स हैं वो थोड़ा सा अ लाइट
कलर में आएगा। हल्का कलर में आएगा। एंड इस
तरीके से आपको दिखेंगी। और जितने भी हिडन
फाइल्स या जो भी डायरेक्टरीज़ होंगे हिडन
उनके स्टार्टिंग में डॉट लगा रहेगा। याद
रखिएगा। ऑल डायरेक्टरीज यहां पर
स्टार्टिंग में जो है उनके डॉट लगा रहेगा।
तो, यह हिडन डायरेक्टरीज हैं। क्योंकि यह
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल्स कुछ है यहां पे। कुछ
लोकल इंपॉर्टेंट फाइल्स हैं यहां पे। कुछ
एसएसएच के रिलेटेड फाइल्स हैं यहां पे।
जैसे एसएसएच रिलेटेड कुछ एजेंट यहां पे
फाइल है। कुछ कॉन्फ़िगरेशन डॉट कॉन्फ़िग है।
तो इसमें अलग-अलग कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस यहां पे
आपकी फाइल्स यहां पे पड़ी हुई हैं। तो कुछ
सेंसिटिव चीजें जो ऐसा लगता है कि नॉर्मल
यूजर को सामने दिखने से कोई मतलब नहीं है।
नहीं दिखना चाहिए। तो उसको हाइड करके ही
रखा जाता है लinक्स के अंदर में। जैसे
यहां पे बैश आरसी वाली जो चीज़ है अह दिस
इज़ आल्सो हिडन ZSH आरसी जो सिस्टम की आपकी
यू कैन से कि एक कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल बोल
सकते हो वो है आपकी। ये हिस्ट्री ZS
हिस्ट्री जो आप टर्मिनल पे जितने कमांड्स
टाइप करते हो वो इसी हिस्ट्री के अंदर में
आपको मिलती है। अगर मैं इसको ओपन करके
दिखाऊं, तो यहां पे आपको कमांड्स दिखेंगे।
जो जो कमांड्स आप रन करते हैं वो इसी ZS
हिस्ट्री में यहां पे आके सेव हो जाती है।
ये फाइल ऑटोमेटिकली बनती है। जब भी आप
टर्मिनल पे कमांड चलाएंगे अगर इस फाइल को
डिलीट कर देंगे तो टर्मिनल पे जो कमांड्स
की हिस्ट्री है वो डिलीट हो जाएगी।
टर्मिनल बिल्कुल फ्रेश हो जाएगा। तो इस
तरीके से लेकिन हर फाइल ये जेडs आरसी अगर
आप डिलीट कर देते हैं तो आपका टर्मिनल
करप्ट हो जाएगा। एंड हो सकता है पॉसिबबली
आपको सिस्टम को रीस्ट रीइंस्टॉल या उसकी
जो भी ट्रबल शूट है वो करके फिर आपको सही
करना पड़ेगा। तो कुछ फाइल्स को आपको
छेड़ना नहीं होता है। उसी तरीके से यहां
पे अगेन आप इसको हटा देंगे तो ये बिल्कुल
नॉर्मल जो नॉर्मल फाइल्स हैं यहां पे आपको
दिखने लगेगी। अब देखो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ये
डायरेक्टरीज हो गई। अब इन्हीं डायरेक्टरीज़
को हम टर्मिनल के थ्रू भी देख सकते हैं।
ऑल दीज़ डायरेक्टरी दैट वी सॉ हियर वी कैन
सी विद द कमांड्स आल्सो। यही खूबी है
लinक्स की। तो मैं क्या करता हूं यहां पे?
फिलहाल के लिए मुझे रूट डायरेक्टरी में
मुझे फाइल सिस्टम में जाना है। तो मैं अभी
कहां पे हूं? स्लैश रूट में हूं। बट मुझे
जाना है फाइल सिस्टम में। तो सीडी कमांड
लिख दीजिए और सीधा स्पेस दे के स्लैश लिख
दीजिए। इससे होगा क्या? सीडी के बाद स्लैश
इसका मतलब है सीडी का मतलब होता है चेंज
डायरेक्टरी। तो स्लैश दिया तो अब हमें
डायरेक्टरी चेंज करनी है। हमें इस वाले से
रूट वाले से सीधा फाइल सिस्टम के अंदर
जाना है। एंटर कर दिया। हम फाइल सिस्टम
में आ चुके हैं। अब हम एलएस करेंगे तो
हमको अंदर की सारी डायरेक्टरी दिख जाएंगी।
अब इसी में जैसा मैंने आपको बिन वाला
दिखाया था। बिन ये बिन के अंदर की चीजें
दिखाई या ईटीसी के अंदर दिखाया था। तो
मुझे मालूम ईटीसी के अंदर जाना है। तो
अगेन वही चीज है सीडी चेंज डायरेक्टरी और
स्लैश ईटीसी अब स्लैश क्यों दिया है यहां
पे? क्योंकि ये स्लैश के अंदर ही हमारा
ईटीसी तो प्रेजेंट है। तो हमने स्लैश दे
दिया। नहीं भी दोगे तो ऑलरेडी अगर आप
स्लैश के अंदर हो तो आप डायरेक्ट ईटीसी भी
यहां पे लिख सकते हो। कोई भी प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है। आप डायरेक्ट ईटीसी भी लिख दो।
उसके बाद चलेगा। यह एंटर करोगे आप ईटीसी
के अंदर चले जाओगे। लेकिन अगर आप स्लैश
डायरेक्टरी में नहीं काम कर रहे होते। आप
कहीं और काम कर रहे होते हैं तो आपको पूरा
पाथ देना होता है लinक्स के अंदर में उस
डायरेक्टरी में जाने के लिए सीडी दिया
उसके बाद पूरा पाथ दिया और उसके बाद उस
डायरेक्टरी में जाएंगे ऐसा होता है तो
यहां पे हमने स्लैश ईटीसी कर दिया अब हम
ईटीसी के अंदर आ चुके हैं क्योंकि आप देख
सकते हो यहां पे ईटीसी हमारा यहां पॉपुलेट
हो चुका है अब यहां पे हम ईटीसी के अंदर
हमें क्या-क्या चीजें देखना है तो एलएस
करेंगे एंटर करेंगे एंड ईटीसी के अंदर
जितनी भी डायरेक्टरीज़ एंड फाइल्स हैं वो
आपको दिख जाएंगी। यूजुअली डायरेक्टरीज
आपको इस तरह के ब्लू कलर में देखने को मिल
जाएंगी और फाइल्स जो है कुछ आपको इस तरीके
से वाइट इसमें देखने को जनरली जनरली आपको
मिल जाएगा। तो इस तरीके से आप उसके सारे
कंटेंट्स को देख सकते हैं। ठीक है? अब ये
आपको समझ में आ गया होगा। अब
ये तो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] कुछ
इंपॉर्टेंट डायरेक्टरी हो गई। हम यहां पे
लinक्स को नहीं पढ़ रहे हैं। हम लinक्स
कीेंस को पढ़ रहे हैं। लinx के बारे में
ओवरव्यू ले रहे हैं फिलहाल। उसी तरीके से
टेंप डायरेक्टरी होती है टेंपरेरी फाइल्स
के लिए यूजर डायरेक्टरी होती है यूजर के
प्रोग्राम्स लाइब्रेरीज के लिए होम
डायरेक्टरी होती है जो यूज़र्स की होम
डायरेक्टरीज को रिप्रेजेंट करती है ये
सारी चीजें होती हैं स्लैश डेव होती है
डिवाइसेस डेव जो होता है डिवाइस डिवाइसेस
फाइल्स के लिए होती है जो डिवाइसेस के
फाइल्स हैं हार्डवेयर डिवाइसेस के उनके
फाइल्स के लिए होती है इन ईटीसी
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल मैंने बता दिया वायर जो
है वो वेरिएबल फाइल्स के लिए होती है जैसे
लॉग फाइल हो गई डेटाबेस हो गई बैकअप वगैरह
हो गया ये मैंने बताया था। इसके लिए होता
है। बूट जो होता है, वह बूट लोडर फाइल्स
और कर्नल इमेजज़ के लिए होते हैं। रूट जो
डायरेक्टरी होती है, वह होम डायरेक्टरी ऑफ़
रूट यूजर होता है। जो भी रूट यूजर है,
उसका होम डायरेक्टरी जैसे वही डॉक्यूमेंट,
डाउनलोड, पिक्चर ये सब चीजें होती है।
लाइव लिब जो होती है, वह सिस्टम
लाइब्रेरीज़ के लिए होती हैं। ऑप्ट जो होता
है, ऑप्शनल ऐड ऑन एप्लीकेशन सॉफ्टवेयर
पैकेज होते हैं। ऑप्ट के अंदर में ऑप्शनल
ऐड ऑन एप्लीकेशन सॉफ्टवेयर पैकेजेस होते
हैं। कुछ ऑप्शनल पैकेजेस होते हैं
सॉफ्टवेयर के वह ऑप्ट के अंदर जो है वह
आपको देखने को मिल जाएगा। एमएटी जो होते
हैं वह उसको माउंट पॉइंट बोलते हैं। फाइल
सिस्टम्स के लिए माउंट पॉइंट यानी कि आपके
सिस्टम में जो भी अ चीजें कनेक्ट हो रही
है वो माउंट होती है। कहीं लinक्स के अंदर
में ये भी चीज़ एक कांसेप्ट है। आप सबको
जानना चाहिए। जैसे Windows में आप
पेनड्राइव लगाते हो अपने Windows के अंदर
में। तो क्या होता है? पेनड्राइव आपके
सामने ओपन हो के आ जाती है या आप
पेनड्राइव को एक्सेस कर कर पाते हो। राइट?
बट वो पेनड्राइव एक्चुअली होता क्या है
उसके साथ? पेनड्राइव जो है ना वो एक्चुअली
माउंट होती है। पेनड्राइव गेट्स माउंटेड
ऑन योर सिस्टम एंड वो एक लोकेशन पे माउंट
होती है। उसी तरह से लinx में भी जब आप
पेनड्राइव या कोई भी एक्सटर्नल डिवाइस कुछ
भी लगाते हो अपना एक डिस्क लगाते हो वो
माउंट होता है और वो माउंट एमएटी वाला जो
फोल्डर है या डायरेक्टरी है उसी को हम
माउंट पॉइंट बोलते हैं। स्लैश मीडिया
रिमूवेबल मीडिया के लिए। अब यह जो माउंट
पॉइंट है यह आपके फाइल सिस्टम्स के लिए भी
माउंट पॉइंट हो सकता है और रिमूवेबल
मीडिया को भी आप इसमें माउंट कर सकते हो
आप चाहो तो लेकिन एक और डायरेक्टरी होती
है स्लैश मीडिया ये डिफॉल्ट एक माउंट
पॉइंट होता है जो आप रिमूवेबल मीडिया ओनली
डालते हो जैसे पेन ड्राइव वगैरह हो गई या
कोई भी फ्लैश ड्राइव डाला तो बाय डिफॉल्ट
वो स्लैश मीडिया पे माउंट हो जाएगा लेकिन
आप उसको अगर परमानेंटली चाहते हो माउंट
करना एक फिक्स फिक्स्ड उस पे पाथ पे तो आप
एमए टी पे माउंट उसको कर सकते हो। अब ये
माउंटिंग का कांसेप्ट अलग है। इट डजंट नीड
इट्स नॉट रिक्वायर्ड फॉर यू एज एन एसओसी
वन बट आपको समझ में आना चाहिए कि एक
रिमूवेबल मीडिया के लिए माउंट पॉइंट है
मीडिया। और एक सिस्टम फाइल्स के लिए या जो
सॉरी फाइल सिस्टम्स जो होती हैं जो सिस्टम
की डायरेक्ट पार्टीशंस यू कैन से लinx के
अंदर आप बोलो या डिस्कस यू कैन से उनके
अमाउंट के लिए एमएटी होता है। अब जैसे मैं
आपको यहां पे दिखा देता हूं। ठीक है?
हां मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं। जैसे
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] कि मैं यहां पर
फाइल सिस्टम में गया। मैं यहां पे यहां
आपको एमएटी दिख जाएगा। कहां है एमएटी? ये
रहा एमएटी। अब एमएटी पे जब आप चलोगे तो
यहां पे एचजी एफएस करके एक डायरेक्टरी बनी
है। इसके अंदर जाओगे तो आपको फिलहाल कुछ
नहीं दिखेगा। व्यू पे भी क्लिक करके शो
हिडन फाइल्स भी करोगे कुछ भी आपको नहीं
दिखेगा। क्योंकि यहां पे कोई भी सिस्टम
अभी जो चीजें हैं वो माउंट नहीं हुई है।
अब मैं आपको दिखाता हूं इसका मतलब क्या
है। मैं राइट क्लिक करता हूं। ओपन टर्मिनल
करता हूं।
इसको बड़ा करते हैं थोड़ा सा। क्या हुआ
भाई? [गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
अब मैं आपको यहां पे दिखाता हूं। डीएफ हफन
एच एक कमांड होती है। मैंने उस कमांड को
रन किया है। ठीक है? डीएफ hफन एच ये कमांड
मैंने रन किया है। चलो मैं इसको HT कर
देता हूं। ज्यादा अच्छा से नोट नोटेशन
अच्छा होगा यहां पे। तो मैंने यहां पे
डीएफ हफन HT कमांड एक चलाया हुआ है। अब ये
कमांड एग्जैक्टली मैंने क्यों चलाया मैं
आपको बताता हूं। मैंने आपके ये कमांड
इसलिए चलाया ताकि मैं दिखा पाऊं कि लinक्स
में
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] जो फाइल
सिस्टम्स होते हैं जो भी फाइल सिस्टम मतलब
उसके अंदर जोज अ इंपॉर्टेंट डायरेक्टरीज
या इंपॉर्टेंट अ पार्टीशंस बोल लो अभी के
लिए पार्टीशंस होते हैं वो सब कहीं ना
कहीं पे माउंटेड होते हैं। तभी वो यूज़ में
आते हैं। जैसे कि लinक्स में ये सारे फाइल
सिस्टम है। पहला कॉलम जिसमें कि आपका
स्लैश डेव्ल एसडीएन ये आपका डिस्क है जो
आपका जो मेन हार्ड डिस्क है ना वो यही है
स्लैश डेव डिवाइसेस एसडीएन तो ये डिस्क
जिसमें पूरा लinक्स इंस्टॉल है जो आपने
लinक्स इंस्टॉल किया है जितनी डिवाइस में
जितनी आपने स्पेस दी है वो सब इसी में है
ये आपका डिस्क है मान के चल लो दिस इज़
Windows C ड्राइव मान के चलो तो ये भी यूज़
में आ रहा है। क्यों? क्योंकि ये माउंटेड
है। माउंटेड ऑन किस पे? स्लैश पे माउंटेड
है। दिस इज़ ऑलरेडी माउंटेड ऑन। तो हम उस
किसी भी पार्टीशन को बिना माउंट किए यूज़
कर ही नहीं सकते। किसी भी पार्टीशन को।
Windows में भी जो पार्टीशन हम यूज़ करते
हैं वो भी माउंटेड ही होता है। बट हम
Windows के केस में बहुत ज्यादा डीप नहीं
जाते। बहुत ज्यादा नहीं समझते हैं। मजा
नहीं आता है। इस वजह से Linux में हर चीज़
ओपन है। सब कुछ दिखता है। तो Linux में इस
चीज़ को हम समझ रहे हैं कि यह भी माउंटेड
है। अब [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] जैसे
यहां पे कोई एक डायरेक्टरी है स्लश TMPFS
ये भी इस डायरेक्टरी पे माउंटेड है। इस पे
माउंटेड है। तो हर चीज़ एक लोकेशन पे
माउंटेड होती है। तो Linux में अगर आप नया
कोई डिस्क बनाते हैं। एसडीए वन के जगह पे
मान लो आप एसडीए 2 बनाते हैं। एसडीए 3
बनाते हैं। ऐसा करके पार्टीशन टाइप बनाते
हो। जैसे Windows में CD यह बनाते हो ना
Linux में भी ऐसा 1 2 3 एसडीए 1 2 3 स्पेस
अगर जितना है बना सकते हो। तो उसको आप
माउंट कर सकते हो। तो वैसे ही चीजों को
वैसे ही डिस्क को माउंट जब आप करेंगे तो
उसको आप करेंगे एमए टी पे। जो ये एमए
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] टी है इसके
ऊपर में आप माउंट करेंगे जो कि मैंने आपको
यहां पे बताया फाइल सिस्टम्स को। और अगर
कोई पेन ड्राइव वगैरह लगा रहे हैं कुछ
फ्लैश ड्राइव मेमोरी कार्ड अलग से कुछ लगा
रहे हैं वो सब यहां पे रिमूवेबल मीडिया पे
आपके माउंट हो जाता है। मीडिया वाले
सेक्शन पे माउंट हो जाता है। चलो इसका हम
लाइव एग्जांपल देख सकते हैं क्या? लेट्स
सी इफ इफ इट इफ इट्स पॉसिबल
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
मैं देखता हूं पॉसिबल है कि नहीं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
तो मैं यहां पर ट्राई करता हूं। एक
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] एक पेनड्राइव
यूज़ कर रहा हूं मैं। ये ड्यूल ड्यूल
ड्राइव है। बेसिकली अ एक साइड में टाइप सी
है एसके और एक साइड में यहां पे टाइप ए
है। टाइप सी MacBook में यूज़ हो जाता है।
टाइप ए जो है Windows वाली जो नॉर्मल USB
होती है उसमें यूज़ में आ जाता है। तो
व्हाट आई एम गोइंग टू डू, अभी आप जैसे
फाइल सिस्टम में हम चलते हैं। अभी हम इसका
एक डायरेक्टरी है मीडिया। राइट? ये वाली
मीडिया डायरेक्टरी है। तो हम इस मीडिया
डायरेक्टरी में चलते हैं। यहां पे इस
मीडिया डायरेक्टरी में ओपन करते हैं। तो
यहां पे मीडिया डायरेक्टरी में अभी कुछ भी
आपको नहीं दिख रहा है। राइट? नथिंग इज़
शोइंग हियर। कुछ भी यहां पे नहीं दिख रहा।
प्लस यहां टर्मिनल में हमने जब ओपन किया
था तो हमने जब डीएफ हफ HTT किया तो यहां
पे फाइल सिस्टम्स ये सारे आ रहे थे। राइट?
जो कि अलग-अलग जगह पे माउंटेड थे। राइट?
अब हम यहां पे हम
मीडिया में चलते हैं। इस तरीके से आ रहा
है। अब मैं इस डायरेक्टरी मतलब इस
पेनड्राइव को मैं यूज़ यहां पे लगा रहा
हूं। ठीक है? एक USB ड्राइव में यहां पे
लगा रहा हूं। एंड लेट्स सी व्हाट इज़
हैपनिंग। अब यहां पे आ रहा है कनेक्ट टू
होस्ट यानी Windows से कनेक्ट करने का
ऑप्शन आ रहा है या तो कनेक्ट टू वर्चुअल
मशीन काली में। तो ये दोनों चीज़ ऑप्शन आ
रहा है। तो मैं यहां पे क्या कर रहा हूं?
ओके काली वाला सेलेक्ट करके एंड अ ओके कर
लेता हूं। जैसे ही मैंने ओके किया तो अब
ये लिख रहा है द डिवाइस सडि 3.2 जेनए वाज़
अनेबल टू कनेक्ट टू इट्स आइडियल होस्ट
कंट्रोलर अटेम्प्ट विल बी मेड टू कनेक्ट।
ठीक है कोई बात नहीं मैं ओके करता हूं। तो
मैंने अब इसको
विंड इस सिस्टम में वर्चुअल मशीन में
ट्राई करा है कनेक्ट करने का। लेट्स सी
व्हाट इज़ हैपनिंग। मैं बैक करता हूं।
लेट्स सी इफ इट इज़ माउंटेड ऑ नॉट। सीडी
रोम में यहां पे
डायरेक्ट आना चाहिए। बट आई थिंक कि यह
कनेक्ट नहीं हुआ है शायद। लेट्स सी
सैंड डिस्क कनेक्ट टू होस्ट। कनेक्टेड तो
है। लेट्स क्लोज़ इट। लेट्स इसको ऐसे करते
हैं।
एंड देयर इज नो
नहीं वो काली ले ये कौन सी है?
ये तो काली का है। दिस इज़ नॉट हियर। एक
बार चेक कर लेते हैं इस तरीके से कमांड
से। इट इज़ कनेक्टेड ऑ नॉट। मैं अब कमांड
डालता हूं डीएफ हफ HTT फिर से। एंड लेट्स
सी इफ देयर इज़ समथिंग। यस यस। अ बट ना दिस
इज तो ये आईएसओ फाइल बनी हुई है क्या सीडी
ड्राइव में? ओके आई थिंक
नहीं बट इसकी स्पेस तो ज्यादा है। ओके मैं
एक बार देखता हूं इसकी स्पेस ज्यादा है या
कम है। मैं इसको कनेक्ट टू होस्ट करता हूं
और विंडोज़ में देखते हैं इसको।
नहीं दिस देयर इज़ नो
इज़ देयर एनी सीडी ड्राइव
अ अ मतलब वो तो नहीं है ना इसमें काली
नहीं है। सो इट्स नॉट कनेक्टिंग। सो लेट्स
कनेक्ट हियर। कनेक्ट नहीं हो रहा है। मुझे
डाउट था बट लेट्स सी। कनेक्ट होता तो मैं
आपको दिखा देता।
लेट्स कनेक्ट।
ओके। यहां पे कुछ इशू आ रहा है। एन
अटेम्प्ट विल बी मेड टू कनेक्ट दिस डिवाइस
टू द बेस्ट अवेलेबल होस्ट कंट्रोलर। दिस
माइट रिजल्ट इन अन वाज़ अनेबल टू कनेक्ट टू
इट्स आइडियल होस्ट कंट्रोलर। आइडियल होस्ट
कंटेनर से कनेक्ट हो अबाउट टू अनप्लग
फ्रॉम द होस्ट एंड कनेक्ट कनेक्ट इट विल
बी फर्स्ट स्टॉप ठीक लीक है द डिवाइस इज़
सेफली रिमूव्ड ओके लेट्स सी इफ इट इज़
गेटिंग कनेक्टेड हियर
ये वाली नहीं हो पा रही है। कोई और पेन
ड्राइव यूज़ कर लेंगे। नहीं हो रही है तो
क्योंकि यह कनेक्ट नहीं हो रहा है। इसका
रीज़न मैं आपको बताता हूं
क्योंकि यहां पे हमारे लिस्ट में ये आ ही
नहीं रहा। लिस्ट में ये आना चाहिए बट
लिस्ट में हमारे नहीं आ रहा। राइट? सो डू
वन थिंग। लेट्स डू वन थिंग। एक और कोई पेन
ड्राइव मैं देखता हूं। इफ देयर इज़ सम पेन
ड्राइव।
ओके आई एम सीइंग गाइस इफ देयर इज वन मोर
पेनड्राइव
प्लीज वेट प्लीज वेट
चलो एक और पेनड्राइव मुझे मिली है। मैं उस
पेनड्राइव को यूज़ करके अ ट्राई करता हूं
यूज़ करने का। तो इसको मैं यहां से हटा
देता हूं। फिलहाल के लिए होस्ट से कनेक्ट
करके वापस से कर देता हूं। और यहां से मैं
इसको इजेक्ट कर देता हूं। ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
सो लेट्स इजेक्ट इट।
ठीक है? [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
एंड लेट्स नाउ
कनेक्ट
अनदर वन। अनदर पेनड्राइव। तो मेरे पास एक
और पेनड्राइव है। मैं उसको लगा के देखता
हूं। कनेक्ट टू वर्चुअल मशीन करते हैं
इसको। लेट्स सी।
काली ओके [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] एंड
लेट्स सी व्हाट इज हैपनिंग यप दिस गॉट
कनेक्टेड दिस गॉट कनेक्टेड गाइस इट्स गॉट
कनेक्टेड वो पेनड्राइव का कुछ होगा इशू
होगा कोई बात नहीं है यहां पे मीडिया में
अ सीडी रोम के अंदर में आपको यहां पे
कनेक्टेड यहां मिल चुका है बेसिकली ये तो
काली लinक्स वाली सीडी रोम है ये वाली
नहीं ये वाली तो उसमें है अब मैं आपको
दिखाता हूं यहां पे अ ये रहा डेफोनिक्स यह
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स नाम से पेनड्राइव कनेक्ट हो
चुकी है। अगर आपको नहीं पता लाइक लेट्स
सपोज कि इफ यू डोंट नो वेयर इट इज करेंटली
तो मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं कि यही नाम से
है प्रेजेंट है। मैं यहां से मूव करता हूं
रिमूवेबल डिस्क एंड सैंड डिस्क क्रूज़र
ब्लेड करके पेनड्राइव है। मैं इसको
डिस्कनेक्ट करता हूं। कनेक्ट टू होस्ट
करता हूं। एंड यहां पे मैं दिखा रहा हूं।
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स नाम से यहां पे इसके अंदर कुछ
फाइल्स हैं। एम्प्ट फाइव फॉरेंसिक्स और ये
सब कुछ फाइल्स हैं। आपको दिख रही होंगी।
तो यह पेनड्राइव है। राइट? तो दिस
पेनड्राइव इज़ बीइंग कनेक्टेड। अब मैं आपको
यहां पे शो करता हूं। देखो क्या होता क्या
है। वीएम में गया। रिमूवेबल डिस्क में
गया। सैंड डिस्क में कनेक्ट करता हूं यहां
पे।
अब यहां पे ये कनेक्ट हो गया। यहां पे आ
चुका है। ये कनेक्ट हो चुका है। अब यहां
पे जब मैं पे रू इस पे जाऊंगा। अब मैं
यहां पे सेम कमांड चलाऊंगा। डीएफ hन ht
व्हाट विल हैपन?
व्हाट विल हैपन? से
अभी भी मेरा पेनड्राइव यहां पे शो नहीं
करेगा। आप देखोगे मेरा जो पेन ड्राइव है
यह किसकी है? यह देखो
यह देखो यहां पर आ रहा है यह। अरे भाई
क्या है? यहां पे अभी भी वो पेनड्राइव शो
नहीं हो रही है। ऐसा क्यों हो रहा है? ऐसा
क्यों हो रहा है? इसका रीज़न क्या है? इसका
रीज़न है कि जब इस पेनड्राइव वाली
डायरेक्टरी पे आप इस तरह से होवर करोगे,
तो यहां लिखा रहेगा माउंटेड एट नॉट
माउंटेड। अब देखो वहां पे लिखा होगा। आप
ध्यान से देखो। वहां पे लिखा होगा माउंटेड
एट नॉट माउंटेड। लिखा दिख रहा है आपको
कहीं पे कहीं पे आपको लिखा हुआ दिख रहा है
माउंटेड एट नॉट माउंटेड आर यू ऑल सीइंग
लेट मी नो [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
करेक्ट क्योंकि ये अभी माउंट नहीं है। ये
हमारे पास डिटेक्ट हो चुकी है। बट इट्स
नॉट माउंटेड। तो अभी यहां पे मैं इसको डबल
क्लिक करता हूं। यहां पे ओपन करता हूं। तो
इसके अंदर की चीजें जो है आपको यहां पे
देखने को मिल जाएगी जो चीजें हैं। लेकिन
यह माउंटेड नहीं। अभी मैं इस पे हॉवर करके
ले जाऊंगा। तो जैसे ही जैसे ही मैंने इसको
मतलब जैसे ही मैंने इसको ओपन किया ना इस
पेनड्राइव को एक्सेस करने के लिए जैसे ही
तो इसके अंदर की फाइल्स दिख गई मुझे।
फाइल्स हो गई वैसे ही ये ऑटोमेटिकली माउंट
हो गया। क्योंकि मैंने आपको पहले ही बोला
था कि किसी भी डिवाइस को किसी भी पार्टीशन
को बिना माउंट किए आप यूज़ कर ही नहीं
सकते। तो यहां पे एक रिमूवेबल ड्राइव वाइस
केस में क्या हुआ कि पहले यह नॉट माउंटेड
था। जैसे ही मैंने डबल क्लिक करके ओपन
किया ये यूज़ में आया और यूज़ में आया तो
Linux को इसको यूज़ करने के लिए पहले माउंट
करना पड़ा। जो रूल है जो जो जिस तरीके से
रूल काम करता है उसी तरीके से होगा। राइट?
उसको चेंज नहीं कर सकते उस रूल को। तो
यहां पे माउंट हो चुका है। अब ये माउंट
कहां हुआ है? माउंटेड एट स्लश रन स्लैश
मीडिया स्लैश रूट स्लैश डिफ्रॉनिक्स। इस
पाथ पे ये माउंट हुआ है रन वाली पाथ पे।
ठीक है? तो माउंट खैर कहीं भी हो सकता है।
मैं यहां पे मीडिया पे चलता हूं। यहां पे
फिलहाल तो मीडिया में ये सीडी रोम और ये
सारी चीजें माउंटेड है इस तरीके से। बट
यहां पे जो ये रन डायरेक्टरी है यहां पे
ये बाय डिफॉल्ट माउंट हुआ है। रन के अंदर
में ये माउंट हुआ है। तो कई बार जब सिस्टम
ऑटो माउंट करती है तो वो अपना जो पाथ है
जैसे लinक्स काली की मैं बात करूं यहां पे
तो यहां पे इसने रन के अंदर में इस चीज को
माउंट कर दिया है। तो यहां पे रन के अंदर
में मीडिया नाम की डायरेक्टरी जो है इसके
अंदर यहां पे ये माउंट हो चुका है। इसके
अंदर एक रूट डायरेक्टरी है और रूट
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर डिफ्रॉनिक्स माउंट हुआ
है। अब यही चीज़ आपको इस कमांड के थ्रू भी
देखने को मिल जाएगी। अभी तक कमांड में
नहीं आ रहा था ना यह जो चीज़ है। अब इसका
नाम क्या है भैया? व्हाट इज़ द नेम? देखो
देखो ये वाली नहीं यार ये वाली नहीं। अ
रूट वाली ये वाली। ये डेफ़्रॉनिक्स है। मैं
राइट क्लिक करता हूं। प्रॉपर्टीज पे जाता
हूं। अभी तुम्हें यहां पे दिख रहा है।
इसका नाम है डेव SDB1। इसका नाम क्या है?
इसका नाम क्या है?
डेव एसdv1
डेव्ल एसdb1 इसका नाम है। हर लinक्स के
पार्टीशन का नाम जैसे Windows में सी डी ई
एफ जी एच आई जे के एल एम एन ओ पी क्यू आर
होता है ना वही लinक्स में स्लैश डेव से
स्टार्ट होता है। फिर एसडीए वन एसडीए टू
या एसडीबी वन एसडीबी टू या एसडीc वन
एसडीसी टू ऐसे चलता है। तो ये एसडीबी वन
से नाम है। अब इस नाम को मैं कंफर्म कर
देता हूं कमांड के थ्रू। तो जब आप कमांड
में अब आप डीएफ हफन एचटी मैं चालू कर इशू
करूंगा कमांड तो अब एक और यहां पे पहले
देखो डेव SR0 के नीचे कुछ नहीं आ रहा था।
ठीक है? यहां पे अब आ रहा है डेव SDB वन
जो कि एक हमारी 30 GB यानी कि 32 GB की
पेनड्राइव है जिसमें यूज़ इतना है। इतना
अवेलेबल है। 5% यूज़ हुआ है। और यह माउंट
कहां हुआ है? रन मीडिया रूट डिफ़ॉन नाम के
डायरेक्टरी पे। आप इसको कहीं भी माउंट कर
सकते हो। Linx में आप खुद से भी माउंटिंग
कर सकते हो। इसका एक लोकेशन होता है। इसकी
एक इसका भी एक तरीका होता है। उस पे हम
नहीं जा रहे हैं। वो लinक्स का एक पार्ट
है। इट डज़ंट लाइक रिलेट टू योर एसओसीएल
वन। बिलकुल आपको उसकी जरूरत आपको नहीं
पड़ती है। राइट? एफ एफ डिस्क वगैरह करके
आप देख सकते हो। देयर आर थिंग्स दैट
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यू कैन गो
एंड माउंट एंड ऑल। एफएस टैब करके एक होती
है जगह होती है। उसमें माउंट कर सकते हो।
मैं आपको अगर वो दिखाना चाहूं तो कैट ईटीc
एफएस टैब करके एक जगह होती है जहां पे आप
मैनुअली माउंट करते हो किसी भी डिवाइस को।
अब यहां पे जो चीजें आप जहां पे माउंट
करना चाहोगे ना जिस भी डायरेक्टरी में वो
परमानेंट माउंट हो जाएगी। रीबूट होने के
बाद भी उसी पे माउंट होगी हर जगह पे। तो
यह एक एफएस टैब है। जब यह ले आरएचसीएसए
रेड हट सिस्टम एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर की पढ़ाई या
lein सिस्टम एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर की जब जो
पढ़ाई-वढ़ाई करते हैं वो ये सब चीजें
सीखते हैं उनके लिए जरूरी होता है।
हालांकि क्योंकि मैंने भी किया हुआ है तो
मुझे याद है क्योंकि अब तो वो मैं मुझे या
सब किए हुए हैं
आई थिंक मुझे टाइम
2016 10 साल से ऊपर हो गए इस चीज को किए
हुए। बट फिर भी थोड़ा बहुत दिमाग में था
तो मैंने ये चीज आपको दिखा दी है। ठीक है?
तो एफएस टैब के अंदर ये चीजें माउंट होती
है। तो इस तरीके से जो मैंने आपको बताया
डीएफ हफन एचटी से अब आपको ये चीजें क्लियर
दिख रही हैं। तो अब आपको समझ में आई थिंक
आ चुका होगा कि किस तरीके से ये चीज काम
कर रहा है। आपको एकदम क्लियर हुआ इस ये
चीज बताइए मुझे।
माउंट हफन ए जो है पीतांबर उसको हम जब सब
माउंटिंग वगैरह कर लो तो वो चला के देखते
हैं कि काइंड ऑफ कि माउंटिंग सब कुछ सही
है अगर कोई उसी में कोई कुछ ट्रबल शूटिंग
कुछ एरर भी आ जाती है ना डिबगिंग टाइप भी
हो जाता है आपका तो वो भी आपको शो कर देता
है कि हां यहां पे कुछ गड़बड़ है। अगर
माउंट हफन ए का रिजल्ट बिलकुल ओके आया कुछ
भी एरर नहीं आया कुछ भी मतलब एवरीथिंग इज़
फ़ाइन यू हैव डन ऑल माउंटिंग एंड ऑल सब कुछ
सही ये चीज़ है
यस क्लियर हो गया ये थी आपकी पूरी
माउंटिंग की कहानी ऐसे काम करता है डिवाइस
चाहे Linux हो Windows हो डजंट मैटर माउंट
जो चीज है माउंटिंग जो चीज है वो ऐसे ही
काम करता है हर जगह पे बस अब यहां से आप
अनमाउंट कर दोगे ना खत्म अब अनमाउंट करने
का कमांड होता है अनमाउंट नहीं होता है यू
माउंट होता यू माउंट। अब यू माउंट आप
करोगे ना तो यू माउंट के बाद आपको यह इसका
पाथ देना होता है। तो क्या है? स्लैश डेव
सॉरी स्लैश डेव स्लश एसdb1
ये होता है कमांड। अब एंटर करोगे तो ये
अनमाउंट हो गई। अब तुम डीएफ हफ एचटी करोगे
ना तो यहां तुम्हें नहीं दिखेगी। ये देखो
यू आर नॉट सीइंग हियर दैट व्हाई दैट
एसडीबी वन क्योंकि हमने उसको अनमाउंट कर
दिया है। अब तुम देखोगे तो यहां पे जो
तुम्हें पहले दिख रही थी मीडिया के अंदर
रूट यहीं पे थे ना रन के अंदर में मीडिया
मीडिया के अंदर में हम जाएंगे रूट के अंदर
तो अब हमें यहां पे कुछ भी नहीं दिखेगा।
वो गायब हो गई क्योंकि हमने अनमाउंट कर
दिया है। अब इसको मैं तुमको लाइव एग्जांपल
के थ्रू दिखा देता हूं।
Linx का लाइव मजेदार लाइव चीज दिखाता हूं
तुम्हें।
एसडीबी वन नाम था ना
मैं यहां पर करता हूं माउंट सव्ल
एसdb1 ये किया और यहां पे देखना मैंने
एंटर किया कांट फाइंड इन ईटीc एफएस टैब अब
ये इसको फाइंड नहीं कर पा रहा जब मैंने
माउंट किया स्लैश डेव्ल एसडीबी वन को ऐसा
ये नहीं ये इसको माउंट नहीं कर रहा इसका
रीज़न ये है कि ये इसको ईटीसीfs टाइम में
फाइंड नहीं कर रहा जब माउंट हम करते हैं
तो ईटीसीएफs स्टेप से उठाता है ये। तो ये
माउंट करने पे ये काम नहीं कर रहा। लेकिन
अब जब मैं डिफ़्रॉनिक्स को यहां पे यहां से
मान लो चलो इसको हटाओ। इसको मैं ऐसे कर
देता हूं। अब मैं डेस्कटॉप पे चलता हूं।
और ये रही। अब मैं इसको ओपन करता हूं।
जैसे ही ओपन करूंगा ना देखो ऑटोमेटिकली
माउंट हो गई। क्योंकि ये टेंपरेरी माउंट
के लिए देखो डिफ्रॉनिक्स आ गया
ऑटोमेटिकली। और जैसे ही मैं यहां से यह
देखना इसको मैं जैसे ही अनमाउंट करूंगा यह
डिफ्रॉनिक्स गायब हो जाएगी।
डिफ्रॉनिक्स हैज़ बीन गायब।
ठीक है? समझ में आ गया? इस तरीके से माउंट
अनमाउंट काम करता है।
एवरीवन गॉट
बता दीजिए मुझे। इफ यू गॉट दिस आई विल मूव
फॉरवर्ड।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
हम यह ऑटोमेटिक माउंटिंग हुआ है। मैनुअल
माउंटिंग के लिए एफएस टैब में एंट्री करनी
होती है। आप किसी भी पाथ पर माउंट कर सकते
हैं। ठीक है? उसके लिए कोई इशू नहीं। तो
ये आपकी माउंट हुई ऑटोमेटिक। अब इसको
एक और चीज है।
एक होती है अ कैट ईटीसी
अ
स्ल प्रॉक स्लश पार्टीशंस ये एक लोकेशन
होती है। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ये
लोकेशनेशंस है प्रॉक सैश पार्टीशंस। ये भी
एक लोकेशन होती है। कैट का मतलब होता है
एक पर्टिकुलर लोकेशन पे जो भी फाइल्स
वगैरह हैं उसको दिखाओ। जो भी उसके कंटेंट
है वो दिखाओ। इसलिए कैट कमांड का यूज़ किया
जाता है। ठीक है? तो स्लश प्रॉप एक
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर में पार्टीशन नाम की
फाइल है। उसके अंदर में ये एंट्रीज होती
हैं। जिसमें आपको दिख रहा होगा कि यहां पे
एक एसडीबी वन की भी पार्टीशन है जो यहां
पे बनी हुई है एंड यहां पे लिस्टेड है।
गॉट इट? हां। एक चीज़ और अभी ये माउंटेड है
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स। देखो माउंटेड एंड रन मीडिया।
मैं इसको रन राइट क्लिक करके अनमाउंट कर
देता हूं। अनमाउंट किया। अनमाउंट फिनिश।
अनमाउंट हो गया। अब मैं डीएफ हफन H टी
करता हूं। तो यहां पे वो एसडीबी वन नहीं
दिख रहा है। अब मैं यहां पे प्रॉप
पार्टीशंस करता हूं। यहां पे ये स्टिल
दिखेगा। तो अगर आपके सिस्टम में इसका मतलब
क्या हुआ? अगर आपके सिस्टम में कोई
पेनड्राइव या कोई रिमूवेबल ड्राइव लगी है
और मान लो कि कोई तेज बन रहा है। उसने
अनमाउंट भी कर दिया है। आपको चेक करना है
कि भैया सच में वो अभी भी है। अनमाउंट हो
गया। अभी भी है या सिस्टम से खत्म हो चुका
है। अगर स्लश प्रॉप पार्टीशंस इस लोकेशन
पे वह दिखने लगे तो समझो वो आपके सिस्टम
में अभी भी लगा ही हुआ है। भले वो
अनमाउंटेड है बट लगा हुआ है।
तो उसको माउंट किया जा सकता है। दैट्स इट।
ठीक है भैया? समझ में आ गया? तो ये माउंट
अनमाउंट की कहानी है आपके सिस्टम के अंदर
में। यहां पे जो हमने इसके अंदर में देखा
है। तो मैं यहां पे अनमाउंट कर चुका हूं।
अब [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] इस भैया
जी को जो है इसको मैं यहां से निकाल देता
हूं। यहां से हटा देता हूं और होस्ट से
क्या करूंगा? रिमूव कर दूंगा। राइट?
सो इट्स बीन रिमूव्ड।
ओके गॉट इट?
खत्म कहानी ट
आई होप कि माय ऑडियो इज़ क्लियर। क्रिस्टल
क्लियर। हेलो हेलो हेलो हेलो हेलो हेलो
हेलो सही है भाई। ऑडियो ऑडियो तो सही है
ना? हां ऑडियो तो सही लग रही है।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
हां
इंटरेस्टिंग मजा आया। हां पेनड्राइव निकाल
दी भाई। पेन पेनड्राइव निकाल के तो नहीं
आएगा यार। पेनड्राइव निकाल के थोड़ी ना
आएगा। पेनड्राइव मैंने ये कर लिया। अब मैं
यहां पे कैट प्रॉप पार्टीशन करूंगा तो
नहीं आएगा। मतलब पेनड्राइव निकाल दोगे तो
क्यों आएगा यहां पे? ये भी तो सोचो। जैसे
ही मैंने डिवाइस निकाला पेनड्राइव।
पेनड्राइव निकाल दिया मैंने। यह देखो मेरे
पेन यह जो सैंडisk की क्रूज़र ब्लेड यह
पेनड्राइव मेरे हाथ में आ चुकी है। मैंने
निकाला यहां पे खत्म हो गई। राइट? यहां से
निकल चुकी है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यह कांसेप्ट क्लियर हो गया? इतने डिटेल
में नहीं बताएगा भाई। कोई तुम्हें पैसे
लेगा उसके बताने की। भाई इतने डिटेल में
कोई नहीं बताएगा तुम्हें बिना पैसे लिए।
तुम बात समझ के रखो इस बात को। लेकिन
वैल्यू नहीं है यार लोगों को। चलो आज तो
60 लोग हैं। अच्छा अच्छा लग रहा है कम से
कम। आज थोड़े ज्यादा लोग हैं। 50 को क्रॉस
कर चुके हैं। [हंसी] तो इट्स गुड।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
हां [हंसी]
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] उसी
तरीके से जैसे मैंने यहां पे बताया आपको
ऑप्ट वाला एमएटी मीडिया ये क्लियर हो गया।
एसआरवी होता है सर्विस डाटा वगैरह होती
है। कुछ खास आपके यूज़ में नहीं आने वाला
है। S एक डायरेक्टरी होती है। ये कर्नल
रिलेटेड इनेशन होती है। सिमिलर टू प्रॉक
बट मोर डिटेल। सिस में प्रॉक की तरह ही
होता है बट और डिटेल होता है और प्रॉक
जिसका अभी हमने देखा प्रॉप पार्टीशंस
वर्चुअल फाइल सिस्टम कंटेनिंग इनेशन अबाउट
द सिस्टम यानी कि प्रोसेस इनेशन नेटवर्क
स्टेटस या फाइल सिस्टम के बारे में सब
बताता है। जैसे हमने अभी देखा प्रॉक के
अंदर ही एक फाइल थी पार्टीशन उसमें
पार्टीशन की डिटेल प्रॉक के अंदर ही और भी
फाइल्स होती है। जैसे अगर मैं इसको सीडी
अ प्रॉक करूं अ सीडी प्रॉक इसके अंदर चले
एस एलएस करेंगे तो इसके अंदर बहुत सारी
यहां पे डायरेक्टरीज़ एंड फाइल्स देखने को
मिलेंगी। इसी में आपको जो था वो क्या मिला
था देखने को? कहां गया? कहां गया? ये
पार्टीशंस देखने को मिला था। ठीक है? इसी
के अंदर में आपको यहां पे मिलेगा एक वर्जन
भी। तो मैं यहां पे दिखाऊंगा तो अगर मैं
दिखाऊं कैट प्रॉक और मैं वर्जन कर दूं तो
ये आपके सिस्टम का लinक्स जो भी आप यूज़ कर
रहे हैं फिलहाल लinक्स कर्नल उसका वर्जन
वगैरह पूरा डिटेल में आपको बता देगा। ये
सारी चीजें बता देगा। ठीक है? मेमोरी की
इनफो चाहिए तो यहां पे वर्जन करके यहां पे
एक एक फाइल है मेम इनफो। तो आप मेम इनफो
कर दीजिए। तो आपकी मेमोरी इनफो जो है वह
अभी करंट की आपको यह पूरी डिटेल में
बताएगा कि टोटल मेमोरी कितनी है 4GB
फ्री मेमोरी कितनी है लगभग 2.2GB
ठीक है मेमोरी अवेलेबल कितना है लगभग इतना
तो ये सारी चीजें आपको देखने को मिलेगी
कैश मेमोरी कितनी है सब कुछ आपको मिलेगी
तो हर चीज़ जो है Linux में आपको अब Linux
में किसी भी डायरेक्टरी में आप हो किसी भी
डायरेक्टरी में हो LS करो उसके अंदर की
सारी चीज़ मिल जाएंगी उसके अलावा एक एक और
मस्त चीज क्या है कि अगर आपको देखना है
कैट अब मुझे स्लैश प्रॉक पी आर पता है टैब
मारो प्रॉक कंप्लीट हो जाएगा अब मुझे मैम
का पता है मुझे मैम इनफो कमांड नहीं पता
मुझे मैम पता है मेम कुछ होता है मेम लिखो
और टैब मारो पूरा कंप्लीट हो जाएगा ये एक
खूबी है लinक्स में तो जिसको प्रैक्टिस हो
जाती है वो पूरा पूरा पाथ नहीं लिखते हैं
वो बस शॉर्ट में एक दो लेटर लिखा और आगे
बढ़ते रहे और टैब मार मार के करते रहे काम
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ठीक ठीक है?
गॉट इट। चलिए आगे की तरफ बढ़ते हैं।
ये सारी [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
चीजें आपको क्लियर हो चुकी होंगी। ये सारे
अंदर में डायरेक्टरीज होते हैं Linux के
अंदर में। अब यहां पे आते हैं सिस्टम
आर्किटेक्चर को थोड़ा डिटेल में और वाइड
डिटेल में। ठीक है? और व डिटेल में देखते
हैं। देखो यहां पे लinक्स फाइल सिस्टम
आर्किटेक्चर में जैसा मैंने बताया वही
चीजें सब चीजें जो मैंने अभी बताई उसको
थोड़ा सा समझते हैं। इसमें क्या-क्या होती
है। अब रूट होता है। चलो भाई स्लैश के
अंदर आपका रूट होता है। उसके अलावा आपका
बिन होता है। ईटीसी होता है। एसbिन यूएसआर
वेयर डेव होम लिब एमएटी ऑप्ट प्रॉक ये
आपका रूट जो है वो रूट जो भी है।
अब यह बिन जो है उसके बारे में मैंने
बताया कि यूजर बाइनरी एग्जीक्यूटेबल्स
होते हैं। जैसे कि आपका यह सारे बैश,
कैट्स, डेट, इको, गैब ये सब एग्जीक्यूटेबल
बाइनरी जिस कमांड्स हैं एक तरह से आप ये
समझ लो कि एक तरह के कमांड्स हैं। डेट
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] डेट कमांड हो
गया, सीएच मोड कमांड हो गया, ग्रेप कमांड
हो गया, जिप कमांड, जीप कमांड हो गया,
होस्ट नेम कमांड हो गया, एलएस कमांड हो
गया, एमके डीआईआर कमांड हो गया। तो ये
कमांड्स होल्ड कर रहा है। ईटीसी
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल्स करती है। जैसे कंटेन
करती है। क्रोन टैब हो गया। एफएस टैब आपका
वही जो माउंट वाला होता है वो हो गया।
होस्ट डॉट अलाउ होस्ट डॉट डिनाऊ होस्ट को
अलाउ डिनाई करने का परमिशन सेट करता है।
ये [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] इनट है
आपका इनिट लेवल्स वगैरह आपको वो बताता है।
उसके बाद यहां पे नेटवर्क्स के बारे में
बताता है। पास डब्ल्यूडी है जो यूज़र्स के
बारे में बताता है। शैडो आपके इसी के अंदर
में शैडो होता है जो आपके पासवर्ड्स के
बारे में बताता है। वो सब चीज़ एसबीएन
सिस्टम बाइनरीज़ में जैसे सिस्टम के जो
बेसिकली सिस्टम वाइड जो कमांड्स हैं
यूज़फुल कमांड्स वह सारे इसमें आ
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] जाते हैं।
ठीक है?
क्या बोल रहे हो?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
उसके बाद स्लश यूएसआर जो होता है इसमें
रीड ओनली यूजर एप्लीकेशनेशंस होते हैं।
जैसे सश यूएसआर बिन यूएसआर इंक्लूड यूएसआर
लेब ये अंदर की डायरेक्टरीज़ होती हैं जो
अलग-अलग काम करती हैं। इतना डीप में आपको
नहीं जाना है। टेंशन नहीं लेनी है। वयर जो
होता है वेरिएबल तो स्लैश वेयर कैश स्लश
वयर लेब्ल वेयर log vयर लॉग ये लॉग फाइल्स
होती है जो एसओसी के लिए सबसे ज्यादाेंट
होती है। स्लैश वय सश log बाकी चीज़ों को
आप स्किप भी कर दो। तो स्लैश वेयर log इज़
अ वेरीेंट चीज़। उसके बाद स्लैश डेव होता
है डिवाइसेस वाली जो फाइल्स होती है होम
जो होता है यूज़र्स के होम डायरेक्टरी जो
भी आप यूजर जो भी आप यूजर से लॉगिन है रूट
से हैं किसी और नॉर्मल यूजर से उसकी होम
डायरेक्टरी यानी उसके अंदर
डॉक्यूमेंट्स पिक्चर्स फाइल्स अदर चीजें
ये रहेंगी। लिब जो होती है लाइब्रेरीज एंड
कर्नल मॉड्यूल्स होते हैं उसके अंदर एमएटी
जो होती है टेंपरेरी जो सिस्टम फाइल्स
फाइल सिस्टम्स है उसके लिए माउंट पॉइंट है
ऑप्ट ऑप्शनल सॉफ्टवेयर एप्लीकेशन बता दिया
प्रॉक के बारे में आपको बता दिया रूट तो
आपको पता ही है तो ये सारी चीजें अब आते
हैं यहां पे द मेन थिंग इज़ अब यहां पे
नेक्स्ट आते हैं भैया लinक्स की परमिशंस
के बारे में समझते हैं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब देखो
लinक्स का परमिशन भी अपने आप में बहुत
कमाल की चीज है। लinक्स में हर चीज परमिशन
से डील होती है। जैसे Windows में भी
परमिशन होते हैं। याद रखिएगा Windows में
भी परमिशन होते हैं। कोई भी फोल्डर, कोई
भी डायरेक्टरी सबका परमिशन होता है। जैसे
Windows में मैं अगर बबूट के इस
डायरेक्टरी पे राइट क्लिक करूं,
प्रॉपर्टीज पे जाऊं
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
तो यहां भी मैं अगर शेयरिंग में जाता हूं,
एडवांस शेयरिंग करता हूं। सॉरी सॉरी ये
कहां गया मैं? सिक्योरिटी में जाता हूं।
शेयरिंग में नहीं जाना, सिक्योरिटी में
जाता हूं। तो यहां पे परमिशंस का ऑप्शंस
हमें मिलता है। तो यहां पे कौन-कौन से
ग्रुप्स के लिए अलाउड है? सिस्टम,
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स एंड एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर के लिए।
ठीक है? एंड यहां पे परमिशंस सिस्टम्स के
लिए क्या-क्या है? डिफ़्रॉनिक्स को सेलेक्ट
करोगे, तो डिफ़्रॉनिक्स के लिए क्या-क्या
परमिशंस हैं? इस यूजर के लिए, सिस्टम यूजर
के लिए एंड एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर यूजर के लिए
क्या-क्या परमिशंस हैं? तो मान लो मैं अभी
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स यूज़ कर रहा हूं यूजर। तो इसके
लिए क्या-क्या परमिशन है? फुल कंट्रोल है,
अलाउ है। मतलब इसको पूरा कंट्रोल है। सारे
परमिशंस मॉडिफाई, रीड, राइट सब दे रखा है।
तो यहां ग्राफिकली तुम इसको चेंज कर सकते
हो। टू चेंज परमिशन। मान लो डिफ़्रॉनिक्स
को मैं एडिट क्लिक करूंगा। तो यहां
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स के लिए सेलेक्ट करूंगा। तो
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स के लिए यहां पे परमिशंस जो है
तुम चेंज रिमूव जो भी करना है कर सकते हो।
या यहां से तुम एडवांस पे जाओगे तो यहां
पे कुछ एडवांस पोर्ट मतलब एक एडवांस तरीके
से थोड़ा थोड़ा सा और ऑप्शंस यहां पे आपको
मिल जाते हैं। आप परमिशंस वगैरह को चेंज
कर सकते हो। तो ये Windows की बात हो गई
है। Linux में भी परमिशन इज एवरीथिंग। मैं
राइट क्लिक करके यहां पे ओपन टर्मिनल करता
हूं। और यहां पे मैं एक मान लो एक फाइल
बनाता हूं। तो मैं फाइल बनाने के लिए
कमांड कोई सा भी कमांड यूज़ कर सकता हूं।
मैं यहां पे लेट्स सपोज़ आई एम यूजिंग अ
विमim कमांड। विमim कमांड यूज़ किया। अब
मैं यहां पे एक फाइल बनाता हूं। डेफ़on
डॉटXT इस नाम से जैसे ही मैं एंटर करूंगा
विम के इंटरनल एडिटर में आ जाऊंगा। यह
विमim का एडिटर है। विम एक फाइल बनाने की
कमांड होती है। फाइल विम लिखो। फाइल का
नाम लिखो। एंटर करो। उसके अंदर तुम आ
जाओगे। अब इसके अंदर टाइप करने के लिए आई
बटन प्रेस करना होता है इंसर्ट मोड में
जाके। अब यहां पे जो टाइप करना है टाइप कर
दो। हे एवरीवन।
राम-राम।
नमस्ते।
कर दिया। सब्सक्राइब
टू डिफ्रॉनिक्स।
एकडमी कुछ भी आपने कुछ भी व्हाटएवर यू
वांट टू टाइप आपने यहां पे टाइप कर दिया।
ठीक है? ये आपने अंदर में फाइल के अंदर
में एंट्री कर दी। राइट? अब इससे बाहर
निकलना है। अब आप ऑलरेडी एक एंट्री मोड
में हैं। यू आर ऑलरेडी इन अ इनपुट मोड। तो
हमें अब इससे बाहर निकलना है। इस फाइल को
सेव करना है। तो इससे हमें बाहर निकलना
है। ठीक है? तो हम एस्केप बटन दबाएंगे
कीबोर्ड पे। तो हम इंसर्ट मोड हट जाएगी।
इंसर्ट मोड से बाहर आ जाएंगे। देखो इंसर्ट
इंसर्ट वाला ऑप्शन जो नीचे लिखा था यहां
पे नीचे में बॉटम लेफ्ट में वो हट चुका
है। हम इंसर्ट मोड से बाहर आ। अब इसको सेव
करने के लिए सबसे पहले कॉलन प्रेस करते
हैं। कॉलन जो हमारा कॉलन होता है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] जो आपके
कीबोर्ड पे एल के पास में होता है। शिफ्ट
के साथ जो प्रेस होती है। कॉलन प्रेस करते
हैं। यहां पे डब्ल्यू प्रेस करते हैं।
डब्ल्यू फॉर सेविंग क्यू क्यू फॉर
क्विटिंग। डब्ल्यू का मतलब बेसिकली यहां
पे राइट का मतलब है राइट कर दिया। मतलब
वहां सेव कर दिया। और क्यू का मतलब क्विट
कर दिया। मतलब हम इससे बाहर अब निकलना
चाहते हैं एंड इससे हम बाहर निकल जाएंगे।
तो अब हमारा फाइल एक बन चुका है dfon.txt
ये फाइल कहां बनी होगी? डेस्कटॉप पे।
क्योंकि हम डेस्कटॉप में काम कर रहे हैं।
तो आप देखोगे यहां पे डिफ़ॉन.xt बन चुकी
है। अब
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
इसी फाइल को जब हम
देखना चाहते हैं तो एलएस करेंगे डेस्कटॉप
के ऊपर तो हमें इसके ऊपर जितने भी फाइल्स
और डायरेक्टरीज़ हैं वो दिखेंगी। तो यहां
पे dfinx.txt दिख रही है। अब हमें देखना
है कि डिफ्रॉनिक्स.xt के अंदर में
क्या-क्या लिखा हुआ है। तो कौन सा कमांड
यूज़ करेंगे भाई? बताओ सभी लोग इसके अंदर
के कंटेंट को देखने के लिए थोड़ी देर पहले
ही बताया था मैंने। बताओ
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
या बिल्कुल सही कैट कमांड कैट स्पेस
dfonictxt इसके अंदर की कंटेंट ये दिखा
देगा हे एवरीवन राम-राम नमस्ते सब्सक्राइब
टू डिफ़्रोनिक्स एकडमी इसने हमें उसके अंदर
का कंटेंट दिखा दिया बट अब हमें देखना है
कि ये डिफ़्रोनिक्स फाइल जो है इस पे किस
तरह के परमिशंस लगे हुए हैं क्या परमिशन
सेट हुए हैं तो जब भी आप Linux में कोई भी
फाइल या डायरेक्टरी क्रिएट करते हो तो इस
उस पे ऑटोमेटिक एक डिफॉल्ट परमिशन लग जाती
है। उसको देखने के लिए कमांड किसी को पता
है परमिशन देखने का कमांड
एलs बताओ हां एलएस हफन एल ये कमांड हम
देते हैं। जैसे ही ये देंगे और
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स लिख देंगे। जैसे ही मैं एंटर
करूंगा अब यह जो चीज है डिफ्रॉनिक्स की
परमिशंस को शो कर देगा।
डिफ्रॉनिक्स की परमिशंस को शो कर देगा
हमारे सामने। तो हमें यहां पर परमिशंस दिख
रहे हैं कि आपको दिख रहा है यह कुछ इस
तरीके का अजीबोगरीब चीज आपको देखने को दिख
रहा है। ठीक है? ठीक है? अब आपको समझ में
आपको लगेगा कि अरे यार ये अजीबोगरीब चीज
क्या दिख रही है मुझे? तो अब इसको हम
समझेंगे कि ये आर डब्लू ब्लैंक आर आर ये
सब क्या है? व्हाट इज दिस? सो इसको समझने
के लिए भैया हम आते हैं अपने
पीपीटी पे एंड यहां देखते हैं देखो इन
लinक्स एवरीथिंग इज़ अ फाइल जैसा मैंने
पहले ही बोला था लinक्स एवरीथिंग इज़ अ
फाइल एंड एव्री फाइल हैज़ एन ओनर एंड अ
ग्रुप और हर फाइल का एक ओनर होता है ठीक
है एक ग्रुप होता है मतलब ओनर मतलब उसका
एक यूजर होता है और एक ग्रुप होता है
परमिशंस डिफाइन हाउ द ओनर द ग्रुप एंड
एवरीवन एल्स कैन इंटैक्ट विद दोज़ फाइल्स।
परमिशंस यही डिसाइड करती है कि उस फाइल के
साथ वो जो ओनर है जो यूजर है वो जो ग्रुप
है वो या इन दोनों के अलावा कोई और कैसे
उस फाइल के साथ इंटैक्ट करेगा? क्या-क्या
उसके पास उस फाइल को इंटैक्ट करने के
परमिशंस हैं? किस तरह की ऑथराइजेशन है?
यही दिखाता है आपका। दैट्स इट।
ठीक है?
समझ में आ गया? अब देखिए परमिशन में सबसे
पहला होता है रीड का। सबसे पहला होता है
रीड। फिर एक परमिशन होती है राइट। एक
परमिशन होता है एग्जीक्यूट। रीड का नोटेशन
आर होता है। आर से हम उसको डिनोट करते
हैं। राइट का नोटेशन डब्लू होता है।
एग्जीक्यूट का नोटेशन एक्स होता है। इसलिए
ये आर डब्ल्यू एक्स कहलाते हैं। दीज़ आर
कॉल्ड आर
डब्लू एक्स। RWX
रीड का मतलब होता है व्यू द फाइल कंटेंट।
रीड की परमिशन जब आपके पास होगी किसी फाइल
के लिए तो आप फाइल को बस देख सकते हैं।
फाइल के कंटेंट को देख सकते हैं। राइट की
जब परमिशन होगी तो आप फाइल के कंटेंट्स को
मॉडिफाई भी कर सकते हैं। चेंज भी कर सकते
हैं। और एग्जीक्यूट की परमिशन जब होगी तो
आप उस फाइल को एज अ प्रोग्राम चला सकते
हैं। एज अ सॉफ्टवेयर रन कर सकते हैं। उसको
बाइनरी में इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं। मतलब आप
सिस्टम में इंस्टॉल करके चला सकते हैं।
ठीक है?
अब यहां पे बात समझते हैं कि डायरेक्टरी
मीनिंग का मतलब क्या है? डायरेक्टरी के
लिए क्या मतलब है इसका? कि अगर कोई
डायरेक्टरी है तो रीड का मतलब है लिस्ट द
फाइल्स इनसाइड एलएस। मतलब कि जो भी फाइल्स
हैं डायरेक्टरी में उसको हम देख सकते हैं,
लिस्ट कर सकते हैं। राइट का मतलब
डायरेक्टरी के लिए क्या होगा? क्रिएट
डिलीट और रीनेम फाइल्स इनसाइड। अगर किसी
डायरेक्टरी को राइट का परमिशन है, कोई
डायरेक्टरी या फोल्डर है, उसमें कोई राइट
का परमिशन है, तो इसका मतलब है आप उसके
अंदर के फाइल्स के साथ क्रिएट, डिलीट और
रीनेम वगैरह कर सकते हैं। एग्जीक्यूट का
मतलब है एंटर द डायरेक्टरी। एग्जीक्यूट का
मतलब है उस डायरेक्टरी के अंदर एंटर करना।
उस डायरेक्टरी के अंदर आप जा सकते हो, घुस
सकते हो। ये डायरेक्टरी के केस में यह
परमिशंस होती है। फाइल के केस में इस
तरीके की चीज़ होती है। ठीक है? अब देखो टू
डिलीट अ फाइल एक फाइल को डिलीट करने के
लिए यू एक्चुअली नीड राइट एन एग्जीक्यूट
परमिशन ऑन द पैरेंट डायरेक्टरी नॉट
नेसेसरीली द फाइल इटसेल्फ मतलब अगर किसी
फाइल को डिलीट करना है तो अगर वो किसी
डायरेक्टरी में है तो उस डायरेक्टरी के
ऊपर में परमिशन आपको चाहिए राइट एंड
एग्जीक्यूट का फाइल आपकी डिलीट आप कर सकते
हैं। ऐसा नहीं है कि उस फाइल के ऊपर में
आपको राइट और एग्जीक्यूट का परमिशन चाहिए।
फाइल के ऊपर में अगर नहीं भी होगी ना वो
परमिशन तो भी अगर डायरेक्टरी के ऊपर
परमिशन है राइट और एग्जीक्यूट का तो उस
फाइल को आप डिलीट कर सकते हैं। लinक्स की
ये खूबी है। लinक्स में ये मजा मजा है। तो
ये कुछ परमिशंस होती है। अब आगे बढ़ते
हैं।
व्हेन यू रन एलएस हफन एल जैसे मैंने रन
किया। यू सी अ स्ट्रिंग लाइक कुछ इस तरीके
की चीजें आपको देखने को मिलेगी। तो अब इस
चीज को हम समझते हैं क्या होता है। ठीक
है? इस चीज को वी आर गोइंग टू अंडरस्टैंड।
अब देखो यहां पे मैं एक और चीज़ करूंगा।
जैसे मैंने डायरेक्टरी अह फ़ाइल बनाई थी
डिफ़्रॉनिक्सic.txt अब मैं एक फ़ोल्डर यानी
डायरेक्टरी भी बनाऊंगा। उसके लिए मैं
कमांड चलाऊंगा एमK डीआईआर और मैं यहां पे
करता हूं डिफ़्रॉनिक्स
एकेडमी। ये डायरेक्टरी बना रहा हूं। ठीक
है? डेस्कटॉप पे बनी होगी। देखो यहां पे
एक फोल्डर बन गई होगी डिफ़्रॉनिक्स एकडमी
के नाम से। अब मैं इसकी भी एलएस हफन एल
करता हूं। एलएस हफन एल मैं इसका मान लो
इसको करता हूं और डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी करता
हूं। इस तरीके से अब यहां पे जब मैंने
किया तो यहां पे मुझे टोटल ज़ीरो करके आ
रहा है। इसका रीज़न कोई बता सकता है कि
यहां पे मुझे परमिशन क्यों नहीं दिखी एलएस
हफन एल से? या मैंने कोई कमांड गलत डाला
है डायरेक्टरी के लिए। ये डायरेक्टरी है।
याद रखिएगा। एनीवन कोई किसी को कुछ आईडिया
है कि यहां पे हमने डायरेक्ट हम
डायरेक्टरी की याद रखिएगा। दिस इज़
डायरेक्टरी। दिस इज़ नॉट अ फाइल। दिस इज़
डायरेक्टरी। व्हाई वी आर नॉट गेटिंग
आउटपुट? जस्ट हमने फाइल में जैसे एलएस हफन
एल से किया तो व्हाई वी आर नॉट गेटिंग
हियर रिजल्ट
बताइए मुझे।
फाइल्स नहीं है। फाइल्स क्रिएट करो। अच्छा
और बताइए। बताइए सभी लोग आंसर कीजिए। मैं
मैं फिर आपको बताऊंगा। बताइए।
देखिए एक्चुअली
एलएस हफन ए ठीक है। एक्चुअली क्या होता
है? देखो एक्चुअली डायरेक्टरी के केस में
जब आप परमिशंस को लिस्ट करते हो यहां पे
चलो मैंने देख लिया। मैंने मैंने सबके
मैंने सबके वो देख लिए हैं। नो फाइल्स
एम्प्टी डायरेक्टरी। फाइल्स डायरेक्टरी
कहां खाली है इसलिए ठीक है। एम्प्टी
डायरेक्टरी। चलिए अच्छी बात है। यहां पे
एक कमांड होती है एलएस हफन एल डी। एक
कमांड होती है एलएस हफन एलडी। ठीक है? और
उसके बाद डायरेक्टरी नेम आप डालेंगे और जब
आप एंटर करेंगे तो आपको डायरेक्टरी की
परमिशन दिखाएगी। फाइल के लिए क्या होता है
कि एलएस हफन एल से आपका हो जाएगा। बट
डायरेक्टरी की जब आप परमिशन देख रहे हैं
तो एल के बाद डी लगाना है फॉर डायरेक्टरी
थिंग कि हां भैया ये डायरेक्टरी की मैं
देख रहा हूं परमिशंस। तो भैया डी यहां पे
लगा देते हैं। राइट? तो हम यहां पे एलएस
हफन एल डी कमांड लगाएंगे। एंड वी कैन सी
दैट डायरेक्टरी परमिशंस। इसके लिए जरूरी
नहीं है कि फाइल हो या ना हो डजंट मैटर।
कोई भी मैटर नहीं करता है। ठीक है? जैसे
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] मैंने पूछा
मुझे लगा आप में से किसी को शायद पता हो
तो मैंने पूछा था एलएस हफन एल डी आपने कर
दिया। ठीक है?
एक ए जो होता है हिडन फाइल्स के लिए होता
है। कोई हिडन फाइल्स वगैरह हो वो भी देखना
हो। एलएस हफन एलए करोगे तो हिडन फाइल्स
वगैरह भी होंगी अगर वहां पे तो उसके भी
परमिशन दिखा देगा। बस उसके लिए होता है।
ठीक है?
गॉट इट?
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
हां। अब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यहां पे
दोनों में डिफरेंस देखिए। देखिए अब ये जो
आपको सामने सामने दिख के आ रही है, इसमें
क्या-क्या चीजें हैं, मैं आपको समझाता
हूं। अब मैं इसको थोड़ा क्लियर करता हूं
ताकि इतना खींचपिच ना हो और आपको फिर
दिखाता हूं। पहले फाइल की हम परमिशंस को
लिस्ट करते हैं। एलएस हफन एल डिफरेंस और
डायरेक्टरी की फिर परमिशंस को लिस्ट करते
हैं एलडी वाला। ठीक है? अब दोनों में
डिफरेंस आप समझिएगा। ये दोनों डिफरेंस
बहुत जरूरी है। देखो पहला जो यहां पे कॉलम
होता है फर्स्ट कॉलम यह डिनोट करता है कि
ये जो परमिशन दिख रही है वो एक फाइल के
लिए दिख रही है या डायरेक्टरी के लिए दिख
रही है। तो ये पहला अगर माइनस ऐसे हफन
दिया है तो यह फाइल कहलाता है। लेकिन पहला
जो
चीज है यहां पे एंट्री जो है वो डी लिखा
है तो मतलब डायरेक्टरी को डिनोट करती है।
यह समझ लीजिए। उसके बाद पहले डिनोशन के
बाद जो थ्री दूसरा तीसरा और चौथा होता है
वह होती है एक्चुअल परमिशन रीड राइट और
एग्जीक्यूट की आर डब्ल्यू और एक्स की बट
यहां पे आर और डब्ल्यू है और एक्स नहीं
है। इसका मतलब है आर रीड की परमिशन यहां
राइट की परमिशन है बट एग्जीक्यूट की
परमिशन नहीं है। बट यह परमिशन किसको मिली
हुई है? यह परमिशन किसको मिली है? तो सबसे
पहले जो तीन ऑक्टेट आपका जो पहला सॉरी
ऑक्टेट बोल रहा हूं। पहला जो तीन फील्ड्स
हैं, यह यूजर के होते हैं। दूसरा जो तीन
फील्ड है, यह ग्रुप्स के होते हैं। और
तीसरा जो लास्ट थ्री फील्ड्स हैं, ये
अदर्स के होते हैं। यानी पहले थ्री
फील्ड्स यूजर के परमिशन को शो करते हैं।
बीच वाले तीन फील्ड्स ग्रुप्स के परमिशन
को शो करते हैं। और तीसरा जो तीन फील्ड
होता है, वो अदर्स के परमिशन यानी कोई भी
यूजर और ग्रुप को छोड़ के बाकी सब अदर
होते हैं। उसके परमिशन को शो करता है।
दैट्स इट। तो यहां पे
यूजर को किस-किस चीज की परमिशन है? मुझे
बताया जाए। सभी लोग चैट में फटाफट बताया
जाए। देख मुझे यूजर को किस-किस चीज की
परमिशन है? बताओ।
हां, यूजर या ओनर कुछ भी बोल लो।
बताओ किस-किस चीज की परमिशन है यूजर को?
जल्दी सभी लोग। आई वांट आंसर्स फ्रॉम
एवरीबॉडी, ब्रदर।
रीड एंड राइट। बिल्कुल सही। बिल्कुल सही।
ग्रुप को किस-किस की परमिशन है? अब बताओ
जल्दी फटाफट। ग्रुप को किस-किस की परमिशन
है? ग्रुप को
किस-किस चीज की परमिशन है?
ग्रुप को किस-किस चीज की परमिशन है?
जल्दी।
ग्रुप को ओनली रीड की परमिशन है। क्योंकि
आर ओनली दिख रहा है ना। wx तो दिख ही नहीं
रहा हमें। ब्लैंक है तो सिर्फ रीड की
परमिशन है। बिल्कुल सही। और लास्ट में
अदर्स को किस-किस चीज की परमिशन है?
अदर्स को अगेन आर ओनली रीड की परमिशन है।
यानी
इस इस फाइल के लिए यूजर को रीड और राइट की
परमिशन है। यूजर इस फाइल के साथ रीड राइट
सब कर सकता है। ग्रुप से ग्रुप्स जो होंगे
जिसमें ये यूजर फॉलो अगर कोई ग्रुप का
बंदा है वो सिर्फ रीड कर पाएगा।
इस फाइल को और लास्ट में कोई और है तो वह
भी सिर्फ रीड ही कर पाएगा। दैट्स इट।
परमिशन हो गया। यही है पूरी परमिशन। खत्म
परमिशन आपके लinक्स की। इतना ईजी वे में
कौन बताएगा आपको? और डायरेक्टरी के केस
में यहां बस पहले वाला डी है जो डिनोट
करता है कि यह डायरेक्टरी की परमिशंस है।
बाकी सब सेम है। अब यह दिखाता है कि यूजर
को रीड, राइट, एग्जीक्यूट तीनों की परमिशन
है। ग्रुप को रीड और एग्जीक्यूट की परमिशन
है। और अदर्स को भी रीड और एग्जीक्यूट का
परमिशन है। तो, यह आपको यह चीज़ दिखाता है।
ठीक है? यह आपको समझ में आ गया होगा
एवरीथिंग। आई थिंक यू गॉट दिस पर्टिकुलर
पॉइंट। एवरीवन गॉट इट। समझ में आ गया सभी
को? इतनी चीजें बताओ मुझे पहले। फटाफट
बताओ। एवरीवन अंडरस्टुड?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
बताइए तब मैं आगे बढूंगा। नहीं तो फिर
वहीं पे लटके रहेंगे। बताइए जल्दी बताइए।
फटाफट एवरीवन अंडरस्टुड? यार आप लोग
रिप्लाई नहीं करते तो मजा नहीं आता मुझे।
यही परमिशन थी। Linux की परमिशन को लेके
हवा लोग बना के रखते हैं। पता नहीं अरे सर
क्या है ये वो परमिशन बहुत टफ होता है। अब
इससे ज्यादा इजी क्या चाहिए भाई? यही है
परमिशन। बस इतना समझ लो। अब देखो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अभी थोड़ी
चीजें और है। उसको भी देख लेते हैं। यही
चीजें मैंने यहां पे टेक्स्ट में लिखी हुई
है आपके लिए नोट्स के लिए। द फर्स्ट
करैक्टर इंडिकेट्स द फाइल टाइप। हफन रहेगा
तो रेगुलर फाइल के लिए, डी रहेगा तो
डायरेक्टरी के लिए। और कहीं-कहीं अगर आपको
एल दिख गया बाय चांस एल तो वो सिंबॉलिक
लिंक होती है। जैसे एक
ऑब्जेक्ट दूसरे ऑब्जेक्ट से लिंक होता है
लinक्स में तो उसके लिए होती है। ठीक है?
तो ये आपकी चीजें होती है। द सेट्स ऑफ
थ्री द नेक्स्ट नाइन कररेक्टर्स आर
डिवाइडेड इंटू थ्री ट्रिप्लेट्स। जैसा
मैंने आपको बताया तीन-तीन के पार्ट्स में
डिवाइडेड होते हैं। राइट? द वे यू
एक्सप्लेन कॉनंसेप्ट्स इज सच अ क्लियर
इंटरेक्टिव एंड यूनिक वे इज़ ट्रूली
इंप्रेसिव। थैंक यू वेरी मच तनवीर
फ़ॉर द वर्ड्स।
परमिशंस वेर ऑलवेज कन्फ्यूज़िंग टू मी बट
इट इज़ क्लियर्ड। यस। ईजी वे में समझेंगे
सब क्लियर हो जाएगा। इजी वे में समझने के
बाद सब बहुत ईजी हो जाएगी। ठीक है?
अब [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
तीन डिवाइडेड होते हैं तीन-तीन पार्ट्स
में। जैसा मैंने बताया। पहला वाला छोड़ दो।
ये पहला वाला छोड़ दो। तो तीन-तीन पार्ट
में डिवाइड होते हैं। ये तीन पार्ट, ये
तीन पार्ट और ये तीन पार्ट। अब पहला जो
पार्ट है वह होता है यूजर का यू द
इंडिविजुअल हु ओ्स द फाइल जो ओनर होता है
फाइल का दूसरा होता है ग्रुप द मेंबर ऑफ द
ग्रुप असाइन टू द फाइल मेंबर्स ऑफ द ग्रुप
असाइन टू द फाइल मतलब हर यूजर का ना एक
ग्रुप होता है मतलब हर यूजर को एक ग्रुप
में डाला जाता है ठीक है अब जैसे मान लो
कि कंपनी में भी ऐसे ही होता है एक
फाइनेंस का डिपार्टमेंट होता है एक आईटी
का डिपार्टमेंट होता है राइट एक एचआर का
डिपार्टमेंट होता है तो फाइनेंस वाले में
फाइनेंस वाले सारे टीम काम करते हैं एचआर
वाले में एचआर वाले काम करते हैं
सिक्योरिटी वाले में सिक्योरिटी िटी वाले
काम करते हैं। आईटी वाले में, आईटी वाले
काम करते हैं। राइट? तो उसी तरीके से हर
अलग-अलग यूज़र्स को एक ग्रुप में बनाए। तो
वही ग्रुप्स की यहां पे बात हो रही है।
मेंबर्स ऑफ़ द ग्रुप। और अदर का मतलब ओ
होता है। यूजर को यू से डिनोट करते हैं।
ग्रुप को जी से डिनोट करते हैं। अदर को ओ
से डिनोट करते हैं। एवरीवन एल्स ऑन द
सिस्टम। यूजर और ग्रुप के अलावा जितने हैं
सब सब बाकी बस।
आई कांट बिलीव पीपल आर मिसिंग आउट दिस
कोर्स। कोई बात नहीं। लोगों का काम है मिस
करना। मिस करने दो।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
यही ट्रेनिंग जब पेड हो जाएगी ना तो तुम
देखना तब लोग सीरियस लेंगे उसको। अब यही
चीजें मैंने जो आपको बताई यहां पर
एग्जांपल के तौर पे नोट्स के तौर पे समझाई
गई है। कुछ इस तरीके से
आर डब्ल्यू एक्स अगर रहे तो मतलब यूजर को
रीड राइट एग्जीक्यूट की परमिशन है। ग्रुप
में यहां पे आर एक्स है ओनली तो रीड और
एग्जीक्यूट का परमिशन है। अदर्स को सिर्फ
आर का है तो रीड ओनली का परमिशन है। दैट्स
इट। ठीक है? अब आगे बढ़ते हैं। अब
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] इसी परमिशन
को न्यूमेरिकल नोटेशन में भी मैं आपको
समझाता हूं। इसी परमिशन को न्यूमेरिकल
नोटेशन में भी डील किया जाता है। अब क्या
होता है? सिस्टम एडमिनस रेयरली टाइप आउट ए
आरडब्ल्यूए। सिस्टम एडमिन जो होते हैं ना
वो नंबर्स में डील करते हैं। आरडब्ल्यूx
में तो अब देखो आप आरडब्ल्यूx में भी कर
सकते हो। कोई गलत नहीं है। कुछ गलत नहीं
है। बिल्कुल सही है। बट शॉर्ट में थोड़ा
जल्दी-जल्दी करने के चक्कर में नंबर्स का
यूज़ सिस्टम एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स करते हैं। एज
एन एन एन एन एन एन एन एन एन एन एसओसी
एनालिस्ट आप आर डब्ल्यूएस का यूज़ करो।
चलेगा। बिल्कुल दौड़ेगा। जरूरी नहीं है
नोटेशन के लिए। मैं बस आपकी इनफार्मेशन के
लिए बता रहा हूं। जैसे मैंने बोला ना मैं
थोड़ा एक्स्ट्रा भी बता देता हूं कभी-कभी।
तो बता देता हूं। फ्लो फ्लो में मैं कुछ
ज्यादा चीज़ बता देता हूं। जब नहीं रहा
जाता तो तो उसको सुन लिया करो। आपके लिए
बेनिफिशियल है। आपकी जिंदगी में काम आएगी
बहुत ज्यादा। ऐसी चीजों को पढ़ने के लिए
लोग बहुत पैसा देते हैं या फ्री में आपको
मिल रहा है। इंस्टेड वी यूज़ अ बेस एट
सिस्टम न्यूमेरिकल ऑक्टल नोटेशन ईच परमिशन
इज़ असाइन अ वैल्यू। हर परमिशन एक वैल्यू
असाइन की जाती है। जैसे रीड के परमिशन को
नंबर चार वैल्यू असाइन किया गया है। पता
नहीं क्यों किया गया है बट चार किया गया
है। राइट की परमिशन को दो किया गया है। दो
किया है। एग्जीक्यूट की परमिशन को एक
असाइन किया गया है। और नन मतलब कुछ भी
नहीं उसको जीरो असाइन किया गया है। यह
ऑक्टल नोटेशन आपका किया जाता है। अब
अब देखो यह मत पूछना कि सर रीड को चार
क्यों नोटेड क्यों इसका नोटेशन चार किया
गया है? ये गलती से भी मत पूछना। अगर ये
पूछना है तो इसका आंसर यही है कि जाके
पूछो कि पूर्व जो है ना पूर्व ईस्ट ईस्ट
को ईस्ट क्यों बोलते हैं? ये जाके पूछना
कि ईस्ट को ईस्ट ही क्यों बोला? ईस्ट को
वेस्ट क्यों नहीं बोल दिया? ईस्ट को नॉर्थ
क्यों नहीं बोल दिया? अब ये भी समझिए। अब
सन सूरज ईस्ट से ही उगता है। उसका जो भी
साइंटिफिक रीजन है हो उगता है भाई मान लो
उगता है। वही रीड को फोर असाइन कर दिया।
राइट को दो असाइन कर दिया। एग्जीक्यूट को
वन और नन को ज़ीरो। टू गेट द नंबर्स फॉर अ
ट्रिपलेट यू जस्ट ऐड देम अप। अब जब आप
इसको ऐड करोगे 4 + 2 + 1 तो ये सात हो
जाते हैं। टोटल सात। इसका मतलब है इसको
परमिशन किस चीज की मिल गई? रीड की, राइट
की, एग्जीक्यूट की। यानी सात नंबर अगर
कहीं पे लिखा रहेगा
उसको रीड का भी परमिशन है, राइट का भी
परमिशन है, एग्जीक्यूट का भी परमिशन है।
एज सिंपल दैट। देखा कितना छोटा कर दिया।
एक नंबर से पूरा का पूरा नोटेशन मिल चुका
है। थाला फॉर अ रीज़ सात। यहां परमिशन में
भी सात है। बताओ यार। सात इज़ वेरी खतरनाक
नंबर। परमिशन में भी सात है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
गॉट इट? अब यहां पर आगे की तरफ चलते हैं।
अब देखो क्या होता है। जैसा मैंने बताया
सात नंबर आता है 4 + 2 + 1 को ऐड करके रीड
राइट और एग्जीक्यूट को 4 + 2 + 1 को ऐड
करके चार है रीड दो है राइट और एक है
एग्जीक्यूट ज़ीरो को भूल जाओ इसका तो कुछ
है ही नहीं नन नन है ये मान लो तो ये सात
आ जाता है रीड राइट एग्जीक्यूट तीनों
परमिशन तो सेवन को हम RWX मानते हैं रीड
राइट एग्जीक्यूट फुल कंट्रोल सिक्स अगर हो
सिक्स किस चीज को मिला के बन सकता है 4 +
2 छ को मिला के और लास्ट वाला जीरो हो
जाएगा बेचारा खत्म नन हो जाएगा। तो आर
डब्लू 4 + 2 रीड और राइट दो मिला के छह हो
जाते हैं। तो रीड और राइट का परमिशन हो
गया। पांच किस चीज को मिला के बनेगा? तो
पांच किसको मिलेगा? एक चार को और
एग्जीक्यूट का वन पांच में बन जाएगा। तो
कैसे होगा? चार रीड का और एग्जीक्यूट एक
पांच हो गया। तो इसका मतलब रीड और
एग्जीक्यूट हो गया। इसका मतलब रीड और राइट
परमिशन हो गई। चार कैसे बनेगा? तो सिंगल
एक रीड ही चार हो जाता है। तो सिर्फ रीड
अगर है तो इसका मतलब वो चार का है। ज़ीरो
मतलब नो एक्सेस। कोई एक्सेस नहीं है। ज़ीरो
एक्सेस है। दैट्स इट। अब Linux के अंदर
में सीएच मोड कमांड
जो है इसका यूज़ किया जाता है परमिशंस को
अप्लाई करने के लिए या परमिशंस को चेंज
करने के लिए। परमिशंस को बदलने के लिए सीए
मोड कमांड का यूज़ किया जाता है Linux के
अंदर में। ठीक है? तो जैसे यहां पे कोई
फाइल है। अगर आपने सीए मोड के बाद 6 44
दिया। इसका मतलब क्या हुआ? 6 4 इसका मतलब
है पहले जो यूजर हैं उनको क्या मिला? रीड
राइट का परमिशन। उसके बाद ग्रुप को क्या
मिला? रीड का परमिशन। उसके बाद फिर से अदर
को क्या मिला? रीड का परमिशन। ये इसका
मतलब होता है। ठीक है? अब यहां पे मैं
इसको लाइव इन एक्शन दिखाता हूं आपको। यहां
पर डिफाइनxt में यूजर को किस चीज की
परमिशन थी? बताइए मुझे। डिफाइनxt में txt
में यूजर को किस-किस चीज की परमिशन थी?
बताइए मुझे।
लेट मी नो गाइस प्लीज।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यूजर को किस चीज की परमिशन है? रीड और
राइट की डिफ़्रॉनिक्स.xt को। राइट? अब मुझे
इसको एग्जीक्यूट का भी परमिशन देना है। तो
आप इसके लिए क्या कर सकते हैं? एग्जीक्यूट
का परमिशन देना है तो आप क्या करेंगे? सीए
मोड कमांड डालेंगे।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है? अब यहां रीड और राइट की परमिशन
ऑलरेडी है। यूजर को ही तो दिया है आपने।
यूजर को देना है यूजर। तो बाय डिफ़ॉल्ट
यूजर की ही परमिशन सेट होती है। जब आप
नॉर्मली परमिशन देंगे एक सिंगल
अल्फाबेटिकल नोटेशन से। तो अगर आप यहां पे
यहां पे मान लो प्लस
x कर देते हो + x कर देते हो
ठीक है और यहां पे डिफ्रॉनिक्स कर देते हो
और एंटर कर देते हो इस तरीके से तो अब यह
क्या होगा इससे क्या फर्क पड़ेगा अब मैं
यहां पे अगर परमिशन देखूं डिफ्रॉनिक्स की
तो आपको यहां पे देखने को मिलेगा यहां पे
अगर आप देखने को मिलेगा कि x की परमिशन तो
मिल बट यह सभी को मिल गई। देखो बट यह सभी
को मिल गई x का परमिशन। जब आपने सीधा + x
लिखा
सब में क्या हुआ? परमिशन आपको मिल गई
एग्जीक्यूटेबल की। आपने जब + x लिख दिया।
सो व्हाट हैपेंस कि मेरे पास जितने भी थे
यूजर को भी एक्स एग्जीक्यूटेबल का परमिशन
मिल गया। ग्रुप को भी एग्जीक्यूटबल का
परमिशन मिल गया और अदर्स को भी मिल गया।
सो ये चीज हमें अगर नहीं करनी है तो अब
मैं क्या करूंगा? CH मोड यहां पे अब मैं
अगर - x करूं तो क्या होगा? देखो
अब मैं अरे यार ये क्या हो रहा है? यहां
से - x करूं और एंटर करूं और मैं परमिशन
अब देखूं तो देखो क्या होता है। यहां से x
की परमिशन हट गई। सभी से एक साथ हट गया।
राइट? एवरीथिंग रिमूव्ड। अब मुझे सिर्फ
यूजर को अगर परमिशन देनी है। आई ओनली हैव
टू
गिव द यूजर परमिशन। तो मैं क्या करूंगा?
सीए मोड
अब यूजर को + x कर दूंगा।
u + x क्योंकि यूजर को u से डिनोट करते
हैं। ग्रुप को g से और अदर्स को o से। तो
u + x और डिफ़्रॉनिक्स.x लिख दूंगा। फाइल
का नाम। एंटर करूंगा। अब मैं परमिशन चेक
करूंगा। तो यहां पे सिर्फ यूजर को
एग्जीक्यूट का परमिशन मिला है।
बाकी जो है
ग्रुप्स एंड अदर्स उनको परमिशन नहीं है।
इस तरीके से आप सिंगल एक यूजर को यहां
ग्रुप को देना है तो G + X अदर को देना है
तो O + X करके ऐसे दे सकते हो। आर यू
गेटिंग? समझ में आ रहा है? बट अब नंबर का
गेम करते हैं। अब नंबर का जब गेम खेलेंगे
हम जब न्यूममेरिक वाला गेम खेलेंगे तो आप
देख रहे हैं कि अगर अगर मुझे यूजर को अगर
मुझे यूजर को सबको परमिशन देनी है मान लो
सबको तो सबको परमिशन देनी है एग्जीक्यूट
का सबको एव्री आई वांट कि सबको एग्जीक्यूट
का परमिशन मिल जाए। तो उस केस में मैं
क्या करूंगा? सेवन वाली परमिशन यूज़ करूंगा
जो कि रीड, राइट, एग्ज़क्यूट तीनों की
परमिशन देती है। क्योंकि यहां पे सॉरी
यहां पे मैंने यहां पे बताया था कि
एग्जीक्यूट का परमिशन यहां पे वन नंबर के
साथ होता है।
एक नंबर एग्जीक्यूट का होता है। राइट? और
जीरो मींस नन होता है। और तीन फील्ड्स को
यह डिनोट करते हैं। तो मुझे अगर यूजर को
सिर्फ एग्जीक्यूट का परमिशन देना है,
व्हाट आई विल टाइप? सिर्फ यूजर को
एग्जीक्यूट का परमिशन देना है। याद
रखिएगा। मुझे बताइए कमांड सिर्फ यूजर को
एग्जीक्यूट का परमिशन देना है। यूजर को
सिर्फ एग्जीक्यूट का मतलब देखो
अभी मैं वापस से इसका हटा देता हूं। ये
वाला परमिशन u + x डाला था ना मैंने। u -
x कर देता हूं। तो यह हट जाएगा। पहले जैसा
हो जाएगा।
ठीक है? अभी [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
तो बताइए
बिल्कुल सही। वेरी गुड वेरी गुड वेरी गुड।
वेरी गुड। तो
एग्जीक्यूट यार समझते नहीं हो आप लोग।
एग्जीक्यूट
एक्स एग्जीक्यूट का नोटेशन क्या है? मुझे
बताओ।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है? वेरी गुड। 700 कुछ लोग 700 बोल
रहे हैं। चलिए। सो व्हाट आई विल डू? मैं
यहां पे सीएच मोड करता हूं। एंड यहां पे
एक नंबर लिखता हूं। तीन नंबर्स का गेम है।
राइट? तीन नंबर्स का गेम है यहां पे। रीड
राइट की परमिशन ऑलरेडी मिली हुई है। तो
रीड और राइट की परमिशन अगर मिली हुई है तो
अगर मैं यहां पे सिर्फ एग्जीक्यूट का
परमिशन देना चाहता हूं तो सेवन करूंगा
जिसमें रीड, राइट, एग्जीक्यूट तीनों हो
जाएगी यूज़र्स के लिए। ग्रुप के लिए ज़ीरो
कुछ नहीं। ग्रुप के लिए मुझे सिर्फ रीड ही
अगर रखना है। ओनली रीड रखना है तो दैट इज़
फाइन। बट ज़ीरो जैसे ही मैं करूंगा तो
परमिशन नन हो जाएगी। ज़ीरो एकदम नन हो
जाएगी। रीड भी नहीं रह जाएगा। फिर मैं
ज़ीरो करूंगा तो वही परमिशन नन हो जाएगी।
और डिफ्रॉनिक्स कर दूंगा और यहां पे मैं
एंटर करूंगा और मैं अगर अब मैं एलएस करता
हूं तो आप देखो यहां पे कि यूजर को रीड
राइट एग्जीक्यूट तो मिल चुका है बट बाकी
का नन हो चुका है। बट मुझे चाहिए था कि
बाकी को आर का परमिशन तो ओनली रहे। कम से
कम आर का तो रहे।
ओनली रीड का तो रहे।
यह मैंने आपको बोला हुआ था।
बट आप मेरी बातों को शायद नहीं समझ पाए।
तो यहां पर ओनली रीड का परमिशन हमारा
किसका है?
तो अब मैं क्या करता हूं कि यहां पे सीए
मोड 74 करता हूं डिफ़्रॉनिक्स और अब मैं
यहां पे एलएस हफन एल डिफ़्रॉनिक्स करता
हूं। तो अब देखो क्या हो रहा है। अब यहां
पे रीडराइट x तो हो गई जो होना था वह मिल
गया। अब यहां पे जो ग्रुप है उसको रीड का
मिल चुका ओनली और एग्जीक्यूटेबल को ओनली
रीड का मिल अदर्स को भी रीड का मिल चुका
यही चीज मैंने बोली थी यही चीज सेम चीज था
तो 700 से तो पूरा जीरो हो जाता ना बाकी
का लेकिन बहुत लोगों ने 7o बोला ये
हालांकि बहुत लोगों के कंफ्यूजन होते हैं
बहुत सारे इशूज़ होते हैं। अब मैं यहीं पे
यहीं पे अगर इस परमिशन को मान लो हटा भी
दूं।
मैं यहां पे क्या करता हूं? अ सीए मोड एंड
यूजर माइनस x कर देता हूं। डिफ्रontxt
अगेन
ठीक है?
अब मैंने यहां पे एलएस आईपन एल किया तो ये
आर एक्स खत्म हो गया। अब मैं यहां पे सीएच
मोड करता हूं। और यहां पे पहले वाली यूजर
को सिर्फ और सिर्फ एग्जीक्यूट का परमिशन
वन से मान लो देना है मुझे। और दूसरे वाले
का सिर्फ रीड ही रखना है और तीसरे वाले का
रीड रखना है तो फोर फोर कर दिया। लेकिन इस
चीज में होगा क्या कि पहले वाले को सिर्फ
रीड की परमिशन मिल जाएगी। अगर मैं ऐसा
करूंगा तो क्योंकि वन इज़ ओनली रीड मतलब
सॉरी वन इज़ ओनली एग्जीक्यूट ओनली
एग्जीक्यूट का परमिशन ये आर डब्ल्यू गायब
हो जाएगा। आर डब्ल्यू गायब हो जाएगा।
इसलिए हमें क्योंकि RW को भी रखना था तो
हमने इसको सात किया क्योंकि सात का मतलब
है R, डब्लू और X तीनों इसलिए हमने सात
किया। अगर सिर्फ हमें एग्जीक्यूट ही देना
होता तो हम सिर्फ वन लिखेंगे। ओनली
एग्जीक्यूट का परमिशन होगा। बाकी को रीड
ही मिलेगा। तो मैं अगर ये लिख के और
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स कर देता हूं
और एंटर कर देता हूं। तो अब देखो अब ls l
करूंगा तो देखो देखा पहले वाले को सिर्फ
एग्जीक्यूट का मिल गया बाकी को आर आर जो
पहले था वही मिला
लेकिन अगर वही शुरू फर्स्ट वाले को आर
डब्ल्यू एक्स तीनों चाहिए तो यहां एक के
जगह पे सात कर दो
सिंपल एंड ये पहले जैसा बिल्कुल हो जाएगा
जैसे हमारा बिल्कुल पहले था r डब्ल्यूx
एग्जीक्यूट के साथ रीड वाला रीड वाला ऐसे
करके ठीक है गॉट इट समझ में आ गया इतना
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़] पूरी परमिशन यही
थी भाई ईजीली समझा दिया आपको बहुत ज्यादा
कुछ ज्यादा ईजी समझ में आया सभी को एवरीवन
अंडरस्टुड प्लीज लेट मी नो गाइस फास्ट हरी
अपर
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यू गेटिंग गाइस
फुली अंडरस्टुड
फुली फुली समझ में आ गया आपको बताइए
चलिए ठीक है। अच्छी बात है। यह समझ में आ
गई। वेरी गुड। वेरी गुड। वेरी वेरी गुड।
परमिशन क्रिस्टल क्लियर हो गए। बहुत
बढ़िया। लैपटॉप ऑफ हो गया था। अरे यार बीच
में लैपटॉप कैसे ऑफ कर दिया? थोड़ी देर
आपको रिकॉर्डिंग देखनी पड़ेगी।
आप रियल में बहुत अच्छा पढ़ाते हो। क्यों
भाई? मैं फर्जी में पढ़ाता था क्या पहले?
अभी तक तुम्हें फर्जी लग रहा था क्या? अभी
अभी रियल में पढ़ाता हूं। अरे रियली अच्छा
पढ़ाता हूं यार। टेंशन क्यों लेने का? चलो
ये समझ में आ गया आपको? अब परमिशन की
कहानियां यहां खत्म। अब आ जाते हैं हमारे
इंपॉर्टेंट एक टॉपिक पे। स्लैश वेयर स्लैश
log जैसा मैंने बोला था। ये काफी
इंपॉर्टेंट होता है। व्हाट इज़ vयर लॉग?
मेन लinक्स लॉगिंग डायरेक्टरी। जहां लinx
में लॉग्स कलेक्ट होते हैं। Windows में
जैसे इवेंट लॉग्स पढ़ा था आपने। Linux में
लॉग में ही सारे लॉग्स कलेक्ट होते हैं।
इसमें ऑथेंटिकेशन लॉग्स होते हैं, सिस्टम
लॉग्स होते हैं। एप्लीकेशन से रिलेटेड
लॉग्स होते हैं। यानी कि जो भी लॉग इन
ऑथेंटिकेशन का लॉग होता है वो इसी में
होता है। सिस्टम से रिलेटेड कोई एक्टिविटी
होगा उसका लॉग इसी में होता है। एप्लीकेशन
से रिलेटेड कोई एक्टिविटी हो रही है
एप्लीकेशन के कोई उसकी भी लॉग जो होती है
इसी में होता है। तो एज एन एसओसीएल वन लॉग
इज़ एवरीथिंग। याद रखिएगा। एसओसी को क्यों
मतलब है? क्योंकि इन्वेस्टिगेशन जो है
Linux की कर रहे हैं तो लॉग एनालिसिस भी
आपको होनी चाहिए पता और उसके लिए लॉग का
पाथ पता होना चाहिए। ठीक है? अब लॉग के
अंदर वेयर लॉग के अंदर भी बहुत सारी और
लॉग फाइल्स होती हैं। जैसे अगर मैं आपको
यहां सिस्टम पे दिखाऊं।
सो इफ वी आर गोइंग टू सीडी
सॉरी CD
वेयर सीडी बोल रहा हूं तो सीडी सुन ले रही
है बताओ सीडी को अभी सीडी बहुत अच्छी नहीं
हुई है सीडी बहुत प्री है सीडी इज़ नॉट
एडवांस अभी कर अभी भी नहीं है एडवांस सीडी
क्योंकि मैं सीडी बोल रहा हूं तो ये सीडी
सीडी बोल रहा हूं तो सीडी समझ ले रही है
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] स्लैश
वायर वायर के अंदर चलते हैं एंटर करते हैं
एलएस करेंगे इसके अंदर में आपको एक लॉग
दिखेगा देखो यहां पे लॉग तो सीडी लॉग में
चलते हैं। एलएस करते हैं। मतलब इसके अंदर
भी अब सॉरी क्लियर इसके अंदर चलते हैं।
एलएस करता हूं मैं। अब इसके अंदर आपको
अलग-अलग देखो यहां पे ये लॉग्स की एंट्री।
ये अलग-अलग चीजें मिल गई लॉग वाली। देख
रहे हो कितनी सारी लॉग्स हैं यहां पे।
अलग-अलग तरह की चीजें मिलेंगी। ठीक है?
पोस्ट ग्रेसक्यूएल से मिल रिलेटेड लॉग हो
गया। इनिट से रिलेटेड लॉग हो गया। सैमस
रिलेटेड लॉग हो गया। सिस्टम स्टैट्स
रिलेटेड लॉग हो गया आपका। ठीक है? टॉर्च
रिलेटेड लॉग हो गई। वीएमवेयर से रिलेटेड
लॉ्स हो गए यहां पे। ठीक है? तो बहुत सारे
लॉग्स यहां पे आपको मिलते हैं। अलग-अलग
तरह के लॉग्स यू यू विल सी हियर लinक्स के
अंदर में। ठीक है? उसी में
इंसाइड दैट
इवन अ नॉन आईटी गाय विल अंडरस्टैंड। क्या
बात है यार। थैंक यू वेरी मच।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
थैंक यू वेरी मच। इतना अच्छा लगा आपको कि
नॉन आईटी लोग भी समझ पाएंगे अगर तो इससे
अच्छी क्या हो सकती है? अब इस वेयर लॉग
वाले के अंदर में अलग-अलग फाइल्स और भी
इंटरनली होती है। जैसे वेयर लॉग के अंदर
में ऑथ डॉट लॉग होता है। यह क्या करता है?
एसएसएच के लॉगिस के लॉग्स कंटेन करता है।
ऑथेंटिकेशन अटेमप्ट्स के बारे में जो है
ऑथेंटिकेटेड अटेम्प्ट्स के जो भी
ऑथेंटिकेशन हो रहा है उसके अटेम्प्ट्स के
बारे में बताता है। एंड सूडो यानी कि जो
एक तरह से अभी के लिए आप जान लीजिए कि एक
सूडs फाइल के अंदर जो भी कमांड जो भी लाइक
यूजर होती है उसको उसके कमांड्स को रन
करने के लिए बेसिकली ये यूज़ में आता है।
मतलब यू कैन अभी के लिए समझ लो कि एक सुपर
यूजर की तरह जो सुपर यूजर वाले जो यूसेस
होते हैं उसके चीजें भी होल्ड करता है।
ठीक है? फिलहाल के लिए सूडो बहुत खतरनाक
चीज है। अगर आप लोगों को एक एक्सप्लोर
करना हो तो सूडो को पढ़ लीजिएगा अलग से।
सूडो इज अ वेरी डेंजरस चीज इन लinक्स।
सूडो का अपना एक अलग दुनिया है लinक्स के
अंदर में। एक तो स्लैश के अंदर पूरी
लinक्स है और उस लinिक्स के अंदर में एक
सूडो एक अलग दुनिया है। ठीक है? तो उसको
बारे में थोड़ा पढ़िएगा। उसके बाद एक फाइल
होती है स्लैश वायर लॉग के अंदर में sिस
लॉग सिस्टम लॉग सिस्टम लॉग्स को कंटेन
करती है। एक फाइल होती है कर्नल डॉट log
जो कि कर्नल लॉग्स को कंटेन करती है। अब
कभी-कभी आपको कुछ फाइल्स हो सकता है ना
दिखे। वो चीजें कभी वो ऑपरेशन होता है वो
चीजें एग्जीक्यूट होती है तब वो फाइल
जनरेट होती है। तो इतना टेंशन नहीं लेना
कि सर आपने तो बोला था होता है बट है ही
नहीं है मेरे में। तो वो चीज़ कभी कोई वो
इवेंट ओकर हुआ। कोई इवेंट एग्जीक्यूट हुआ
तो वो फाइल्स ऑटोमेटिकली लॉक फाइल बन जाती
है। लॉक फाइल्स आप नहीं बनाते। ये
ऑटोमेटिक क्रिएट होता है। अब एसएसएस से
रिलेटेड लॉक फाइल हो सकता है आपको कहीं ना
मिले। लेकिन जैसे ही आप एसएसएस सर्विस यूज़
करोगे सिक्योर लॉग इन के लिए वो फाइल
ऑटोमेटिकली क्रिएट हो जाएगी और उसके अंदर
में लॉग्स जनरेट होना शुरू हो जाएंगे। उसी
तरीके से वय लॉग सिक्योर एक लोकेशन होता
है जो कि रेड हैंट या सॉरी रेड हैट या सOS
में यूज़ होता है। ठीक है ना? ये जनरली यूज़
होता है। ठीक? अब देखिए
यहां पे
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
कुछ और भी यहां पे है जैसे वेयर लॉग
मैसेजेस जो कि जनरली सिस्टम एक्टिविटी के
बारे में लॉक करते हैं। वायर लॉक Apache
टू एक्सेस लॉग जो कि वेब एक्सेस लॉक वेब
Apache सर्वर यूज़ कर रहे हैं आप उससे
रिलेटेड जो लॉक्स हैं वो आपको बताता है।
फिर उसी तरीके से Vire LG Apache 2 के
अंदर एरर लॉग होती है। Apache सर्वर यूज़
कर रहे हैं कोई चीज़ होस्ट किया आपने। उसके
एरर जो सर्वर से रिलेटेड एरर वगैरह है
उसको भी यहां पे ये लॉक करते हैं। तो
अलग-अलग जो है वो लॉगिन सिस्टम यहां पे
चलती है। ये पूरे लॉग्स होते हैं। अब इसी
में जो मैंने लॉग्स आपसे डिस्कस किए उसमें
मैंने आपको बताया था ऑथेंटिकेशन एक लॉग्स
होते हैं। ऑथेंटिकेशन लॉ्स आर वेरी
वेरीेंट। क्यों? क्योंकि ये यूजर के लॉग
इन को ट्रैक करते हैं। एसएसएच एक्सेस जो
होता है। एसएसएच एसएसए जो होता है एक तरह
से यू कैन से कि
एक रिमोट सिक्योर रिमोट लॉग इन एक
प्रोटोकॉल है एसएसएच जो कि बेसिकली
सिक्योर लॉगिन के लिए या सिक रिमोट एक्सेस
के लिए यूज़ में लिया जाता है एसएसएच को तो
एसएसएच एक्सेस के लिए जो है यह भी ट्रैक
करता है इसको फेल्ड लॉगिन्स को ट्रैक करते
हैं ऑथेंटिकेशन लॉग्स और सूडो के यूसेस को
ट्रैक करते हैं। अब U12
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] या डेबियन जो
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स होते हैं आपके Linux
जैसे U12 या काली Linux वगैरह हो गया ये
सब जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम होते हैं हम
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
इसमें ये पाथ होता है जनरली wlogg और डॉट
log और आरएचएल या SOS की जब बात करते हैं
रेड इंटरप्राइज Linux या SOS जैसी लinक्स
डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन क्योंकि ये दूसरे टाइप के
लिनिक्स डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन होते हैं। ये अलग
होते हैं। तो इसमें WC सिक्योर इस लोकेशन
पे
आपकी प्रेजेंट होती है। तो यही चीज यहां
पे मैंने आपको बताया था कि वायर लॉग
सिक्योर जो है यह इक्विवेलेंट होता है
किसके ऑर्थ डॉट log के इस वाले जो डेबियन
बेस linx है ये है रेड हट या सेंटो एस बेस
linx ठीक है एग्जांपल लॉग अगर देखें तो
कुछ इस तरीके का लॉग का आपको लॉग सैंपल
लॉग देखने को मिल जाएगा जब आप एज एन एसओसी
एल1 इन्वेस्टिगेट कर रहे होंगे जब आप काम
कर रहे होंगे सिस्टम पे तो आपको कुछ इस
तरीके का लॉग देखने को मिल सकता है जैसे
जुलाई 10 मतलब एक डेट होगी एक टाइम होगा
सेकंड्स के साथ उसका सर्वर मान लो ऐसा
होगा सर्वर एसएसएचडी 2 3 4 5 एसएसएचडी एक
डीमन होता है जो एसएसएच
सर्विस को स्टार्ट करने यूज़ करने के लिए
यूज़ रिस्पांसिबल होता है। इसके बिना एसएसए
आप यूज़ नहीं कर सकते। Linux में जितने भी
आप पैकेजेस को या सर्विसेस को यूज़ करेंगे
उसका एक डीमन होता है। डीमन। डीमन का मतलब
उसका एक चलाने वाला एक फाइल होता है जो
उसको इनिशिएट करने के लिए हेल्प करता है।
चलाता है उसको उसको हम डीमन बोलते हैं।
ठीक है? उसी के कारण वो सर्विस चल रही
होती है। तो एसएसएच के लिए एसएसएच डी एक
डीमन है। एक्सेप्टेड पासवर्ड फॉर एडमिन
फ्रॉम इतना। मतलब इस आईपी से एक पासवर्ड
एक्सेप्ट किया गया है फॉर एडमिन यूजर नेम।
तो इस तरह का कोई एक लॉग आपको देखने को
मिल सकता है। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब व्हाट इज़ एसएसएच? तो इसको हम सिक्योर
सेल बोलते हैं। एक सिक्योर टनल बोल लो
सिक्योर सेल लॉगिन वगिन करने के लिए रिमोट
एक्सेस के लिए। रिमोट एक्सेस वगैरह करते
हैं। पोर्ट इसका पोर्ट नंबर होता है 22।
ठीक है? एंड अटैकर्स को क्यों मजा आता है
इसमें? क्योंकि यह रिमोट कंट्रोल प्रोवाइड
करता है, पर्सिस्टेंस प्रोवाइड करता है,
लेटरल मूवमेंट भी प्रोवाइड करता है।
एसएसएच के थ्रू आप एक मशीन से दूसरे मशीन
में लॉग इन कर सकते हैं। एक मशीन से दूसरे
मशीन को एक्सेस कर सकते हैं। एसएसएच इज़
क्वाइट डेंजरस। ठीक है? अगर ये
कॉम्प्रोमाइज किसी भी तरीके से हो जाता है
तो इट इज़ वेरी वेरी वेरी वेरी डेंजरस। ठीक
है? डेमन डेमन डेमन डेमन।
अब लinक्स का जो एसएसएच जो है ठीक है? वो
कुछ इस तरीके से काम करता है जो मैं आपको
अभी बताने जा रहा हूं। एक एसएसएच क्लाइंट
होती है। Linux में कोई भी सर्विस यूज़
करते हैं। उसका एक क्लाइंट होता है, एक
सर्वर होता है। ठीक है? तो एसएसएच क्लाइंट
जो है कुछ इस तरीके से एसएसएच का एक कमांड
इशू करता है। जब भी कोई आपको एसएसएच के
थ्रू कोई भी रिमोट होस्ट से कनेक्ट होना
होता है। तो आप कमांड में क्या लिखते हो?
एसएसएच स्पेस यूजरनेम होस्ट या उसकी जो भी
उसकी IPपी एड्रेस है। इसका एग्जांपल मैं
आपको बताता हूं। जैसे मान लो किसी एसएसएच
से कनेक्ट करना चाहते हो। ठीक है?
मैं देखता हूं कोई ऑनलाइन है कि नहीं।
ऑनलाइन एसएसएच
रिमोट मशीन देखते हैं कुछ अगर होगा तो
ओके ये तो ऑनलाइन क्लाइंट है ये। इनका
क्लाइंट्स तो मिल जाएंगे बट आई डोंट थिंक
कि
मशीन हमें जल्दी मिलेगा।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] देखते हैं।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
नहीं आया। नहीं आया। जनरली कोई रखेगा तो
नहीं।
5% यहां है तो सही बट कौन सा इसका कुछ दे
रखा है क्या? एसएस फ्री टनल। ठीक है। 6%
यूज़ क्रिएट एसएसएस टनल देखते हैं। लेट्स
सी।
अच्छा ये बाय करने का हट यार। फ्री चाहिए
फ्री।
ऐड दिखा रहे हैं। [संगीत]
[संगीत][गाना गाने की आवाज़]
[संगीत]
[गाना गाने की आवाज़]
हमारा भी वीपीएस है तो हम कनेक्ट तो कर
सकते हैं बट
इसके लिए ऐड दिखा रहे थे।
अच्छा
फ्री है क्या यह
होस्ट यहां पे है बट
व्हाट इज़ अ यूज़ अच्छा अकाउंट क्रिएट करना
पड़ेगा ठीक है ये अकाउंट क्रिएट करके होगा
ऐसे तो होगा नहीं ठीक है कोई बात नहीं है
चलो मतलब कहने का मतलब है अगर होस्ट ऐसे
है जैसे मान लो मान लो मैं रूट यूजर के
लिए अप्लाई कर रहा हूं मैं ये होस्ट है
मान लो मैंने कॉपी कर लिया ठीक है तो
व्हाट विल आई विल डू एसएसएच और रूट यूजर
से कनेक्ट करना चाहता हूं मैं रूट @ और जो
भी होस्ट का आपका नाम है तो मैंने यहां पे
जो भी होस्ट का एड्रेस है वो होस्ट का
एड्रेस यहां पे आपको डाल देना है कुछ इस
तरीके से। ठीक है? और बस पोर्ट नंबर भी आप
माइनस हफन पी से पोर्ट नंबर असाइन कर सकते
हो। बाय डिफ़ॉल्ट आपका 22 पे होगा और एंटर
कर दीजिए। अब यह आपसे पूछेगा आर यू श्योर
यू वांट टू कंटिन्यू कनेक्टिंग? क्या आप
कनेक्ट होना चाहते हैं? आप यस करेंगे।
एंटर करेंगे। एंटर करोगे यहां पे। अब आ
रहा है पासवर्ड। इसका पासवर्ड क्या है?
रूट। इसका पासवर्ड मतलब यह सही हमने
कनेक्ट तो सही किया है। बट अब इसका
पासवर्ड क्या है? पासवर्ड करने के लिए यूज़
करने के लिए यहां पे आपको अकाउंट बनाना
पड़ेगा यहां पे। क्योंकि पासवर्ड ये ऐसे तो
देंगे नहीं। यहां अकाउंट बना के आप
पासवर्ड ले सकते हैं। एंड यहां पे आप
कनेक्ट कर सकते हैं। अब मैं यहां पे अ
कुछ भी डाल देता हूं तो ये रॉन्ग पासवर्ड
आ जाएगा। अगर मैंने कुछ भी पासवर्ड डाला
तो परमिशन डिनाइड आ रहा है। तो इस तरीके
से आप कनेक्ट करते हैं। सो व्हाट आई मीन
टू से
कि यह एक फॉर्मेट है। इसके साथ आप IPपी
एड्रेस भी यूज़ कर सकते हैं। यहां पे जैसे
आपके पास रूट एड्रेस कोई IP एड्रेस है मान
लो तो
इस तरह से IPपी एड्रेस भी दे सकते हैं।
किसी वीपीएस या किसी सर्वर से करना हो तो
आप IPपी एड्रेस डाल के एसएसएस के थ्रू
कनेक्ट कर सकते हैं। ठीक है? तो आप रिमोट
लॉग इन उस सर्वर में रिमोट लॉगिन हो जाते
हैं। इसी तरीके से जब आप बग बंटी वगैरह
कोई करता है, बग हंटिंग करता है, बग बंटी
हंटर जो होते हैं या आप करेंगे कभी तो जो
वीपीएस आप लेते हैं जैसे आप डिजिटल ओशियन
से ले लिया आपने या फिर आपने किसी भी
वीपीएस कंपनी से वीपीएस ले लिया ताकि आपका
स्पीड काफी अच्छा है। तो उसके वीपीएस से
आप ऐसे ही कनेक्ट करते हैं। आपने वीpएस
वहां स्टार्ट कर दिया। आप अपने काली के
टर्मिनल पे आए या Windows के टर्मिनल पे
आपने वहां के untटू मशीन या काली मशीन में
कनेक्ट कर लिया। वहां की स्पीड से एकदम
मस्त आप अपना बग बंटी दबा के कीजिए। मस्ती
में खींचिए, मजे में कीजिए, स्पीड आएगी।
ऐसे ही होता है। ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके।
नाउ लेट्स क्लोज ऑल दिस फालतू चीजें।
लेट्स मूव टू द स्लाइड।
ओके। तो ये थी हमारी भैया एसएसएच। किस ऐसे
इशू करता है कमांड? कमांड जब इशू होती है
ये एप्लीकेशन लेयर में काम करती है।
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर में फिर हम जाते हैं
नेक्स्ट। तो यूजरनेम होता है, होस्ट होता
है और प्राइवेट की एक्सचेंज होती है। हम
जब करेंगे तो वहां पे प्राइवेट की
एक्सचेंज हम करते हैं। प्राइवेट की सेंड
करते हैं। उसके बाद मैसेज जो है सेंड होता
है पैकेट्स के फॉर्म में। कहां पे जाता
है? एसएसएच सर्वर के पास। अब एसएस सर्वर
से जब जाता है तो प्राइवेट की गेट्स
वेरीिफाइड। अब प्राइवेट की जो है वो
वेरीफाई होती है वहां के स्टर्ड मशीन में
जो स्टर्ड की होती है उससे जो कि इस
लोकेशन पे वेरी प्रेजेंट रहती है। एसएसएच
ऑथोराइज्ड कीज़ इस लोकेशन पे वो प्रेजेंट
रहती है। अब ये लोकेशन कहां मिलेगा आपको?
डॉट एसएसएच है। इसका मतलब यह एक हिडन फाइल
है। ठीक है? याद रखिएगा। डॉट एसएसए हिडन
फाइल है। तो मैं सीडी में चलता हूं यहां
पे। अब मैं यहां पे क्या करूंगा? एलएस हफन
a इससे आप हिडन फाइल्स को देख सकते हैं इस
लोकेशन पे। मैंने यहां पे किया। अब यहां
पे देखो डॉट वाले सारे भी दिख रहे हैं
यहां पे। डॉट वाले दिख रहे हैं आपको? डॉट
वाले भी। बिना एलएस हफन a के मैं एलएस
करूंगा ना, तो आपको बस चार पांच चीजें
दिखेंगी। बस जैसे ही एलएस हफन ए किया यहां
डॉट वाली दिख रही है। अब इसमें देखो डॉट
एसएसए करके भी एक डायरेक्टरी है। तो इसके
अंदर जाना है सीडी डॉट एसएसए एंटर करेंगे।
एलएस करेंगे। अब इसके अंदर में आपको यहां
पे फाइल्स वो कॉन्फ़िगरेशन की मिल सकती है।
या तो डॉट कॉन्फ़िग वाले में भी मिल सकती
है। कहीं भी मिल सकती है। तो यहां पे अभी
कोई प्राइवेट की क्रिएट नहीं हुई है तो
नहीं मिल रही। अगर प्राइवेट की क्रिएट
होगी तो आपको वहां पे ये वाली फाइल देखने
को मिलेगी। कौन सी फाइल भैया?
ऑथराइज्ड कीज़ जो भी वहां पर की सेव होगी
वह आपको देखने को मिल जाएगी और जैसे ही
वेरीफाई हो जाती है आपका प्राइवेट की
वेरीफाई होगा और आपको ऑथेंटिकेशन मिल
जाएगा आप कनेक्ट कर पाएंगे तो पहला
एप्लीकेशन लेयर में आप इशू करते हैं कमांड
को एप्लीकेशन लेयर जहां यूजर इंटैक्ट करता
है एप्लीकेशन से उसके बाद ट्रांसपोर्ट
लेयर में बाकी काम आपके हो जाते हैं
क्लाइंट का और सर्वर साइट का जो भी
वेरिफिकेशन वगैरह होता है सर्वर को भेजना
होता है एंड देन आपका वेरिफिकेशन ओके एंड
दैट्स इट आपका काम यहां पे कंप्लीट हो
जाता है एसएस से लॉग इन हो जाती
तो एसएसएच [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
एक क्लाइंट कमांड होता है। एसएसएचडी इसका
जो डेमन होता है जो डेमन जो इसको चलाता है
सर्वर प्रोसेस जो होता है वो एसएसएचडी
होता है। पोर्ट 22 होती है। एसएसएच के
ऑथेंटिकेशन दो मेथड्स होते हैं। एक
पासवर्ड ऑथेंटिकेशन होता है। एक की बेस्ड
ऑथेंटिकेशन होता है। तो पासवर्ड
ऑथेंटिकेशन में क्या होता है कि आप
पासवर्ड डालते हैं। यूजरनेम और पासवर्ड
डालते हैं और आपका ऑथेंटिकेशन हो जाता है।
और एक की बेस्ड ऑथेंटिकेशन होता है जिसमें
पब्लिक की और प्राइवेट की का यूज़ किया
जाता है। यह क्रिप्टोग्राफिक जो एल्गोरिदम
होती है मतलब एक क्रिप्टोग्राफिक जो
टेक्निक है उसका यूज़ होता है यहां पे
पब्लिक की और प्राइवेट की कांसेप्ट। ठीक
है? और सिमेट्रिक सिमेट्रिक इंक्रिप्शन
आपने पढ़ा होगा वो चीज यहां पे यूज़ होती
है। तो यूजर नेम पासवर्ड तो नॉर्मल है। आप
सब जानते हैं यूजर डाला, पासवर्ड डाला हो
गया। अब आगे बढ़ते हैं कि अब इसमें हम
देखते हैं कि पासवर्ड ऑथेंटिकेशन में क्या
होता है और पब्लिक की ऑथेंटिकेशन प्राइवेट
की ऑथेंटिकेशन में क्या होता है। इसको
थोड़ा सा समझ लेते हैं। उसके बाद आपकी
क्लास ऑलमोस्ट खत्म है। उसके बाद ज्यादा
कुछ नहीं है। थोड़ा देर और इतनी देर वेट
किया तो 10 मिनट वेट कीजिए। आपका कहानी
यहां पे समाप्त हो जाएगा।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अब देखो पासवर्ड ऑथेंटिकेशन में क्या होता
है? द क्लाइंट सेंड्स द यूजरनेम एंड
पासवर्ड। आप क्लाइंट हैं। आप एसएसएच से
कनेक्ट करना चाहते हैं किसी और रिमोट मशीन
से। आपने क्या किया? यूजरनेम पासवर्ड डाला
थ्रू इंक्रिप्टेड टनल। द सर्वर चेक्स द
ईटीसी शैडो पाथ ऑन लinक्स टू सी इफ दे मैच
सिंपल बट वलनेरेबल टू ब्रूसफोर्ड अटैक्स।
अब सर्वर जो है इस पाथ को देखता है ईटीसी
शैडो पाथ को। क्यों? क्योंकि यही पाथ है
जहां पे
पासवर्ड्स स्टोर किए जाते हैं। ईटीसी शैडो
पाथ पे। यह अगर आपको मैं दिखाऊं तो यह जो
पाथ है बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग और बहुत ही
सेंसिटिव पार्ट है आपके लनिक्स। मैं कैट
ईटीc करूं शैडो करूं
तो यहां पे जितने भी यूज़र्स हैं उनके
पासवर्ड स्ट होते हैं। जिस-जिस यूजर के
पासवर्ड सेट होंगे आपको यहां पे दिख
जाएंगे। कौन सा होता है? कौन सा कॉलन होता
है इसमें? पहला यूजर का नाम होता है और
दूसरा कॉलन जो होता है वो पासवर्ड हैश का
होता है जो यहां तक आपकी जा रही है। ये
पासवर्ड हैश है
जो यहां पे है सेट किया हुआ है ये इसका
मतलब है रूट का पासवर्ड यहां पे सेट है
इसलिए ये हैश दिख रहा है बाकी कोई यूजर जो
है अगर कोई मान लो कोई और यूजर है जैसे कि
इफ देयर एनी यूजर हां एक और यूजर है
डिफ्रॉनिक्स तो इसका पासवर्ड सेट है तो
यहां पे पासवर्ड दिख रहा है दैट्स इट यही
इसका मेन गेम है यही है बस और कुछ नहीं अब
अगर मैं डिफ्रॉनिक्स का पासवर्ड हटा दूं
ठीक है? मैं जैसे एक कमांड होता है पास
डब्ल्यू डी हफन डी और मैं डिफ्रॉनिक्स लिख
दूं और एंटर करूं तो यहां पे पासवर्ड चेंज
हो चुका है। पासवर्ड चेंज हो चुका है।
अब यहां पे मैं शैडो करूंगा ईटीसी शैडो।
तो डिफ्रॉनिक्स के आगे आपको लंबी सी
स्ट्रिंग नहीं दिखेगी क्योंकि यहां पे
पासवर्ड वाला जो एरिया है वो ब्लैंक है।
डी से मैंने पासवर्ड को डिलीट कर दिया।
डिफ्रॉनिक्स के पासवर्ड को हटा दिया। तो
अब आपको दिखेगा रूट में तो दिखेगा वो लंबा
सा स्ट्रिंग क्योंकि रूट का पासवर्ड अभी
भी सेट है। गॉट इट? हैशड पासवर्ड होता है।
वो हैड्ड पासवर्ड होता है। अरे वो प्लेन
टेक्स्ट पासवर्ड नहीं है भाई। वो एक्चुअल
पासवर्ड नहीं होता। ये एक्चुअल पासवर्ड
स्टोर होगी क्या सिस्टम पे ताकि कोई भी आए
इस पाथ को खोले और पासवर्ड आपका देख ले।
हैशड पासवर्ड होती है। इसको हम पासवर्ड
हैशिंग बोलते हैं फॉर सिक्योरिटी रीज़। अब
मैंने यहां पे पासवर्ड ये कमांड डाला पास
डब्ल्यू डी हफन डी डिफ़्रॉनिक्स। तो
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स यूजर का पासवर्ड हट चुका है।
अब यहां पे कुछ भी नहीं आ रहा। अब मैं
अगेन अगर पासवर्ड सेट कर दूं। जैसे मैंने
सेट किया पास डब्ल्यू डी डिफ़्रॉनिक्स। अब
मैं पासवर्ड सेट कर रहा हूं।
ये रहा 1 2 3 4 5 ये डाला। पासवर्ड सेट हो
चुका है। अब मैं वापस से जब ईटीसी शैडो
देखूंगा तो डिफ़्रॉनिक्स के आगे वापस से
पासवर्ड हैश जो है हमारी आ चुकी है।
पासवर्ड सेट हो चुका है। समझ में आ गया?
यहां रूट का पासवर्ड भी हटा सकते हैं। कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। फिर से लगा दो। रूट का
पासवर्ड। रूट का पासवर्ड हटाओ। फिर से सेट
कर दो। कोई बात नहीं है। तो यह होती है
ईटीसी शैडो जहां पासवर्ड स्टोर होती है।
तो ये उसी लोकेशन को चेक करता है जब आप
यूजरनेम पासवर्ड डालते हो एसएसएच लॉगिन के
लिए। तो बट जब वहां जहां भी यूजरनेम और
पासवर्ड के जीकर हो तो ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक
वहां पर पॉसिबल है और ये थोड़ा सा लेस अ
मतलब यू कैन से थोड़ी वीक अ तरीका है
एसएसएच का पासवर्ड ऑथेंटिकेशन उसी से
ज्यादा स्ट्रांग है पब्लिक की ऑथेंटिकेशन
द सिक्योर वे इसमें क्या होता है दिस
यूजसेस अ सिमेट्रिक इंक्रिप्शन जिसमें
आरएसए या ईडी 25519 यूज़ होता है ये एक
एल्गोरिदम है इंक्रिप्शन एल्गोरिदम है
आरएसए से हो गया या ईडी वाला हो गया कोई
भी। दिस इज़ द मोस्ट कॉमन प्रोफेशनल मेथड।
द सेटअप। इसमें क्या होता है? यू हैव अ
प्राइवेट की केप्ट ऑन योर मशीन। आप एज अ
क्लाइंट है तो आपका एक प्राइवेट की है जो
मशीन पे है। एंड अ पब्लिक की प्लेस्ड इन द
सर्वर्स फाइल। तो आप ही क्लाइंट हैं। तो
आपके पास एक प्राइवेट की पड़ी है। और एक
पब्लिक की है जो सर्वर के पास पड़ी है।
सर्वर वाली फाइल में। तो सर्वर का फाइल वो
पब्लिक की कहां स्टोर होगी? वो स्टोर होगी
इसी लोकेशन पे। जो मैंने लोकेशन थोड़ी देर
पहले दिखाई थी आपको। वो जो हिडन फाइल थी
एसएसए उसके अंदर में एक फाइल बनती है
ऑथोराइज्ड कीज़ अगर नहीं बनी है तो आप खुद
से एक फाइल जनरेट कर दीजिए सेम नाम से
ऑथोराइज्ड अंडरस्कोर कीज़ और उसमें वो
स्टोर हो जाएगी अगर नहीं जनरेट हो रही है
ऑटोमेटिकली लinक्स में ये खूबी है कि अगर
कोई फाइल ऑटोमेटिकली जनरेट नहीं हो पा रही
है तो आप खुद से भी सेम फाइल नेम के साथ
उस सेम लोकेशन पे फाइल जनरेट कर दीजिए उसी
में स्टोर होना शुरू हो जाएगा जो भी इनेशन
है क्योंकि वह उसी से लिंक्ड है। द चैलेंज
अब क्या होता है? द क्लाइंट टेल्स द सर्वर
वि की इट वांट्स टू यूज़।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] क्लाइंट
सर्वर को बोलता है द सर्वर जनरेट्स अ
रैंडम नंबर अ चैलेंज। एक चैलेंज जनरेट
करता है। अरे ऐसा थोड़ी है ना चैलेंज सॉल्व
करो। इंक्रिप्ट इट इट यूजिंग योर पब्लिक
की एंड सेंड्स इट टू द क्लाइंट। उसको
पब्लिक की से इंक्रिप्ट कर देता है और
क्लाइंट को सेंड कर देता है। ओनली योर
प्राइवेट की कैन डिक्रिप्ट दैट मैसेज। अब
वो क्योंकि आपके पब्लिक की से वो
इंक्रिप्टेड रहेगा। तो आपके पास जो
प्राइवेट की है उसी से सिर्फ डिक्रिप्ट हो
सकता है। द क्लाइंट डिक्रिप्ट्स इट्स
कंबाइन इट विद द सेशन आईडी एंड सेंड्स अ
सिग्नेचर सेंड्स अ सिग्नेचर बैक। क्लाइंट
क्या करता है उसको डिक्र मतलब सर्वर जब
क्लाइंट बोलता है
ठीक है [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] कि भैया
लॉगिन करना है आपको यूज़ करना है। तो सर्वर
बोलता है ऐसे कैसे पहले तुम वेरीफाई तो
करो खुद को। तो एक चैलेंज है लो सॉल्व करो
इसको। ठीक है ये चीज। तो क्लाइंट बोलता है
अच्छा भेजो। अब वो चैलेंज जो भेजेगा
पब्लिक की से इंक्रिप्ट करके भेजेगा। अब
सर्वर के क्लाइंट के पास जो प्राइवेट की
है सिर्फ उसी प्राइवेट की से वह डिक्रिप्ट
हो सकती है। तो वो उसको डिक्रिप्ट कर देगा
और उसको क्या करेगा? भेज देगा वापस सेशन
की के साथ और एक सिग्नेचर के साथ कि हां
भैया डन। द सर्वर वेरीफाई द सिग्नेचर इफ
इट मैचेस यू आर इन। सर्वर वेरीफाई करता है
और आप मस्त चालू कर देते हो। राइट? मस्ती
में। यह चीज होती है पूरी ऑथेंटिकेशन
सिस्टम जो कि पब्लिक की पर बेस्ड होती है।
तो, यह ज्यादा सिक्योर होता है। पब्लिक की
ऑथेंटिकेशन, पासवर्ड बेस्ड ऑथेंटिकेशन
थोड़ा बेसिक हो गया। थोड़ा लेस सिक्योर हो
गया। क्योंकि यहां पे पूरा
क्रिप्टोग्राफिक एल्गोरििदम्स यूज़ हो रहे
हैं। मल्टी स्टेप ऑथेंटिकेशन हो रही है।
यहां तो बस एक चीज हो रहा है डेटाबेस के
उससे तो ब्रूट फ़ोर्स हो सकता है। दैट्स द
थिंग।
Linux [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] एसएसएच की
बात करें Linux में तो एसओसी के लिए
बहुतेंट होता है क्योंकि अटैकर्स जो है वह
अपनी खुद की एसएसए कीज़ डाल देते हैं और
पर्सिस्टेंस अचीव कर लेते हैं। अगर खुद की
एसएसएच कीज़ अटैकर्स ने डाल दी तो वो
एसएसएच एक्सेस एसएसएच के थ्रू सिस्टम को
कभी भी एक्सेस कर सकते हैं। आप सिस्टम को
रिबूूट कीजिए। कुछ भी कीजिए क्योंकि उनका
एसएसएच की है। वो डाल के आपके पास रखे हुए
हैं। वो उधर से कमांड भेजेंगे। इधर से
प्राइवेट पब्लिक की जाएगी। वो आराम से
डिक्रिप्ट हो जाएगी। तो उन्होंने कहा अरे
भाई यह तो अपना ही बंदा है। लॉग इन हो
जाएंगे आप। तो यह बहुत डेंजरस चीज है। तो
रियल एसोसिएट इन्वेस्टिगेशन फ्लो को देखें
तो मेनी फेल्ड एसएसएच लॉगिनस आपको देखने
को मिल सकते हैं। देन हो सकता है आपको
सक्सेस भी मिल जाए। सूडो एक्टिविटी भी
करने का मौका मिल जाए। तो यह सब आपको
चीजें देखनी है। यह सिनेरियो हो सकती है।
बीइंग एन एसओसी एल1 आपको यह सिनेरियोज़
देखने को मिल सकती है। बहुत सारी फेल्ड
एसएस लॉगिंस वगैरह हो रही है। और जब ऐसी
चीजें हो, तो आप एज एसओसी क्या सोचेंगे कि
यहां ब्रूट फ़ोर्स जो है वो हुआ है,
कॉम्प्रोमाइज हुआ है। एंड यहां पे
प्रिविलेज एस्क्लेशन हुई है क्योंकि सूडो
एक्टिविटी हो रही है। यानी कि सुपर यूजर
वाली एक्टिविटी हो रही है। आप ऑलरेडी एक
सुपर यूजर बन चुके हैं। Linux में रूट जो
यूजर होता है जनरली वो सुपर यूजर कहलाता
है। एंड उसको सारी फैसिलिटीज़ होती हैं जो
सूडोअर्स लिस्ट में होता है जिसमें सूडो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] एक्टिविटी यानी
जो मेन यूजर है सूडो यूज़र एंड सुपर यूज़जर
वह सारी एक्टिविटी कर रहा है। तो इसका
मतलब वहां पे आपका प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन हो
गया। आप एक रूट यूजर आप एक सबसे खतरनाक
यूजर बन चुके हैं। रूट फ़ोर्स के बाद ऐसा
हुआ है। ठीक है? ये चीज़ भी होनी है। ये
चीज़ भी आपको समझ में आनी चाहिए। यस आपने
डाउट पूछिए। गेमिंग गेमिंग फाइनल एसओसी
माइंडसेट क्या हो सकता है यहां पे? व्हेन
इन्वेस्टिगेटिंग Linux जब आप Linux को
इन्वेस्टिगेट कर रहे हैं तो वाज़ देयर अ
लॉग इन? यह आपको नहीं पूछना है। इसके बदले
में आपको क्या पूछना है? हु लॉ्ड इन किसने
लॉग इन किया? कहां से लॉग इन किया? किस
मेथड से लॉग इन किया है? लॉग इन के बाद
एक्चुअली क्या-क्या हुआ? क्या प्रिविलेज
एस्क्लेशन हुआ था? या प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
ट्राई किया गया था? यह क्वेश्चंस आपको
बीइंग एन एसओसी
आपको पूछना है अपने आप से। एज अ एसओसी
माइंडसेट आपके दिमाग में ये होना चाहिए।
चलिए और आज क्या बात है कि अभी तक एंड तक
लगभग 50 लोग यहां पे आज की क्लास में
जुड़े हैं। ये खतरनाक चीज हो गई। लinक्स
ज्यादा ही पसंद आ रही है मुझे लगता है आप
लोगों को क्योंकि लक्स इंटरेस्टिंग भी है।
चीजें नई-नई चीजें देखने को सीखने को और
जानने को मिलती है तो आपको मजा आता है।
Windows से आप लोग परेशान थक जाते हैं
बेचारे क्योंकि Windows में ज्यादा कुछ
डीप जा नहीं सकते। ज्यादा कुछ होता समझ
में नहीं आता जब तक आप Windows फॉरेंसिक्स
पे काम नहीं कर रहे हैं। जब तक आप उसको
खोल के नहीं रख रहे हैं उसकी चीजों को।
राइट?
इंटरेस्टिंग है। तो ये
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] होती है आज की
सेशन कंप्लीट। काफी लंबी हो गई आज की भी
सेशन। लगभग 2ाई घंटे की सेशन आज भी हो गई
आपकी। एक बार और हुई थी काफी लंबी सेशन।
बट आई होप कि जो एफर्ट मैं आपके लिए डाल
रहा हूं, जो जो एफर्ट मैं आपको प्रोवाइड
कर रहा हूं इनसेस के थ्रू आई होप आप उसकी
रिस्पेक्ट जरूर करेंगे और उस चीज को थोड़ा
सा सीरियस लेते हुए एंड
देखते होंगे आप इनसेस को इन सेशंस को आप
आई होप कि शेयर करते होंगे अपने दोस्तों
के बीच जो भी एंथूजियास्टिक्स हैं जो भी
एसओसी सीखना चाहते हैं एसओसी एल वन बनना
चाहते हैं या जो भी एसओसी एल1 रोल के लिए
प्रिपेयर कर रहे हैं वो उन तक आपको को यह
वीडियो पहुंचाने हैं। आप खुद तो सीख रहे
हैं। आपको पता चल चुका है तो आप आ चुके
हैं। बट मैं आपको यह बोलना चाहता हूं कि
जितने भी ग्रुप्स हैं ना Telegram,
WhatsApp, Instagram स्टेटस, स्टोरीज,
Facebook ग्रुप्स हर जगह इन वीडियोस को
फैलाइए क्योंकि आपके अलावा और भी बहुत
सारे ऐसे लोग हैं जिनको इसकी जरूरत हो
सकती है। उनको नहीं पता कि यहां पे यह चीज़
यह ट्रेनिंग चल रही है। उनको नहीं पता
होगा डिफ़्रॉनिक्स के बारे में। उनको नहीं
पता होगा डिफ़्रॉनिक्स एकडमी YouTube चैनल
है। यहां पे ऐसी चीज़ बढ़ रही है। उनको आप
मिलेगा। आप जब शेयर करेंगे तो उनको
मिलेगा। आप में से कई ऐसे लोग होंगे जो
काफी बड़े क्रिएटर होंगे या ऐसा भी हो
सकता है कि आप में से कई लोग के पास अच्छे
खासे फॉलोवर्स होंगे। Telegram या कहीं पे
भी चैनल होगा, ग्रुप होगा वहां शेयर किया
कीजिए। दैट वुड हेल्प। कहीं और आप ग्रुप
में एडेड हो वहां शेयर कीजिए क्योंकि ये
तो पढ़ाई की चीज है। राइट? दैट्स इट।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] और जाते-जाते
लाइक ठोकते जाना सभी लोग। यह बात याद
रखिएगा। 100 लाइक्स 100 प्लस लाइक्स करते
जाना। लाइक ठोक देना। और रिकॉर्डिंग जब
देखना हाइप का बटन मिलता है। हाइप कर दिया
करना वीडियो को। ठीक है?
या
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
प्रेम बोल रहे हैं व्हेन आई गेट माय जॉब
आई विल डेडिकेट इट टू यू सर। आई विल कीप
माय प्रॉमिस। थैंक यू वेरी मच। आई होप यू
गेट द जॉब। आई विश यू गेट द जॉब।
हु इज नितेश? नितेश नितेश नहीं यार नितेश।
इट्स इट्स नितेश। ओके सबसे पहले लाइक ठोक
दो। हां लाइक ठोक दो भाई। हाइप कैसे करते
हैं? कोई भी वीडियो रिकॉर्डिंग देखोगे ना
जब रिकॉर्डिंग देख रहे होंगे। अभी नहीं
लाइव में नहीं आएगा। तो उसके नीचे में
थोड़ा सा ना एक हाइप का बटन आता है। हाइप
दिस वीडियो। पॉइंट्स होते हैं। 500 पॉइंट,
1000 पॉइंट ऐसे कुछ करके आता है। तो हाइप
पे करोगे पॉइंट्स। ओके कंफर्म करोगे आपका
कुछ नहीं जाएगा। वो हाइप हो जाएगी। वीडियो
प्रमोट होती है। YouTube उसको रिकमेंड
करता है आगे चलके।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अ आई हैड अ डाउट। आई एम वर्किंग इन द
फील्ड ऑफ़ नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी एंड फायर
वॉल्स। शुड आई स्टार्ट दिस सीरीज और शुड
आई स्टिक टू माय फील्ड? आपको फील्ड चेंज
करना है तो आप स्टार्ट कीजिए। बट अगर आपको
उसी में रहना है तो जस्ट फॉर नॉलेज जस्ट
फॉर। दैट्स इट।
ठीक है? आई होप यू गॉट द आंसर। इफ यू वांट
टू चेंज द फील्ड, इफ यू वांट टू चेंज द
डोमेन देन डेफिनेटली यू कैन स्टार्ट द
फील्ड। क्योंकि आप मुझे यह नहीं पता है कि
नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी डोमेन में आपको कितना
इंटरेस्ट है। आप कितना इंटरेस्ट दिखाते
हैं। आपको कितना मजा आता है। अगर मजा आता
है तो आप उस डोमेन को कंटिन्यू कीजिए। अगर
मजा नहीं मजा अगर नहीं आ रहा है तो आप
स्विच कर सकते हैं इसको फॉलो करके। दैट्स
नॉट एन इशू। ठीक है? सब मजे की बात है।
अगर आपको नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी में ही मजा आ
रहा है, यू डोंट नीड टू स्विच। अगर आपको
वहां से लग रहा है कि अरे यार अब मजा नहीं
आ रहा है, तो यू कैन स्विच। ठीक है? है बट
नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी इज़ मोस्ट थोड़ा ज्यादा
इंटरेस्टिंग चीज मुझे लगता है। द वे यू
एक्सप्लेन कॉनंसेप्ट्स इज़ आउटस्टैंडिंग।
थैंक यू वेरी मच तनवीर।
सर हाउ वी गेट बेटर जॉब वो भी बताऊंगा
मैं। ट्रेन इस ट्रेनिंग को खत्म होने दो।
सब सिखाऊंगा। सब बताऊंगा आपको। टेंशन नहीं
लेना। इस ट्रेनिंग को खत्म होने दो पहले।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ग्रेट सेशन
एज एज ऑलवेज। थैंक यू वेरी मच। चलिए ओके
गाइस देन इट्स टाइम टू एंड द सेशन टॉप
फैंस की लिस्ट मैं आपको यहां पे दिखा देता
हूं एज यूजुअल यहां पे जो लोग मुझे दिख
रहे हैं ऑलमोस्ट सारी क्लासेस में
प्रेजेंट रहते ही हैं एंड आई रियली रियली
हैप्पी कि आप लोग कम से कम रेगुलर रहते
हैं एंड आज तो लगभग 50 लोग थे लास्ट लास्ट
तक जो जनरली नहीं होता है इतने लंबे सेशन
में नहीं होता है बट लगता है आज काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग लगा है तो दे वर देयर राइट
बहुत अच्छा इसमें एक करके हैं विदिश
बिदिशा डे कुछ करके हैं इनका अच्छा नोट्स
वगैरह आता है। इनका अच्छे अपडेट्स वगैरह
आते हैं। एंड गुड जॉब आपने इतना अच्छे आप
नोट्स वगैरह डालते हो। अ मैं देखता हूं
मैं तो सबके देखता हूं नोट्स जो भी Lindin
पे मेन पॉइंट्स मैंने बोला हुआ है आप
लोगों को कि एक तो वीडियो पे 100 कमेंट्स
आप पूरा कर दिया कीजिएगा जब भी कोई वीडियो
हो ताकि नेक्स्ट वीडियो आ जाए, नेक्स्ट
क्लास आ जाए। राइट?
एंड दूसरी चीज कि
एंड दूसरी चीज यह कि जो भी की पॉइंट्स
हैं, नोट्स हैं उनको शेयर किया कीजिए। आप
Lindin पे पोस्ट किया कीजिए। हमको टैग कर
दिया कीजिए। डेफोनिक्स को टैग कर दीजिए।
राइट? राइट? तो इससे एग्जैक्टली पता चल
जाता है कि आप में से कितने लोग क्या कर
रहे हैं। किस तरीके से हैं। आपके लिए भी
बेनिफिशियल वो होता है। यू कैन डू दैट।
ठीक है? तो अभी के लिए सबको शुभ रात्रि।
गुड नाइट टू एवरीबॉडी। थैंक यू वेरी मच
फॉर जॉइनिंग द सेशन। नेक्स्ट सेशन में
जल्दी मिलते हैं। उसके बाद लinक्स खत्म
देन हमारा एक और सेशन लinक्स खत्म। उसके
बाद फिर तो एसओसी की जो बची है चीजें वो
शुरू एंड फिर वो खत्म। फिर आपका यह पूरा
का पूरा ट्रेनिंग एज प्रॉमिस जैसे मैंने
करा था वो खत्म हो जाएगी। राइट सभी को
टाटा बाय-ब हां जी। हां जी। राम-राम। टाटा
नमस्ते। गुड नाइट। शुभ रात्रि।